Swift is a popular programming language
often used for creating iOS apps this is
the perfect course for learning Swift
vandad teaches this course he currently
works as a lead iOS Developer and he's
created many popular courses
hi everyone and welcome to this course
my name is vandon and I'm a senior full
stack developer from Sweden
in this course we're going to talk about
Swift as a programming language without
blending in Mac OS or iOS or back-end
development we're going to talk about
variables constants structures enums
classes you name it even modern futures
of Swift as a program language such as
async and await I've been doing iOS
development myself since late 2007 and
I've been using Swift since 2014 when it
came out first publicly
this course is built for people who are
already familiar with another program
language from before you don't have to
be very proficient in that language that
you're using but as long as you know the
basics it could be python typescript
JavaScript rust whatever it is but as
long as you're familiar with the basics
then you should be good to go
this video itself is part of a bigger
playlist which is available on my
YouTube channel and which you can find
just by searching for my name and this
playlist which I'm referring to is
called Full stack with Swift and the
goal of the playlist is just to get us
familiar with doing Swift development
for both front and and back end so if
throughout this course I sometimes make
references to this playlist then at
least you know what that is for
before we get started I'd really also
appreciate it if you could give me a
follow on YouTube just by searching for
my name the link to which you can find
in the description at the bottom of this
video and I'm also very active on
Twitter and Linkedin daily by publishing
tips and tricks about programming
languages and just generally informing
the public about languages such as
python typescript JavaScript rust Swift
you name it so without further Ado let's
just get started with the course
hi everyone and welcome to this chapter
of full stack with Swift in this chapter
we're going to look at all the modern
Concepts that are available in Swift as
a programming language if you've already
watched an introduction you probably
know that and that this course generally
not just this chapter but this course
generally is not for absolute beginners
so I expect you to already know another
programming language it doesn't it
doesn't really matter what it is it can
be python rust it can be typescript
JavaScript whatever as long as you know
the basics of programming languages such
as what functions and variables are then
you're good to go if you don't have that
experience from before this course
generally might be a little bit
difficult for you to follow through with
and I will do my best to explain
everything but since I I don't really
want to explain all the basics
um I think it is best that you perhaps
have a look at some guides on getting
started with another broken language
such as Python and then get started with
this course however if you haven't
worked with any other program language
from before and you're also very
talented as well and which I assume
every everybody is you might be able to
follow along with this course without
problem
so what we're gonna do now is to go
ahead and set up a playground basically
a workspace with many playgrounds in it
and playgrounds are Swift's concept of
being immediate being able to
immediately see what your changes are
doing and it will allow you to basically
run your code automatically as soon as
you make any changes to your code so
it is a very powerful way of testing
code or even creating some projects in
it you can you can create a whole
project with a playground and see the
results graphically even on the screen
so it's very very
um powerful for those of you who are
familiar for instance with flutter and
dart you already know that you can see
your changes and display it on the
screen immediately and playgrounds are
no different they're very similar
actually to how Dart and flutter work
but a little bit actually simpler I
would say because we're writing pure
code and just seeing pure text displayed
on the screen as a result of for
instance calling a function
so in order to continue with this
chapter you probably need a a Macintosh
um however what we're going to do we're
just going to use Swift foundation and
SDK in here or a library so you can
actually follow through as well on Linux
such as if you have for instance Visual
Studio code re setup and if in and
you've installed Swift you should be
able to follow through the only
difference will be that those of you who
have a Macintosh and xcode installed you
will be able to create a simple
playground and see your changes
immediately for those of you who are
following this on Linux and visual
studio code for instance you need to run
the code manually so you will need to
just type your code and then call Swift
compiler from from your terminal and
we're a console in order to run those
codes so it shouldn't be that different
so you should be able to follow along
even on a Linux machine so without
further Ado let's just go ahead and
create our workspace now I'll explain
what a workspace really is a workspace
is a collection of pro projects you
could say a collection of files and
projects it's it's really just one file
that explains the structure of a project
to xcode if you're if you're running
things on Linux so you don't have to
create a workspace you probably can't
because xcode does that and
unfortunately this xcode
um obviously xcode application creates
like a proprietary format for all of its
files kind of so not the text files but
like the workspace and project files
they are proprietary XML format which is
puzzling Y in this day and age it has to
use XML really but um
that's a different subject so if you're
following through and with the course at
home with Linux then you don't have to
create this workspace but if you're at
home with a Macintosh you need to go
ahead and create this workspace together
with me
so I'm going to bring up my extra just
enough in here so that we can see what
we're doing I'm going to go to new and
let's just say workspace
then in here let's just say Swift and
crash course YouTube okay in here and
let's just say save this workspace as
you can see it's just an empty workspace
at the moment so it doesn't have any
contents
what we're going to do then let's just
increase the size of this so it takes
the entire screen
and then we're going to go ahead in file
new and then we're going to go into a
file
and in here type playground in the
search field and add a new blank
playground okay
so the first concept that we're going to
talk about in here is going to be called
variables so let's just say variables
and I can see that our workspace was
actually just creating here without any
folder so we might be able to remedy
that before we click create our
playground let me just go ahead and open
a finder window in here so let's just go
ahead in here
you don't see actually what I'm doing
but right here is the folder then I'm
going to take a I'm going to create a
folder in here let's let's say Swift
crash course YouTube
and place this and and then we can close
our xcode place the workspace in there
and let's just double click on the
workspace to open our xcode so now all
the playgrounds that we're going to
create are going to be creating inside
that folder okay so let's go ahead and
create our variables for a playground
from scratch so file new file okay and
then in here we're going to say
playground and you can actually find
playground a little bit lower in here I
think as somewhere in here you can see
in the playground section so let's say
blank playground and let's call the
variables okay because we're going to
talk about variables now
so this is the default thing that you
can see in here and basically this is
your view you might see A Whiter screen
in here simply because well maybe you
haven't changed your themes in xcode and
that's something that you can figure out
on your own how to change themes and
exit we're not going to talk about that
okay let's clear this and instead of
importing UI kit we're going to just
import foundation and if you're watching
this course at home or wherever you're
watching this on Linux for instance then
and if you don't have a Mac OS you need
to also do the same thing just import
Foundation just create a simple Swift
file you don't have to create a
playground just click create a plain
text Dot Swift file and then import
Foundation library in here okay
foreign
foundation and Foundation includes all
the basic as its name indicates it
includes all the basics of what Swift
contains really like how strings work
how integers work all the default
operations between these different
variables and even optionals Etc so
importing foundations is one of the most
important uh things you can do basically
in your Swift file as you're as you're
getting to learn Swift
okay so let's go ahead and talk about
variables in Swift There are two
different syntaxes or keywords for
creating variables One is using a let
and the other is creating a variable
using VAR so let and VAR the difference
between these is very confusing for some
people and that they think that let
creates immutability and VAR creates a
mutability
however the only thing different between
these two is that a let variable cannot
be assigned to again whereas a VAR can
be assigned to again
and there are some other small
differences between them such I mean we
will actually look at those things and
when we're working with classes for
instance or structures how they differ
from each other and but for now just
know that let's cannot be assigned to
again and far can be assigned to a game
but also keep in mind that there are
some other small differences between
them which we'll explain okay so let's
go ahead in here and say let's my name
and then we say equal to Lambda for
instance and then we say let your name
is Foo okay after you've done these and
created these two variables you cannot
assign to them again simply because
there are less variables so let's say my
name is your name and if we go down here
at the bottom of the screen you can see
my mouse and I'm going to hold on this
button so I'm just going to press my
track path and then say automatically
run and this will just ensure that this
playground will be automatically
executed anytime we change anything in
it okay you can see the error it says
that cannot assign the value my name is
a let constant so that's how you know
that you cannot assign to it again after
creating a let constant you just need to
leave it you don't have to you you can't
basically assign a new value to it okay
so that's how let's works now let's go
ahead and create a variable so for now
we're just going to create a simple
array and already assume that you know
what arrays are but we're going to talk
about collections a little bit later
just know that in Swift you create an
array with this syntax with square
brackets okay so let's say VAR names is
we're going to say Mining and your name
okay so we just created an array in here
and you can then see the results to the
right hand side you can see this array
contains van Dot and a foo okay
now you can go ahead then and say since
this is a variable then it can be
mutated even internally if it contains
for instance a structure so we say names
and then we can call an append function
on it and we say bar and then we can
also add baths to it as you can see in
here so by the end of this then our
array called names contains found.foobar
and bass however if you change this to a
let you will see that we'll get some
errors in here saying that this is a let
constant cannot use mutating member on
immutable value names now this goes to
this goes a little bit deeper in how
let's mvar are different from each other
but in order to understand that we need
to understand what structures are
because arrays in Swift by default are
structures if you're not using old
Objective C arrays for instance so just
know that by creating a variable array
you can append to it and you can remove
stuff from it for instance as we'll see
later however if this is let you cannot
mutate even the internal values inside
it so you can see there are two
mutability concepts in in Swift one is
that you can actually mutate this array
for instance you can say names is
completely equal to another variable
like the law okay
so you can see all of a sudden it became
blah blah bar bass you see so this is
mutating the variable itself it is
actually assigned a complete new array
to names as a variable and these two
statements are mutating what is inside
this variable so doing a let in here
prevents both assigning a new value to
names and also mutating names
however having a VAR you can assign a
new variable two names and you can also
mutate names internally okay so this is
another difference between let and VAR
so it is also very very important to
understand these two differences
mutation of the variable internally and
assigning a new value to the variable to
mutate it so a lot of developers
struggle with that especially in the
beginning so I completely understand if
it is a little bit difficult to start
with but the earlier you learn this
concept the better because otherwise I
think a swift can become quite difficult
for for you to understand going forward
so spend some time and experiment with a
let's and VAR but we will have quite a
lot of examples in this chapter so you
don't have to do it on your own okay
so
now if you change a variable like if
you've created a variable and you assign
a new value to it and it won't it won't
change the object that it originally was
assigned to now I will explain what that
actually means so let's say let's Foo
let's create another space in here let's
say Foo is foop and then we say VAR Foo
2 is equal to foop like this okay you
can see now this variable of food 2
contains the value inside Foo all right
and you can see both of them contain the
string Foo now if you go ahead and set
the value of Foo 2 to for instance Foo 2
like this you can see that Foo and futu
still contain the values that you'd
expect Foo contains food and food 2
contains the new value so by assigning a
new value to Food 2 which was previously
equal to Foo you're not overwriting the
value that was inside Foo simply because
this is referring to this
and the reasoning behind this is that
we're working with something called
value types now I will explain more
value types later but all you need to
know for now is that by assigning the
value of Foo to Foo to we're simply
copying this value over to futu
so this value is being completely copied
and you're creating a new instance of it
inside food too so now we have two Foos
inside memory by this point
so we're not getting a reference so it's
not a reference type that we're talking
about
Swift has value types and reference
reference types for those of you who are
not familiar with this concept from
before don't worry about it I'll explain
it more in details but for those of you
who are familiar with this concept just
know that
structures which are basic basically as
Swift string is a type of structure
it in structures are basically value
types and then we also have classes and
which are reference types and we'll
explain all of these later in the future
but just know that by assigning a value
that was assigned to a variable would
let assigning it to a variable like this
with VAR and then changing the value of
that variable and assigning a new value
to that variable you're not changing the
value that was assigned to that variable
initially I know that I mean this the
sentence is a little bit complicated but
I think I think you get my points in
here what I'm trying to say okay
now we can have a look at another
example of this and how that looks so
let's go ahead and say let's more names
and let's create an array in here and
then we say Foo and then a bar okay
then let's let's say we create a copy of
it we say a copy is more names and
simply because this is a let's variable
and also that we're working with a swift
array which is a structure then we
should know that structures are value
types and assigning the value of a
structure to another let's variable in
here creates a copy of this entire array
for us okay so now that we have sorry
let's make this a copy variable
basically let's now go and add some
value to this cop a copied variable and
say append and we say Bas all right and
then we say let's get the value of more
names and then the copy you can see more
names in here still contains Foo and bar
which were the original values however
they copied the variable now contains
bass as you can see in here so adding
Beth to this copy did not change the
values that were inside more names and
this again goes back to how swift is
working with value types in here it is
copying over the contents of more names
into this copy variable and changing
this variable's internal data does not
affect the original data which it was
assigned to in the beginning okay so
hopefully that makes sense by now
now one thing that can be a little bit
confusing for developers is when when
they're working with let M VAR but with
old Objective C classes all right and
this this can be a little bit strange to
start with like a lot of developers who
are not so familiar with swift would say
that let creates immutable variables so
you cannot change them internally
however if you're working with a let's
variable with a let constant for
instance in Swift however that that its
internal value is an instance of a class
that class can mutate internally without
this letter variable getting in the way
let's have a look at an example
for those of you who are familiar with
Objective C you know that there is a
class inside Swift
which is called NS mutable array now if
you just want to learn Swift you don't
at all need to know about this it is
simply for those of you who are a little
bit curious about let's and VAR okay I'm
just going to demonstrate this to you
but please if you're not completely
understanding this example it is
completely fine chances are if you're
working with Swift and you're learning
Swift swift UI and even if you're
working with UI kit for instance you
create your UI applications for iOS Mac
OS whatever
chances are you may not really be using
the this uh thing that I'm gonna show
you at all or maybe you'll use it once
or twice in your entire career and more
and more Swift gets modern less and less
we're going to use these classes so but
for those of you who are Mac Developers
for instance you probably actually work
with NS Mutual array perhaps often okay
if you especially if you have an old
code base
so let's create a constant in here where
we say let's old array and we create an
NS mutable array in here okay
and then in here we say that the value
is an array okay and then we say the
array contains the values of Foo and bar
like this okay then you can see in here
that Swift playground says old array as
Foo and bar right and you see oh this is
let so we cannot change its internal
values because if you for instance have
a look at this one an array again okay
which is created with let if you say
more names and you say append and you
say hello you will see that you will get
an error in here it will tell you that
you cannot append to this variable
because it's created with a let
statement or a let's syntax okay over in
here since we're creating a let's old
array that is equal to a class instance
which is not a structure and again I
completely understand that we haven't
talked about classes and structures yet
but just know that this is not and this
is basic as its name indicates it is
mutable internally it can be changed
whether it is assigned to a let or a VAR
it doesn't make any difference it is a
class whereas this is a structure okay
and structures are value types and
classes are reference types okay so just
know that for now that this is indeed
mutable even if it is assigned to LED
variable okay so now all of a sudden you
can say old array and then you can say
add and let's say baz
all right and now you can see Swift
playgrounds runs this code and tells you
that indeed your let's constant what you
thought was constant has changed
internally all right now you can go
ahead and create a new verbal and we say
new array is old array
and if you say new array
add
q u x in here Cox okay and then we say
old array and we say new array
now you can see the results in here
since new array got the value of old
array
you add a new value to this new array
and you'd expect probably for new array
only to change not for old array to be
affected however you can see the result
that both old array and new array are
actually referring to the exact same
array so this can cause a lot of
confusion for developers who are for
instance new to Swift thinking that oh I
just created a let immutable variable no
one can change this however you can see
that it got changed and even worse you
can as if if you pass this value for
instance to a function
and that function itself can also change
this variable so it is quite dangerous
just by using let it's not that we're
completely getting rid of mutability in
Swift so a lot of things can go wrong
especially if you're using reference
reference types such as nsmutable array
but don't worry about it I mean if if
this is a little bit alien at the moment
I will explain this a lot more in
details later okay
as I mentioned be very careful when
you're working with mutable types in
Swift and when you're passing them for
instance to functions because those
functions can actually change your
mutable types even if they say they
don't okay so let's have a look at this
let's say we create another array in
here let's let's copy this and I'm going
to say let's some names and then we say
Foo and bar okay so that's fine let's
create a function and I completely
understand we haven't talked about
functions yet but this is this syntax of
what functions look like in Swift so we
say funk change the array and then we
have an argument call array and in here
we say NS array okay now I'll explain to
you what nsra is nsra is the um and it's
mutable array is the mutable
variant of nsra and if you actually go
to the source code for NS mutable array
let's say in its Mutual array
you can see that it's subclasses nsra so
anywhere you have an NS Mutual array and
sorry anywhere your function or call
expect and NS array you can actually
pass an instance of NS Mutual array to
its because it will just work it will be
downgraded to ns3 okay
so let's say that we look at this
function and this function just looks
like it is working with an immutable
array in here however internally it can
say let's let's just say copy as array
as in its mutable array so this is a
syntax in Swift that you shouldn't
really use that often but code can
actually do that without without getting
bugged by Swift really okay so you can
see in here we're saying we're creating
a copy
uh oh a rage array like this where we're
basically creating a variable that is
called copy however it's not really
copying the instance it's just named
copy so maybe we could just call it
array2 or something or just copy but uh
just know that it is really not copying
the value inside this or it is just
assigning it to this variable and but it
is setting its data type it's promoting
its data type to immutable data type
it's assuming that it is mutable okay
it's this is really bad code you should
never write stuff like this okay but I'm
just demonstrating that it is possible
to write code like this and you should
kind of guard yourself against code like
this and then in here we say copy dot
add Mass okay now if you pass if you
call this function change the array with
your Mutual array everything will just
work as expected some names
and then you can say some names and have
a look at the data
now when this code is run you can see in
this scope some names after being passed
to change the array has actually been
internally mutated you can see Foo bar
and pass so this pass that this function
added to this array is actually present
outside that function as well simply
because we're working again with
reference types meaning that there's one
copy of this in the memory and this
function is actually changing the
original copy okay
so that was really uh it that's what I
wanted to explain in this particular
section of the video with variables and
uh constants so just know that you have
let and you have VAR and let it if
working with value types such as
structures of Swift arrays or strings or
integers it prevents immutability of
that value internally meaning that you
can't change this van dot to for
instance say and my name my name
uh and then you can say
is equal to actually my name make
uppercase you can't do stuff like this
so you cannot and like change the value
that is assigned to this and you can't
reassign a value to my name after it has
been created okay so the reassigning
that you cannot reassign a value to a
let constant applies to both reference
types and and value type so it doesn't
matter if if the value inside this let
constant is a string or it's an instance
of a class as long as it's let you can't
assign a new value to it for instance
let's say here is you can see it is a
sum names it is an instance of a class
which is a reference type However the
fact that you cannot reassign a value to
this still holds true whether it is
holding an instance of a class or an
instance of a structure so let's say
some names is blah in here now we should
get an error in here saying that you
cannot reassign another value to this
after you have created it so this
reassigning to a let constant applies
both to reference types and value types
however the internal mutability of a
let's constant only applies the
prevention of internal mutability of a
let constant only applies to Value types
such as structures if you've assigned a
class to a let constant the class might
internally change without Swift actually
complaining at all okay so I completely
understand is a little bit complicated
and I personally believe that some other
personal languages have implemented this
a little bit more beautifully and a
little more like fluid such as rust
can I have some courses actually about
rust as well so you can watch my Ross
crash course for instance on YouTube and
learn about mutability and rust as well
but I I believe that Russ has
implemented mutably a bit nicer than
Swift and because Swift can cause some
confusion in how it handles and mutable
values but for now just know these
simple rules and then we can move on to
the next section of this video
all right now that we've talked enough
about variables let's move on to another
concept which is very very important to
learn in any programming language that
you're learning at the moment and those
are or that is operators so operators
are small functions that are a little
bit special in how they're declared and
Swift treats them as such it treats them
a little bit more special than other
functions so and let's have a look at
what operators are but before doing that
let's create a simple playground for
operators so let's say go let's say file
new and we say file if we can find it oh
we can't because we can't create a file
inside this so let's be in here inside
our editor and I'm going to say command
n and then I'm going to go ahead and
create a playground in here let's say
blank playground and then we're going to
say operators but be very careful
because by default so if playgrounds or
xcode actually tries to create this
playground inside another playground and
that is horrible it is really off full
and just please just use the main folder
to create your playground and also add
it to the main
xcode workspace structure as well in
here so let's say create
now we have operators and let's do the
same thing in here I want to say import
Foundation okay
after doing this let's start talking
about
operators so let's create two constants
in here let's say my age and we say 22
and we say let your age is 20 okay
now let's work with our first two
operators and those are the greater than
and less than operators if you have two
integers like this and I kind of expect
you to already know what an integer is
from other program language perhaps that
you already know then we say if my age
then once you have two integers you can
use this particular operator that you
can see it says greater than so the left
side should be greater than the right
side your age and your age and this is
an if statement okay which I kind of
already actually I kind of expect you to
already know what if statements are so
you can see now we're using an if
statement and then and putting our left
hand side and right hand side variables
in here and using operator which is
having this kind of a syntax so what
this operator is doing is comparing the
value to the left with the value to the
right and it Returns the value of true
if the value to the left is indeed
greater than the value to the right okay
and here then we can say I'm older than
you okay and then we say else if my H is
less than your H so this is another
operator that works between integers for
instance that says it will I will return
true if the value to the left is less
than the value to the right then in here
we say I'm younger than you and else oh
hey we are the same age okay so if I'm
not older than you and I'm not younger
than you then we should be the same age
logically all right you can see nothing
is happening in this playground because
we don't have automatic running so I'm
just gonna hold my trackpad on this
button and then I'm gonna say
automatically run and then you can see
that our code is going to run in here
and the value basically we got into this
branch of our if statement I'm older
than you simply because this operator
indicated to Swift that the value to the
left is indeed uh larger than the value
to the right return the value of true
and then Swift fell into this if
statement so that's these two are the
first operators that we're seeing in
Swift basically however I mean there are
some other very special operators such
as the equal operator that we're seeing
in here but we shouldn't really go ahead
and explaining that we're simply
assigning a value to a variable in here
with that operator okay
now there are other operators such as
Plus for instance let's say let my
mother's age is my age plus 30. so this
is a an operator that is operating
between two integers I can from the left
hand side and a right hand side so it
simply takes
the value to the left and adds the value
to the right to it and then returns that
result to us okay
so that's another operator that we're
seeing in here the plus operator you can
also of course use for instance the
multiplication operator and we can say
let's double
and double my age is my H and you say
times two and as you can see this is an
operator that is sitting between two
integers again it takes the integer to
the left and and multiplies it by the
integer to the right and Returns the
value and which then gets assigned to
this variable you can see it's 44. if
you remember the age was set to 22 times
2 is 44.
so you've probably now seen a few
operators in here and you're wondering
okay how many different types of
operators are there and there are three
different types of operators in Swift
and I mean not I'm not counting these
operators I'm just talking about three
different types of operators okay
the first one is called a unary prefix
the second one is called a unary postfix
and the third one is called a binary
infix okay so when we're talking about
unary as you remember let's actually
write them down let's just say uh one is
unary urinary prefix the second one is
urinary postfix and then the third one
is binary infix okay
wherever you're seeing unary just know
that this thing is working with only one
value again working with one value and
binary is working with two values okay
so you can now imagine that this
operator the multiplication operator
that is working with two values is
indeed a binary in fix it is binary
because it's working with two values the
left and the right hand side and it is
an infix operator because it's sitting
in between so infix in between okay it's
sitting in between two other values so
all the operators that we've seen so far
the greater than or less than
basically addition and multiple
multiplication are binary infix
operators we haven't seen a unary and Sr
unary prefix and unitary postfix so
let's have a look at unary prefix as
you'd expect unary Works only with one
value so let's say let's Foo is true so
this is just assigning the value of true
to Foo however if you want to change the
value of this true to false and you want
to flip it basically you use this
operator in here which is the apostrophe
operator which is a unary prefix
operator that takes the value to its
right hand side and basically
um negates it okay so you can see in
here true became false simply like that
so this is a unary prefix it's prefix
because it's before the value that comes
right after it okay
then we have a urinary post fix so a
unary postfix offer is a little bit
special I mean in all my years of
working with swift I've been working
with swift since summer of 2014. it is
very very seldom that you create your
own post-fix operator and you want to
read postfix There are some unitary
postfix operators already it's built
into Swift but and you use them perhaps
quite a lot however creating your own
postfix uh unary postsex operator is
something that you do very very seldom
okay
let's have a look at a unary postfix
operator let's say name
and I'm just going to create an optional
value now I know we haven't talked about
optionals but just for the purpose of
demonstrating what a unary postfix
operator is let's go ahead and write
this syntax let's say optional and then
we say rendered okay
now if you want to grab the value that
is inside this variable and unwrap it we
say let unary
postfix is equal to name and then we put
this apostrophe after this name now just
know for now that what the what we did
in here is that we put an optional value
into a variable call name an optional
simply means that this name can either
contain null values or it can contain a
value that's what optionality in Swift
means but I've prepared a completely
separate playground for optionals which
we're going to talk about a little bit
later however this you can see now it
goes ahead into this optional value and
grabs the internal value and assigns it
to this okay so let's say if we inherit
say type of name and then we can type of
unary postfix now they have two
different types you can see the type of
this variable is an optional string and
the type of this variable is indeed a
string so this unary postfix operator
went inside this optional and grabbed
its value out and forced it out and
assign it to the variable to the left
hand side basically using the assign
assignments operator
so this is a unary postfix operator it
comes after a variable and it works only
with one variable so it doesn't have a
variable here and a variable there it is
only working with the Val and the
variable to its left hand side okay
prefix unary prefix works with the value
after it post or postfix works with the
value before it okay so that's the
second example basically for unary
postfix
now for the last type of operator which
is the most common type and we call them
binary infix simply because they work
with two values hence the name binary
and also infix simply because they sit
in between the values that they work on
okay so let's say a result is one plus
two and this is a simple example of a
binary infix operator you can see it's
working with two values and sits in
between them okay
and other another example is let's say
let names is equal to Foo
and then we say plus empty space plus
bar and this is another
um
infix binary
operator that is sitting between two
strings you can see you may be a little
bit confusing you can say oh but if this
is sitting between these two strings
what is this sitting in between is it a
prefix operator well it is not what is
happening here is that Swift is
executing this code from the left hand
side because there is no parenthesis
then it says okay Foo plus empty space
becomes Foo plus like empty space like
this and then takes this plus and uses
it in between the result of the previous
statement and Bar
okay so that's what is happening inside
this code basically
okay so that was an example of a binary
infix operator and as I mentioned most
operators that you use in Swift are
going to be binary and fix there are
quite a lot of actually other operators
as well but we don't use them so often
okay depends again also on your code
base
now there is another category of
operators and which is called a ternary
operator okay and ternary is something
that is a kind of a Hot Topic in any
programming language that supports
ternary simply because it can be misused
and it can cause your code to look very
very difficult to read actually so
um what I suggest oops what I think is a
good idea is always a check with your uh
with your teammates who are working with
your colleagues basically in your team
and ask them if if they're comfortable
with ternary and if they're if there are
what are the
um what are the boundaries that they
that they feel comfortable using ternary
operators within ternary can become very
complicated especially if you're nesting
them if you're using a ternary inside
iternary and it's just good to check
with people what they're comfortable
with okay but let's just have a look at
a ternary operator let's say let's a H
is 30. now let's say that you want to
display a message to the user saying
that let's message and then you want to
say if the age is over or equal to 18
then this message should say you are an
adult however if the age is less than 18
then you should say you are not yet an
adult
how do you do this well what you could
do is to say let's message is a string
okay
uh and then you could say if
H is more than or equal to 18 then
message is you are an adult
otherwise message as you are not yet an
adult so this works actually very well
and you can type the message out you can
see now it says you are not all simply
because the H is 30 or if you were 16 it
would say you are not an adult yet or
you're not yet an adult
however there's another way of writing
the same exact code so let's just
comment this out okay and that is using
the ternary operator so in here you can
see we've defined our variable first and
then we're going using an if statement
and an else statement and then assigning
values to that variable okay however you
can also say let's message is then you
would put your condition in here you say
condition
okay
and then the format is then you put a
question mark then you say value if
condition
is met
and then so let's put this to the next
line and then a colon in here and value
if the condition is not met
so this is the format of a ternary
operator first you put your condition in
here so what is the condition so if the
age is more than or equal to 18 so just
let's just write it age should be more
than or equal to 18. then we say that
the value should be you are an adult
then the value if the condition is not
bad is you are not yet an adult and that
is exactly how you write a ternary
operator so you say you take your
variable that you want to actually
calculate the value of then you say it's
equal to then you put the condition of
your ternary operator and then a
question mark after a question mark
follows the value that you want to
assign to your variable
should the condition be met and then a
colon and the value that you want to
assign to the variable should the
condition not have been met okay and you
can see now the messages you are an
adult and if you change this value again
to 17 you can see the value will be
changed to you're not yet an adult okay
so
I hope that you've now got an idea of
some operators in Swift you've we've had
a look at different types of operators
in unary prefix unary postfix we have
binary infix and we've also looked at a
fourth category of operators which are
ternary operators and again just be a
little bit careful with ternary
operators because not a lot of
developers are actually very comfortable
using these I met I personally like
ternary especially like in these cases
where is less code is understandable
it's compact is not so much logic
however some developers just write them
all in one line like this and that can
be a little bit difficult to read I I
actually agree my uh habits in Swift is
to manually
break my code down into smaller bits and
pieces like this into different lines as
well
unfortunately unlike some other
programming languages like rust and dart
and there is no internal analyzer as
such sorry there are no formatter so
Swift Code you need to format it by hand
unfortunately and it has been
eight years since Swift's come out and
there is still no internal formatter for
Swift of course you can select your code
and then indent your code with Ctrl I in
xcode
but you cannot have xcode format of your
code for you as you type so that is a
little bit of an unfortunate problem
that we have to deal with but it is what
it is and we can just get used to it so
if you want to make your code a little
bit more readable I suggest that you
format it a little bit by hand so kind
of handcrafted as well okay
that was really it for the operators so
in the next section we're gonna look at
if an else statement so see you there
now that we're done with operators let's
go ahead and create a new playground or
if and else so right here I'm going to
press command n
on MacIntosh and let's say playground in
here oops if I can spell it and a blank
playground
and let's just call it if
else
and please just ensure that you're not
creating it
inside an existing playground you can
see in here it's called operators and we
should change that to be inside our main
folder basically okay and then we say it
shouldn't be inside the operators group
either it should be inside the group op
ARP workspace so create now we can
collapse the other ones and in here just
like normal we say foundation not like
normal actually like usual I meant to
say
so let's talk about if and else
statements we've already seen a few
examples of if and else and if you've
already done programming in another
programming language you should already
be familiar with what if and else
statements are so it's just a
conditional basically okay let's add a
few values in here so I'm just going to
copy and paste some values and place
them in here so some seed values that we
can work with Okay let's create a simple
if statement and then if sorry an if an
else statement so we say if my name is
equal equal valid so in here
so like this and so this is using a
lowercase v as you can see in here okay
then we say your name is and then we're
going to add our variable within a
string and this is how you do it in so
if you say back backslash and then
parenthesis and then you say my name in
here okay
then in here we can say else and with no
conditions in front of it and then we
say oops
I guessed I guessed it wrong like this
and then let's do an automatic run for
our playground and we should now come to
the oops part because we guessed the
name incorrectly with a lowercase v as
you can see in here so this is a simple
if statement so you compare something
with uh with something else and then you
can have an else block or not you can
actually just have an if statement as
well so you don't have to have an else
Block in Swift okay
now you're not limited in you're not
limited only to one else statement you
can't have else if as well okay so let's
just say if
my name my name is equal equal land up
with the proper spelling as well with a
capital V then we say now I guessed it
correctly okay
and then we say else if
my name
is Foo now you can see that we have
another Branch so we have an if and then
if that case is not met then the program
will fall into this statement so it's
very important to understand that it's
not that Swift is executing both of
these concurrently it's executing the
first one first if that condition is met
then Swift goes in here and ignores
everything all the other statements
inside the if statements so all the
other else ifs and the last L statement
if it is available so it's just
branching basically okay
so if my name is Foo as we say are you
Foo and this doesn't really matter what
you type in here I'm just trying to
demonstrate how if and else if basically
statements work in Swift and then we can
have a final else statement in here and
says okay I give up okay
and you can see that Swift has gone into
this Branch because name was correctly
set to Van Dot and we're comparing it
with vandan sorry it wasn't set to Vanda
I mean it was set in here but we're
actually comparing it correctly with the
correct value in here okay and some
people write their if statements a
little bit more in like what I call a
flipped way and here you can see we're
saying if my name is equal to Vandal and
so if you're reading it like you would
read an English sentence I would say if
my name is equal to valid however some
people actually do it in the opposite
way like this they would say if van dot
is equal to mining so this is another
way of writing it an uncommon way of
doing this and a lot of old and like a
little bit old school developers would
do stuff like this it is not so common
in all my years of working as a software
engineer I've seen one or two people
preferring this however
me and my colleagues have been able to
convince them otherwise that this is
this we shouldn't do this in most modern
Source codes don't do this however you
may be an exception in so maybe you're
working at a company where this is the
prevalent way of doing if statements in
that you actually put the value and that
you and are testing
um last and then you compare with the
value and that you're expecting first as
I said this is a little bit uncommon in
my experience but maybe at the company
that you are you and your teammates have
decided that this is the way to do it it
is completely equal to this it is the
same thing as this code and I mean what
it achieves is the same however the
syntax is a little bit different okay so
it is up to you and your teammates to
decide what which way to do however
if you're new to Swift I beg you to
please don't do this and it is this way
that you should learn how to write your
if statements so please don't flip these
values however if you're a seasoned
developer and you know exactly what
you're doing and you and your teammates
have decided that in your code base all
your if statements should be written
like this or in just a few exception
cases you write your code like this as
long as you've checked with your team is
and everything is fine then you go ahead
and do it but if you're learning Swift
just now this is the way to write an if
statement okay and this is the way that
almost everyone writes their if
statements seasoned or not seasoned
good so that was simple these are some
simple if statements basically comparing
a value with another value but what if
you are having a little bit more
complicated logic in here
so let's say that you want to make sure
that your name is found out and that
your age is also 30. so you can see the
age is defined in here as 20. let's just
go ahead and compare it with 30 instead
let's say if my name
and in here if you want to compare also
the age you can say and
my age is 30 for instance okay then we
say name is landlord and age is 30. then
we say else if a my age is 20 then we
say I only guess the age right and then
an else statement in here we can say I
don't
know what I'm doing okay so as you'd
expect now we're going to go into this
line of code so what's happening here is
that Swift started executing this code
from left to right and I said okay from
left the name is truly vandot and it
started comparing the age and that says
age is indeed 20 is not 30 so I'm not
going to go into this if statement so it
ignores this if then it looks at the
code that follows this if statement and
says oh it's an else otherwise if the
age is 20 is the age 20 yes it is then
it falls into this statement and then
ignores the rest of the else
so you need to think of if statements as
in branches and they get executed
separately not concurrently and they're
basically in a Serial order from the
first statement if it fails goes to the
next statement then goes to the next
statement if any of these statements
succeed in trapping the logic so this
one trapped and said okay if the age is
20 and in it is indeed then the code
goes in here if any of these else
statements or if statements do that the
entire rest of this code is then ignored
so this didn't fall into so this we
didn't fall into this we did fall into
this and then the rest is completely
ignored regardless of how many else's
you have in here you can say else if
blah blah and then another else after
that but all of those will be ignored
okay
now just like we have the an operator in
here the logical and operator we also
have the or operator okay but you need
to be careful with it because you can
actually make the code and do things
that you didn't want it to do so let me
just explain something in here
so let's write an example let's say if
my H is 20 not 200 or my name is Foo
then we say either age is 20 name is Foo
or both
so what happening here is that you can
see we say you may be reading this
saying either the age is 20 or the name
is Foo but what Swift does reading here
says either the name at the age is 20 or
the name is who or both of these so even
if both of these are true then this code
is executed and the reason behind that
is that if your age is 20 then the code
actually comes here just by default it
doesn't even execute the rest
okay so that is the reason that if age
is 20 your name might indeed be Foo and
that is what you've written in here but
the code has already fallen into this
simply because the first part of the
condition was met so Swift doesn't even
execute this part it says oh ages 20 of
course let's go in here okay simply
because Swift looks at the statement app
versus oh said or so I don't have to
execute it simply because I already know
that my age is 20 so it falls here okay
so it can be either this part this one
or both
animistics and developers make is they
think that they can add another else
Block in here and that else block will
be executed as well and that is not the
case because as I've explained it before
if statements are zero and they get
executed one at a time if any of them
traps the
um the execution of the program meaning
that it actually results to the compiler
understanding that oh this branch of
code should be executed then the rest
will be ignored so if in here you type
else if my name is Van dot even if your
condition is met which in this case is
because my name is truly vandad or my
age is 30 I started 20 which it was set
up here if you remember
my name and my age were van dot and20
respectively this code will not be
executed so let's say it's too late to
get in this class you can see that it
won't be executed it won't be displayed
in here only this branch is executed
simply because my age was 20. okay and I
can change it actually to Foo and you
can see it still gets here first because
my age is 20 and the operator after that
is a logical or meaning that oh if this
or this or both and it's since this one
is true it doesn't even have to execute
this okay
so
as I mentioned yeah or can actually or
an and logical operators they can get
quite complicated in that if you're if
you're working with these operators and
also parenthesis then you could create
kind of confusing code as well and if
you actually don't use parenthesis
sometimes your logic could be completely
incorrect let me just show you an
example
let's write a coding here and we say if
my name is landlord
and then we go to the next line and we
say and my age is 22.
okay
then we go to the next line and your
name is Foo and remember
my name is my age is 20. your name is
Foo at your age is 19. okay then here
we're saying your name is who and we
know that that is true in fact
or your age
is 19. okay so we say and what is this
code actually doing so we say my name is
Found Love
and I'm 22 and your name is Foo
Foo
or
you are 19. do you see what happening
here so what happened was that and you
can see that this message actually is
printed here in our playground meaning
that the code did fall into this as into
this execution Branch so what happened
you can say that my name is Vanda and my
age is 22 but you can say well your age
is not 22. how did this code come here
and the reason is because we're mixing
ands and ores and you can see what what
Swift reads in here says okay if your
name is Van Dot
and your age is 22.
and your name is Foo is this true then
looks at all these ants this is yeah
your name is but your age is not 22.
then it looks at the rest that it could
and says do I have any other logic to
follow and it says yes actually you've
written it here either these
or that your age should be 19 and it
looks at your age so uh Yes actually
your age is 19. so you can see how this
could be confusing for you reading this
you may think oh your name should be
vandot and your age should be 22 and
your name should be Foo or your age
should be 90 so you may think that this
part is executed separately and this
part is separate but since there's no
parenthesis between these Swift reads it
from left to right and then there's no
uh precedence between the ands and ores
so they have the same precedence so it
says okay this entire thing is the same
precedence and I just execute it from
left to right
and this or at the end basically traps
the execution branch and ensures that
the code falls into the if statement
okay so writing code like this could be
a little bit confusing what you might
have wanted to write is this instead
you probably wanted to say if and then
parenthesis okay
and then this is your own logic so you
want to basically check your name and
age so let's put it inside parenthesis
so we say my name is founded
and let's go to the next slide and
my age should be 22 so you're basically
saying and so you say my name is Vandal
and my http 22. then you go to the next
line and you say and and another
parenthesis your name
is Foo
or your age is 19. like this okay so
what is happening in here is uh and I
can see our playground has some problem
so what this really equates to I mean if
you want to read it in English you could
say my name is founded and I'm 22.
and
your name is Foo
or you are 19. so do you see how this is
differences your name and my name is Van
Dot and I am 22 so this condition should
be met and so should this because we are
using an and meaning that not only this
condition should be met but also this
condition then it says okay well this
condition is met because your name is
Vandal and your age is 20 actually
oops we have 20 here so that's that's
interesting so so we wrote 22 that's
fine I mean let's let it actually be
like this so it says my name is Vandal
and my age is 22 so it says oh this is
not met okay so as soon as this is not
met and this is an and statement it says
oh I don't have to execute any of this
now because I know that the left hand
side of the and operator and The Logical
operator is not exec is not true so I'm
not even going to execute this okay then
if we put an else Block in here
then we can say hmm and let's say hmm
that didn't work so well okay so if you
put parenthesis between these and you
can see that the logic becomes a little
bit clean clear so and we can change
this actually and we say let's say or
okay and now all of a sudden you can see
that this block of code is executed
simply because either this should be
true or this or both of them and since
this part is not true it comes here it
says your name is for indeed and your
age is 19. do you remember H was 19 and
name was Foo then it executes this code
simply because one of these branches is
true either this or this or both and we
know that that this is true so it
executes this code so
usually you don't write code actually
like this thankfully in Swift usually
your code should make more sense inside
your if statements and you shouldn't
have too many branches like this with
ands and ORS and parentheses but
sometimes if you have very complicated
code if you're working with low-level
Logic for instance At Your Service layer
you might write code like this so you
should be ready to kind of be able to
handle and read this type type of code
but I completely understand it it is a
little bit complicated to look at it if
you're just looking at it like this and
usually code like this is prefix with
some common explaining why we're doing
things the way we're doing them okay
so that was it for our if and else
playground in the next section we're
gonna talk about functions so we can
create a separate playground basically
for functions after working with if and
else statements we can go ahead now and
work with functions we've seen a few
examples of functions in Swift before
and hopefully you already know what
functions are so we don't have to go too
much into details with functions but
let's go ahead and explore some
possibilities that we have with
functions in Swift so command n in xcode
or if you're in Visual Studio code I
think also command n and or control n on
Linux and we are going to just search
for playground in here playground and
let's say blank playground in here and
let's call it functions and then let's
create it inside the main group and
inside the main folder okay and I think
would be perhaps a little bit better if
we change the size in here so I'm going
to go to themes in Midnight which I'm
using I'm going to select all of these
and then let's just change the font size
perhaps to let's just say 36 perhaps or
even yeah 30 36 I think is good enough
so we see the code a little bit better
okay
so with functions in Swift you have the
same possibilities as you have in many
other programming languages such as
Python and dart and typescript
JavaScript pretty much all the modern
programming languages have some kind of
same syntax and functionality for
functions so let's have a look at a few
examples so let's say we import
Foundation
I'm gonna get rid of that part to the
left or Explorer so we can create
functions in Swift with the func syntax
or a keyword and then the name of the
function and it should be camel case
meaning that the first word of the
function name should all be lowercase on
all the subsequent words inside the
function name should have or their first
letter as uppercase and all the other
letters as lowercase so here is an
example of a function that takes no
arguments and it has no return value so
let's say no arguments and no return
value you can see all the if the first
word has all its letters as lowercase
and all the other words have their first
letters as uppercase that follow the
first word okay
then we put uh parenthesis in here and
we can put our arguments in between the
parenthesis but this function doesn't
have any arguments then we do curly
brackets and then inside the curly
brackets is the body of your function
and here we're just going to say I don't
have I don't know what I'm doing okay
and the way that we write these things
in playground is a little bit special
because in Swift playgrounds whatever
you type as the string will actually be
printed inside the playground's preview
however this is not how you would
actually write Swift Code so you would
probably just issue a print statement
okay but in playgrounds this does make
sense so let's just do automatically run
in here so our code gets executed
automatically without us having to do
anything and you can see nothing is
being printed here simply because we're
not calling or invoking our function now
the process of invoking a function is
just to tell to tell Swift that you want
the code inside this function to be
executed and the way to do that is just
you use the function name no arguments
and then with the parenthesis and any
arguments that the function expects
within the parenthesis now thankfully
this function doesn't have any arguments
so we don't have to pass any arguments
within the parenthesis either and you
can see the value is then printed to our
playground console in here okay now we
can also have functions that have
arguments so let's create a function
that takes any integer value and adds
the value of 2 to it but this particular
function is not going to have any return
value again so we're just going to have
a look at how to pass arguments to a
function so let's say func plus two so
like this and then we take a value and
you can see this is how you specify an
argument to a function in Swift you just
type name of the argument and then you
type the data type and also there's
another way of doing this and I'll
explain it later and you can have two
labels for a variable one an external
label and an internal label which is
something
quite unique to Swift you can have it in
some other languages but not in all so
here's an example of a function that
internally creates a new variable let's
call it new value and then takes that
value and adds a 2 to it with a unary
with a binary infix operator as we've
seen before
but you can see that it doesn't return
anything okay and we can say plus two
and then we can pass the value of 30 in
here and you can see new value will be
equal to 32 within this function all
right so that's how you can basically
pass a variable to a function using an
argument
you can have functions that return
values as well so they do some
calculation and then they return a value
and the way to do that is to use this
particular syntax as I'll show you now
let's say new plus 2 and then we take a
value of type integer and we return a
value in here and then we can just say
we return the value of
value basically plus two and the return
statements in these simple functions
that just have one line of code is
optional this is something that Swift
has taken from rust however rust takes
it to an entirely new level in that rust
allows even for you to type some more
code in here and then the last statement
inside the function that doesn't have a
semicolon will be returned however Swift
doesn't have that ability so because
semicolons are optional in Swift so if
you don't want to have a return value in
here if you don't want to type the
return syntax in here or keyword you're
more than welcome to do that the most
modern code actually emits return so if
you see a statement like this this
function is set to return this statement
implicitly all right and the way to call
it is that you can say new plus two and
then you pass the value of 30 and you
can see the value of 32 will be returned
from this function okay
now you can also have functions with
multiple arguments so let's say func
custom ADD so we have a new add function
in here okay and we take two variables
so let's say value one int and value two
int all right and then we return also an
INT so what we return is value One Plus
value two all right so we take two
arguments value one namely and value two
we add them and we just return them as
part of our function declaration all
right
then we can assign the return value of
this custom ad to a variable so let's
say let custom ADD it
is equal to execute the function of
custom ad and for Value 1 we pass the
value of 210 and for the second value we
pass the value of 20 and you can see the
result is value of 30. so this function
is being executed and it's returned
value is being assigned to this variable
to the left hand side of the assignment
operator okay now you can also have
functions that do not have this outside
label as as it is called so at the
moment this function has two arguments
and they only have one label this label
is used externally as you can see at the
call site and also internally inside the
function however functions can also
determine how these labels are created
every argument can have two label sorry
two labels external and internal okay so
you can see that then internally inside
this function this label is not
available so if you type external there
is nothing available but if you type
internal then it is available to you
okay so and let's go back in here and
have a look at an example of a function
that doesn't have any external labels
all right so for its arguments so let's
say func custom minus all right and it
has two arguments and let's just call
them left hand side and then right hand
side and we return an integer as well
okay
oops and then we say left hand side
minus right hand side now if you call
this function just the way it is then
you can you can write like this custom
subtract it
and then we say is equal to custom minus
and then let's let's say let's say the
value of 20 and the value of 10 in here
okay and you can see then easily that at
the call site we have to pass these
argument names LHS and rhs however if
you don't want to do that if you don't
want to pass a an argument name you can
just say custom minus and then you want
to say 20 and 10 like that then you have
to make sure that Swift gets the
external name as underscore like this so
underscore simply means that the a call
site where you're calling this function
from shouldn't have argument names so
you can see now you have to remove LHS
and rhs and then your code will work as
expected
okay so that's how you can basically
ignore external argument names and just
keep in mind that the first uh the first
part of the argument's name can be its
external name and then if you put a
space and then another
basically word or sentence hopefully not
a sentence but a few words it will be
the internal name of that argument okay
and if you don't have that the only name
you have in here will be available
externally and internally all right
good so
um if you are now if you're in pure
Swift you can see in here we're at the
moment calling this a function like
custom minus but if you're in pure Swift
meaning that you're not inside a
playground if you call a function that
has a return value so let's say cost
them add
and then you say value one is 20 value 2
is 30. in a playground you just get the
return value and the return value of
this function will be displayed here
however if you're in peer Swift meaning
that you're not inside a playground then
doing this will actually give you a
warning telling you that you're calling
a function without consuming its result
the reason we're not seeing that morning
in a playground is that playgrounds
consume the result of all functions
implicitly and and type them out here in
the preview but inside pure Swift Code
when you're writing like iOS code or Mac
OS code or watch OS whatever and you're
basically you don't have a playground in
those codes it's pure Swift Code so you
need to consume these values meaning
that you have to assign them to
something okay like that and then you
need to also consume this somehow so
even if you type code like this so it
will complain saying that hey you're
assigning this to add it but you're not
using added anywhere so what's the point
of doing this function call all right so
if you want to write a function in Swift
that does produce a value however the
person or the call site where you're
calling that function doesn't
necessarily have to consume that value
you can mark that function as
discardable result and I'll show you how
to do that so let's go ahead and create
a my custom ADD function in here so we
say my custom at okay and then we have
two arguments in here that are
externally not named but internally
they're called LHS as in left hand side
and then we have rhs in here okay and we
return integer as well and we say LHS
plus rhs so if you want this function to
be able to produce integer but the call
side the color of this function doesn't
have to consume that integer you need to
mark this function as discardable result
doing this in a playground doesn't make
any difference at all because as I
mentioned playgrounds consume the result
of all functions implicitly however if
you're in pure Swift this will make a
lot of sense and to be honest with you
we can actually have a look at this I
mean now I'm improvising a little bit
I'm just going off the script but let me
just create a simple iOS project in here
and let's say my app
and then we're just gonna save it on
desktop it's fine I don't really care
where it is saved at the moment so let's
just save it
and let me just show you how this looks
inside a for instance Swift UI
application so if you go into our app in
here and say
um what should we do in here let's say
perhaps we have a window group in here
let's go to content View
and now we have a swift UI application
though so it would have been better if
we actually created a
um let's just create a filing here Swift
file let's say my service okay
and in here let's just say that we have
a
what should we do let's say uh struct
person okay
and then we create a function in here
just like we're learning now we say get
H and this is not really how we write
normal code anyways but this is for the
purpose of demonstration and then we
have another function that's called do
something and then we say length age is
get H so we call that function now if we
leave this code like this let me just
actually change this to yeah that's fine
if you try to compile this code you can
see that now we're getting
initialization of immutable value age
was not used or something was never used
okay and you even if you write your code
like this you will get a warning same
result of call to get ages on you so
this is the warning that I was just
talking about inside a playground you
don't get These Warnings but inside a
pure Swift Code you get These Warnings
so the way to fix that is to prefix this
with discardable result and then compile
your code you can see then it's working
as expected however if you assign this
to a variable you will get the warning
anyways because you're assigning it to a
variable that you're not using later so
this discardable result doesn't fix this
this issue however it fixes the issue of
you calling this function without
assigning its variable to any values
sorry without assigning its value to any
variables okay
good you didn't have to create this
project I mean this was just a test okay
so that I can demonstrate what I meant
in this case now that we have that we
can just type my custom ad and then we
can just say say the value of 20 and 30
in here without having to worry about
consuming the result of this function
now you you may be thinking but why
would you write a function like that
well some functions for instance in
service layers inside an application may
do some complicated work and they may
produce a Boolean value indicating
whether it was successful or not however
it's not always that you actually care
about that Boolean value and you can
call that function without caring about
its result in that case you can prefix
the function declaration with a
discardable result as I showed you right
here okay now functions can also contain
their own functions so this is something
that not many program languages support
darts for instance support so then you
can also have something like that in
Rust as well
so let's have a look at that so we say
funk do something complicated with a
value and you can see width is the
external argument label and value is the
internal argument label in here okay and
this function we can see returns an
integer let's break this parameter down
like this and then in here we say we
have another function inside this that
actually does the logic okay so we say
main logic
with a value and returns an INT and in
here we just say Value Plus 2 okay so
we're not really doing anything
complicated we're just plusing the value
with 2. however this function do
something complicated contains another
function that does the actual logic and
this function then can call this
function internally but no one else in
the entire application can call this
function this function is only available
to this function because it is written
inside it okay then what we can do is
say return the main logic we call that
function we say Value Plus three then in
here we can go ahead and say do
something complicated with the value of
30. so what happens is that the value of
30 goes in here
then 30 will be plus 3 33 and then we'll
go into main logic so 33 plus 2 will be
35 as you can see printed out here okay
now arguments in Swift for functions can
also have default values so you can have
for instance a function that says Funk
gets full name as you can see in here
okay we say first name is the name of
the argument internally and externally
it has the default value of Foo and then
we can say last name is a string and it
has the oops the default value of bar
okay and this function returns a string
which is like this we put the first name
in here and a space and last name all
right so we're basically calculating a
full name using this syntax now you can
call this function now in so many
different ways actually you can call in
three different ways I would say one is
without arguments so because both the
arguments that are available that are
required for this function have default
values so you don't have to pass any
arguments to it and you can also mix and
match you can for instance pass actually
I think you can call it in four
different ways yes so you can also call
it only with a first name if you want to
so you can say bass you can say you can
see now the result will be bazbar so the
last name is picked from the default
value and the first name is overwritten
by the value at call site
and you can also say get full name and
then we say only pass the last name
let's say Foo so now the value will be
Fufu right
and then you can also call it with both
parameters so you can say first name and
we say Babs and last name we can say
[ __ ] like this all right so you can see
now the result will be baz and Cox in
here all right so these were just some
examples of how you can create functions
in Swift now we will actually look more
at functions on how to create more
complex functions perhaps but this is
like the basic structure of how to
create functions in Swift and there are
some functions of course that are a lot
more complicated than what we have in
here but the complication is usually
inside the function itself the function
um header or the function signature is
usually one form of these things that
we've written in here with some param
with some arguments that perhaps have
internal or external names or some
arguments that have no external names
but internal names discardable result
and pretty much pretty much that's it
really so that's about functions for now
in the next section of uh this video
we're going to have a look at closures
which are kind of special functions so
see you there now that we've finished
talking about functions let's go ahead
and talk about a special kind of
function which is with local variables
and it is called closure so before we do
that let's create
its own playground so I'm going to go
here and say command n and type
playground in here if I can spell it
and in blank playground I'm going to
create closures in here and Ensure again
that it is created in your workspace and
not inside another playground
I'm going to press the create button and
let's say in here that import Foundation
okay now
closures are available in many other
programming languages such as python
there are also available available in
Dart for instance and in I would say
rust as well and of course JavaScript
and typescript
so most modern programming languages
have closures and what closures really
are there are special types of functions
that are created in line so that you can
actually pass them to another function
for instance and they can hold a
function so you could you could pretty
much say that there are function
references kind of but not really uh but
I think the easiest way to explain
closures is to demonstrate how they look
like how to how the syntax looks like
and I think after that it will be a lot
more uh it it will be a lot easier to
understand what basically they do so
let's go ahead and create a closure in
here which is supposed to add two
integers together and return a result so
if you were to do that using a function
you would probably do add and then you
would say like left hand side into your
right hand side integer uh and you could
perhaps also remove the external label
of these arguments so that you don't
have to actually write LHS rhs when
you're calling this function then you
would say that this function returns an
integer then you could say left hand
side plus right hand side is that
function
however if you want to assign this to a
variable for instance call at then you
could say let's actually comment this
out then you could say let's add then as
you would do with any other variable you
as you could do actually with any other
variable you don't have to do that but
you need to tell Swift what type of data
type this function is accepting so you
could say let's add and then you would
say column and instead of for instance
saying this is an integer equal to one
or this is a string equal to Foo you
could say in here that this is actually
a function
right and then you say okay it accepts
an integer and it actually accepts two
integers and it returns an integer okay
so this is you defining the data type of
this variable or a closure okay and then
you could say it's equal to so now
you've defined a data type now you
actually create the function then inside
the creation of the function you just
create curly brackets as you would do
any other function and in here then you
get your data you say left hand side is
an integer right hand side is an integer
okay
and you return an integer
and then you say in like this so let's
actually break this down bring it to the
next line
like this okay so this is where you're
defining the data type for ADD and this
is where you're actually assigning it to
a valid function all right and let's
change our playground to automatically
run in here and then you can see Swift
is telling you that you're not returning
anything in here so let's just say LHS
plus rhs okay and these values that we
have in here they're just internal uh
argument names so they're not actually
being used externally okay now that we
have ADD you can see it tells you that
add is actually invariable that points
to F function which requires two
arguments and returns also an integer
so you could call at just like you would
call the add function so if you say add
20 and 30 you can see that you're pretty
much just calling that function that is
beneath this add variable you could say
okay so you get the result of 30.
so now that you know how to create one
of these functions closures you can see
you can create it in line like that you
can actually pass any one of these
functions like these and which you
create inline to another function and
that's where the power of closures
really come to play so let's create a
quite a useless function and that we
call custom ADD but it's just there for
for the purpose of demonstration of
closures
so this custom function what it does it
it takes two integer variables and then
it uses another function that you give
it so you pass a function to this
function and that function is passed to
this function will do the actual
addition and R function that we will
create now will just call that function
all right so it will just demonstrate
how you can pass a function to another
function and how you can create a
function on the go or on the fly so
let's create this custom ADD function in
here we call it custom ad like this okay
and this custom ads it takes two uh two
values we call them LHS left hand side
all right and then we say rhs another
integer and as the second parameter we
want actually a function that does the
addition for us so this custom ad itself
doesn't really do the addition it will
delegate the addition task to the given
function so just like you would Define
any other variable like here you
basically type the external argument
name internal argument name
or just one argument name that is used
externally and internally and then you
would Define its data type this is very
similar you see defining a data type
with a column we did the same thing in
here so we want basically a function
that takes an integer or two integers
and returns an integer so let's go ahead
and Define it here we say the external
label for this argument is using so we
can say custom ad kind of like this
custom at 10 20 using like this okay
so the external name of this argument is
using and internally is called function
all right and then we say this function
requires two integers and it returns an
integer all right so this is just like
defining any other variable inside or
argument inside your function signature
you just say external data sorry
external argument name internal argument
name it's data type and its data type is
pretty much just a function with two
integers as arguments and returns an
integer okay after doing that we close
the arguments list with the closing
parenthesis and now we have to define
the return value of R function so this
custom ADD function at the moment you
can see it's not returning anything
because the parenthesis ends here but we
don't have any of these pointers in here
so let's say that our function also
returns an integer okay then inside the
function itself inside this custom math
function we need to return an integer
but it is this function that does the
calculation so let's just call it just
like you would call any other function
so we just say function LHS and rhs and
again this is just a label it doesn't
have to be called function you can just
call it f if you want to or you can just
call it l h whatever you want to but I
really really suggest that you don't
name your variables with f or H or L
it's just better just to call them
something and that means something as
well okay and in this case function I
think is a quite a good name for it but
you might disagree
so we have function now and you can see
it is being called by custom add-ins and
this result is being returned from
Custom app and you can call the custom
ad function as I'll show you now so
let's say custom ad you can see we have
three parameters okay I'll break them
down here now the left hand side you can
see it doesn't have any external labels
so let's just say 20. and then we say
30. now this using is going to be very
interesting because usually when you
come here Swift is going to be able to
substitute this for you using an a
trailing closure syntax okay so if I go
here and press enter you can see all of
a sudden the using label was just
completely removed now if if you go
ahead in here and you just want to see
okay but what is happening in here what
you could do is instead go ahead and
create a function in here because this
should be a function you see it's
telling you it needs to have two
arguments and a return value of integer
you could create a function yourself and
then say left hand side and right hand
side ends and it should return an INT
and then in here you and also please
don't forget the in syntax because it
needs to know Swift needs to know where
this function actually starts its body
okay then in here you say left hand side
plus right hand side so after doing this
you can see now the value of 50 being
printed to the playground console all
right so that's what you could do
manually however what syntax what Swift
does is that if it sees an argument at
the end of a function you can see sorry
an argument at the end of the list of
arguments of a function so here we have
a left hand side and right hand side and
then we have a closure
that has to be passed to this function
but disclosure is not like the first
argument it is the last argument and
Swift does something called a trailing
closure syntax what it does is that and
we can actually do it by hand we can go
in here you can see it removes this
argument name first of all
then it puts an ending parenthesis here
and then removes this column
then you can see this should pretty much
do the same thing in here so and then it
of course removes this parenthesis in
here as well
so now you can see the parenthesis ends
here and then there's no using since
using argument name and then there is a
trailing closure right after the
function is finished so we can actually
put this maybe here actually it's good
yeah and we can clean this up as well a
little bit like this so this is the
trailing closure syntax in Swift meaning
that if there is a closure at the end of
a function and then it shouldn't it
doesn't necessarily have to have all the
bells and whistles around uh argument
names and Etc okay it can just emit
writing the argument name close the
parenthesis right after the argument
before it and then creates the closure
right after this function call and it
will be passed into this argument okay
so now you saw that we created a closure
which is this one and we passed it to
another function which is then being
used to calculate the value of 20 plus
30 okay
now Swift also has a very handy
functionality where it can infer data
types based on the function signature
now I'll explain this a little bit now
and you can see in here this function
custom ad already has defined that the
closure being passed to the function
argument has to have the data type of
integer integer and it sorry it has to
have the data type of integer for both
of its arguments and also integer first
return value
now in here then you could say okay but
if this function already knows that it
should be integer and integer maybe I
could just remove these well it kind of
would be right you can just go in here
and say left hand side right hand side
and then in
and if it runs your code again you
should basically see 50 again you can
see in here so we could maybe change
this to 30 just to see that everything's
working as expected
uh there we go we got the value of 60.
so you can remove these data types
right so if let's actually copy this
code and bring it a little bit down here
and remove the data types like this and
we can remove the return value as well
so that's the first step of cleaning up
the code that you can do all right now a
lot of developers would call this
actually clean up they would say oh yeah
you should remove these data types
they're not so good Etc however I've
worked on a lot of big projects that
have been written in purely in Swift
and once your code base gets very very
large that you have maybe thousands of
source files and then every of those
source files has hundreds of lines of
code
on average perhaps written in them I've
noticed that I mean after doing a lot of
uh
benchmarking on the compilation and
asking xcode to tell me exactly where
things are taking a time or the most
time during the compilation it's been
where it has where the compiler has been
trying to figure out data types so
there's a little less information you
give to the compiler the more time it
takes for the compiler to compile your
code so here you can see we have a lot
of information for the compiler we're
telling it that this closure has two
arguments integers and it's returning an
integer so the compiler doesn't have to
figure it out on its own so it says okay
then I just calculate this and return
the data however here the compiler has
to ensure that yeah okay so the function
it has to go back to the custom ad
function and say okay this shouldn't
have two integer arguments and it should
return an ins then it comes here and
checks that because we haven't even told
it what return value we have then it
says okay there's some data here some
data in here and they have to be plus
together can two integers be plus
together okay so it's it has to figure
figure out all of this on its own so it
has to basically look up the plus
function or in fixed binary operator to
ensure that that actually exists between
two integers so you can imagine all of
this basically puts strain on the
compiler and of course if you have
thousands and thousands of these
functions that where the compiler has to
figure out things on its own then of
course your compilation is going to be
drastically slower
now now that we're talking about
stripping information from the compiler
there's also one more step that you can
take in order to make your code more
Compact and more difficult for the
compiler to guess but on small smaller
code basis this is this doesn't really
make any difference to be honest so
let's actually copy and paste this code
right here what you can do in this case
is that you can completely remove these
this information from here and in Swift
you can tell it that you have two
arguments in here by specifying by
prefixing every argument with its index
and dollar so you can say dollar zero
plus dollar one so Dollar in here will
mean basically an argument at an index
of zero which is this guy and an
argument at the index of one which is
this guy and then you're just plusing
them together and returning the value so
some developers will then be like custom
at 20 30 and then we'll do like this
so it is completely up to you and your
teammates how you like to format your
Swift Code because unfortunately there's
no real official linter and official
code formatter for Swift as I mentioned
before so there are some Community
guidelines how to format code but you
can't actually see code written like
this sometimes and to be honest with you
for me at least this is readable I have
nothing against it but if it was me
writing this code I would probably write
it a lot more like this
just because of the experience I've had
with ensuring that the compiler can
compile my code faster on larger code
basis but writing code like this is also
completely fine dependent on the context
all right
good now now that we've done that let's
have a look at passing
um some sort of special closures to
functions and before I before we do that
let me just write some coding here as uh
like a preparations let's just Define an
array in here and say and I'm also aware
that we haven't worked with arrays yet
but if you've worked with another
programming language you already
probably know what arrays are so it's
just like a homogeneous uh actually they
can be heterogeneous as well but it's
just like a series of data okay let's
just leave it at that let's just say
ages are 30 20 19 and 40. so now we have
four integers placed inside this array
okay now you can see in here we can
start sorting this array let's say that
we want to sort things ascending and
descending so we say sorted okay and you
can see it has an argument in here and
there's a function called sorted using
actually let's just say sorted by let's
say sorted by this a little bit better
and you can see it expects a function so
it says give me a function that takes
two integers and then it can throw and
we haven't talked about throws it and it
should return a Boolean okay so let's go
ahead and see how we can implement this
function so we say LHS integer rhs
integer and it should return a Boolean
okay and then actually it throws as well
but we don't have to write that and then
we say in all right so in here let's
just return true for now and let's see
what happens okay so if you return true
in here let's see the data that is being
returning here
uh ss14 19 20 30. so it really didn't do
anything so but if we say in here uh LHS
should be more than rhs okay and this is
of course it's going to return a Boolean
value all right now you can see what
happened is that the result is that the
return from age is that sorted is an
array that is sorted descending so as
long as left hand side is more on right
hand side if you're basically doing this
comparison with greater than then you're
sorting the array descending and you can
read the documentation if we're sorted
by as well to understand how it actually
works okay so it's when you want to sort
a sequence of elements that don't
conform to the blah blah let's see and
that returns true when the first element
should be ordered before the second so
it says return true when the first
element should be ordered before the
second and and what we're saying is that
if left hand side is more than the right
hand side then it should be sorted
before and that's why we're getting
descending and if you change this to
less than
you should expect your rate to be sorted
ascending okay
so what what I'm trying to doing here is
that we have a lot of code in here you
can see that takes left hand side and
right hand side returns a Boolean
however there as you may guess this
particular
um
operator which is a binary infix
operator already takes a left hand side
and a right hand side and returns a
Boolean so if we were to Def to
implement this uh operator ourselves we
would probably write it like this right
function less than and we say left hand
side integer right hand side integer and
it returns a Boolean and we say left
hand side less than right hand side
however please don't do this because
this actually goes into a something
called an infinite Loop
it will go into an infinite recursion of
itself because this function will just
call itself all right so what I'm trying
to say in here is that if you look at
this function signature you can see it
is exactly the same as this function
signature so and since this is a
function name in itself why don't we
just pass it to this so instead of
writing all of this why don't we just do
this
right because it is the same thing it is
the exact substitute of this so let's
remove that
and remove this code as well and you can
see actually you can do that so by
passing a function or an operator a
binary in fix operator to this to this
argument you're substituting pretty much
all this code that we wrote in here so a
lot of newcomers to Swift will write
code like this but a lot of seasoned
developers know that that and this
binary and fix operator already is a
substitute for that closure so you can
do the same thing for more than so this
is going to sort descending and this is
going to sort ascending so you can see
here descending sort and ascending sword
okay
so
that was uh one one example or rather
two examples of passing operators to
closures okay
now let's move on to the next example
and for that I'm gonna go here to our
custom ad function and I'm gonna copy it
right right here and let's paste it down
here and let's call it custom ad2 and if
you remember I mentioned that we have
this syntax called basically trailing
closures in Swift meaning that if there
is a closure at the end of the function
signature as its list of arguments then
Swift helps you out by removing by
allowing you to remove the and the
argument label and allowing it to Trail
basically the closure at the end of the
function call as we saw in here so you
don't have to type and using in here
okay which is something that we
otherwise would have to do all right
like this using this and then
parenthesis so since that function as
since this argument is at the end then
we don't have to do all of that work
however if you make a mistake of putting
this argument for instance at the first
place where are in the middle not at the
end then let's see actually what
happened in here with a comma
then calling this function you will have
to do something like you have to do
mental gymnastics like this custom uh
two and now you have to pass your
closure like this all right and then you
say LHS
and rhs
and then you say LHS plus rhs and then
you have to go in here and say 20 and 30
for instance okay so I don't know about
you but this code looks a lot dirtier to
me than it should be because it has a
lot of labels and it is like it is a
function or a closure before these
values being sent here and so to me this
doesn't look very clean to be honest
with you and you can of course make this
a little bit shorter as well you can
remove that code that you've written in
here and you can say dollar zero dollar
zero plus dollar one and then do it like
this and then go 20 30. so it becomes a
little bit more readable if you do this
however it's still not as clean as it
can be so you can also put perhaps the
value of 10 in here just to demonstrate
that this is actually working as
expected so now this should be 60 okay
so
um that's why I really suggest that you
take advantage of trailing closure
syntax in Swift and add your closures if
you have a closure argument at the
absolute end of your argument list okay
now we've seen how we can pass uh
operators like this to a closure
parameter of a function and but as you
as you'd expect since arguments sorry
since operators are normal functions and
you can also pass normal functions to
closures so let's have a look at an
example let's create a function in here
it's called add 10 2 and then we get a
value of integer and we return an
integer and we just add 10 to this value
all right and then we can have another
function in here called at 22 and then
we just add 20 to whatever integer
parameter that is passed to our function
now we can then have an a function in
here called do addition all right and
then it takes a value and we externally
call it on and we say do addition on
value all right int
and then we want to have a function that
basically takes this value and does some
addition with it and returns an integer
okay so we say using a function using
function and this function should take
an integer as its only argument and it
should return an integer okay so that's
so it shouldn't take two integers
basically simply because we want to pass
one of these functions which has only
one integer as its input to this closure
in here okay and our function should
return an integer than what it's going
to internally do is going to invoke that
function with this value and return its
result as the result of our function we
could have written return in here but it
is not necessary in modern Swift okay
now let's go ahead and invoke this let's
say do addition and then we say on the
value of 20 and in here using you could
you could imagine that well you could
create a trail enclosure in here you can
see and we say value and we could say
value
plus 30 okay so what is going to happen
in here is this value of 20 is going to
be passed here to this closure and it's
going to be 20 plus 30. so let's see if
Swift playground is going to be able to
recover and you can see 20 plus 30 is
50. now instead of doing this instead of
passing this uh into basically an inline
closure to this using argument you can
as you'd guess pass a reference to any
of these functions that has the same and
they both these functions have the same
um header or definition as this closure
they take an integer as their argument
and they return an integer so let's say
that we say add 10 to
like this and you can see now it's this
function internally going to be passed
through this so this function is going
to be at 10 2 and it's going to be
invoked with the value of 20. 20 plus 10
is going to be 30 which is which is then
printed right to our playground console
then let's copy this and go here and
then we say add do addition again on 20
but add 22 which is our other function
up here okay and then we have the value
of 40 printed to the screen now and this
function is a little bit strange as you
can see I mean not strange actually they
don't have external
argument names so if you change that and
so that the value is actually the
external argument name then you have to
change the signature past here as well
so then we should say add 10 to with
value and add 22 with value so just make
sure that your function signatures are
basically the right signature according
to how you've defined those functions in
here okay
very good I think this suffices for uh
closures really closures are as I've
mentioned uh kind of inline arguments
and usually that you pass to another
function
and you can Define closures and by
assigning a function to a variable and
then you can pass that variable around
to other functions as well so
really when as Swift developers talking
about closures they're just talking
about functions that are in line so they
don't have the funk keyword before them
so any function that doesn't have the
fun keyword behind it is in fact a
closure instead you could pretty much
just say that okay
good we're done now with closures and we
can now move on to talking about a
little bit more fun stuff in Swift
um namely structures see you there
so we're now done with closures or at
least for now let's go ahead and start
talking about structures I think from
this point on in the course we're gonna
actually have a little bit more fun
since we've talked about the absolute
basics of Swift up to this point and you
can imagine that the basics are not so
fun and I think for me at least
personally personally the fun part comes
in when we have enumeration structures
uh classes protocols extensions generics
all that so let's get started with that
I'm going to go in here and let's do
command n and xcode and let's create a
blank playground and we're going to call
it structures okay
structures again a warning please click
create this not inside another
playground just change both the group
and the folder to the root of your or to
your workspace basically okay and then
we say create
so we have structures and let's import
Foundation as usual I'm going to get rid
of the Explorer to the left hand side
so structures in Swift are a way of
grouping data together and giving some
sort of a name structures in Swift are
value types and meaning that when you
assign an instance of a structure to
another variable then the data inside
that structure gets copied over so you
don't actually get
um it get you don't get the same
reference using two variables I know it
I mean this could be a little bit
difficult to understand for especially
those who are not familiar with value
types from another programming language
but don't worry about it I'll explain it
all soon so let's just first of all go
ahead and create our first structure
which we're going to call person okay
struct person
and in here when you create a structure
you can then go and instantiate it so
you can create an instance of this
person such as let Foo is person okay
and you can see then you do this syntax
in here with parenthesis
and inside this parenthesis you would
eventually pass any arguments that the
Constructor of this structure requires
at the moment the structure doesn't have
any values inside it so it doesn't
contain any properties so that's
important to understand the term
property it doesn't have any property
and we could go ahead and create
properties and the way to do that is
using the let's or VAR RM scene keywords
in here so you could say we have a
constant in here called nape and its
data type should be string and all of a
sudden you see your playground is going
to give you an error in here if you have
automatic running as well especially it
tells you that you are missing an
argument called name let's just ask it
to fix it for us and we say name okay
it's a string and we say Foo in here
okay just like having the name property
in here you can create another property
for instance called H and we could say
it is an integer now you see playground
will give you another area in here
saying that you're missing the age
argument and we can ask it to fix it and
says H okay then we say 20 in here okay
now you can see we've created an
instance of person with two properties
name and H all right now you can access
these properties using something called
a DOT notation so if you go in here and
say Foo dot name and food.h just like
that and Swift playground is going to be
able to print and consume the results of
these and print them to the console as
you can see in here however if you're
writing pure Swift Code this will make
no sense you're basically saying food's
name but you're not doing anything with
it but since Swift playground implicitly
consumes the result of all variables and
all return data it is being printed in
here but in Swift it is more likely that
you would say let's name and and age is
foo's name and then plus food that's age
inside like a string or something okay
so I'm not going to write all of that
but you you get my point so you have to
consume it in another way if you're not
using Swift playgrounds but just know
that you can drill down inside a
structure using this notation which is
called a dots notation you just put the
name of the variable that points to
structure and you say dot and then you
get the properties out okay
now you can also have custom
Constructors for your structures as you
can see in here we didn't actually have
a Constructor and the Constructor for
structures is always created by the
compiler itself and this is one of the
reasons a lot of people prefer to use
structure as a swift rather than classes
simply because you don't have to create
Constructors for them Constructors are
implicitly created by the compiler so if
you add another property in here there
will be a new Constructor so which will
replace the old one that had only name
and age with the new arguments in it as
well or the new property in it as well
okay so that's one of the properties of
Swift structures that they have implicit
Constructors you don't have to create
yourself
now if you do want to create a custom
initializer or Constructor for your
structures you can also do that I'm
going to show you how so let's create a
structure in here and we say Commodore
computer okay
for those of you who are old schoolers
and have worked with comforters one of
my favorite computers it was actually my
first personal personal computer at
Commodore 64. okay
and so we create a common computer and
we say let's name okay and your name is
the name is supposed to be something
that you designate it could be like my
lovely Commodore or whatever and then we
have another property in here called
menu Factory I always have difficulty
writing and spelling it and we say it's
the string now in this case if someone
wanted to go ahead and create an
instance of commodore computer it would
probably go let's say Commodore 64 is
equal to color computer and they would
say name and then they would say my
commodore
and the manufacturer is always always
going to be a Commodore okay so in
Commodore 64 has the manufacturer of
cover and also Commodore 128 is going to
have a my color 128 okay so both of
these instances have the manufacturer as
Commodore then you can ask yourself okay
if you have a Commodore computer who
always has its manufacturer equal to
Commodore why should the call site
meaning this part pass this value over
and over again so you could create a
Constructor that always sets this value
for you to Commodore let's go ahead and
have a look at how you could do that
so let's go ahead and say we have an
initializer you can see in here okay so
you just type in it not funk in it
except you just type in it and it
implicitly becomes a function then since
it is a function then you have your
argument list and then your function
body then as you as you can expect in
here you just want the call side to pass
the name to you so you're just say name
String but you emits the manufacturer
from the initialization so you say self
name is name all right and you need to
prefix this name which itself simply
because if you say name is equal to name
it just thinks you see it highlights the
name it says name is name it's the same
thing you're not actually referring to
the name inside the structure so you
have to say self that name so Swift
understands you're referring to this
name being assigned the value of this
argument okay and then you say self dot
manufacturer is Commodore so you
yourself take it upon yourself to assign
a value to this property okay then you
can go ahead and say let's 6 c64 is
Commodore computer and you can see the
only argument that the call site has to
pass to you is the name so you say c64
then you can say c64 name and c64 at dot
manufacturer and the values will be
exactly as you'd expect them so it'll be
c64 and the manufacturer will be
Commodore as you've set it inside the
initializer or the Constructor of this
structure okay
now there are other ways of actually
doing that so what you could have done
in here instead of having a custom
initializer in here or a Constructor you
could have commented this out and he
said in manufacturer equal to Commodore
like this
okay so this would have achieved the
exact same result so you don't you don't
have to have a custom initializer if you
want to assign values to your properties
that don't change pretty much okay so
just keep that in mind please so there's
another way of doing that
okay
now we've looked at that let's have a
look at another type of properties that
you can create inside your structure and
those are called computed properties and
I'm going to show you the Syntax for
them now for that let's go ahead and
create a new structure so we say struct
and we call it person two unfortunately
we've already consumed person in here so
we can't have another structure called
person unless we go ahead and comment
this out but we're not going to do that
let's just create a person too but
please if you're working with production
level applications please don't do this
please don't call your structures or
classes two or three or four unless your
business logic requires you to do that
okay
which in all my years of software
development I've never had the
requirement of calling something two or
three so
um just keep that in mind please this is
just for the purpose of demonstration in
this playground okay so let's go ahead
and create a person person structure in
here with a first name and last name so
I'm just going to say first name
is a straight and then I'm going to copy
this and go ahead and change at first to
last so we have first name and last name
now let's say that your requirement in
here to create a property for your
person 2 structure called full name so
this full name should always be equal to
the first name and the last name with a
space in between it so what you could do
is to go ahead and create an initializer
for your person too and you could say
full name and you can see in here you
can't just say full name is equal to
first name and last name because you
will get actually an error in here and
you this this syntax is invalid so let's
actually have a look at here cannot use
instance member last name within
property initializer because at the
point of you assigning this value to
full name first name and last name are
not known so even though this might make
sense just looking at it but Swift
compiler doesn't work that way so you
could be tempted to go ahead and say
okay I will create an inch socializer in
here
and I say first name is a string last
name is a string but I don't want you to
pass me to full name I can't figure it
out on my own so you say cell first name
is first name self last name is last
name and cell full name is a string
consisting of Ace another string which
is the first name which is passed in
here as a parameter and then we will
have a space and then last name so this
actually is completely valid Swift Code
there's nothing wrong with it I would
say however there is a better way of
doing that and that is used and that is
called computer properties so what you
could do is to completely remove this
initializer in here
and then change this let's to a VAR and
then make it a function
so this is a computer property when you
have a variable and inside and then for
the variable value you actually have a
function in here okay and in here you
could just say first name
and space last name so now you actually
did what we wanted to do from the
beginning when we said equal to you see
we try to do this but that didn't work
all you have to do really all you have
to so this is what we try to do at first
but in order to get this to work you
have to say first VAR Define the data
type
to remove the equal sign make it a
function and then put the logic in here
and that will be valid Swift Code okay
so you can now go ahead and create an
instance of this structure let's say a
let Foo bar is person two
we say pers first name is Foo and last
name is bar like that then we say Foo
bar first name and foodbar last name and
then we can have access to a property
called full name just like you have
access to first name and last name you
can see first name is Foo last names bar
add full name property or computer
property is set to food space bar okay
and this is how computer properties work
all right
now
structures the way they're created is
that they don't inherently allow
mutation right so let's let's have a
look at an example every I mean
everything we've created so far has been
immutable meaning that we haven't been
able to change the structure internally
we've just instantiated those structures
and assigned some values to them and
after assigning value to them we
couldn't actually change those values so
we can't go in here and say c64 name as
well so this is going to give you an
error because this is not assign it all
right you can see we got an error in
here okay so how do we make sure that we
can create structures that are mutable
so you can actually change them after
you create an instance of them so let me
show you an example of creating a
function that can mutate a structure
okay so let's create a car in here car
structure and then we say current speed
is in an integer let's just say current
speed then we can pass 10 or 20 meaning
10 kilometers an hour for instance
now what if you want to have a function
in here a funk drive with a specific
speed okay and then in here we could say
driving
but what we want to do is to change the
current speed of this car with the speed
that is given inside the drive function
so if you say current speed current
speed is speed you can see now you
immediately get an error in here saying
that you cannot do that so it says
cannot assign to property current speed
and because it is a let constant
so you might say okay let's fix that
let's change it to VAR then this will
not work either because you can see now
you get another error saying cannot
assign to property self is immutable so
the suggestion that and that's uh xcode
playgrounds is giving you it says Mark
the method as mutating so let's fix that
and you can see the suggestion actually
works so this function is prefix with
the keyword of mutating allowing the car
instance to be changed and the reason
behind all of this mental gymnastics is
that structures inherently are immutable
meaning and and they're also date and
there are also value types meaning that
once you've created an instance of it
it's sitting in the stack and it
shouldn't be changed but if you create a
mutating instance then then a mutating
function you're basically bending the
rules of how structures are actually
working and it's completely valid Swift
syntax as well so it's nothing illegal
but
I think actually in I mean all my years
of working with swift it is not so often
you want to do something like this and
but there are a lot of classes inside
Swift itself that have mutating
functions but usually when it comes to
structures you don't want to mutate them
but sometimes you have valid reason to
do that okay
so let's go ahead and create an
immutable car you may be thinking okay
but what does that mean but this is a
mutating function I'm going to show you
what I mean let's create an instance or
a variable car called immutable car and
we're going to say it's an instance of
car and this current speed is 10. then
you can go ahead and say immutable car
and then you could say drive and with
the speed of 20. all right you can see
now you're going to get an errand here
saying that oops you're calling a
mutating member on an immutable value or
variable and it says immutable car is a
lead constant so what happened here is
that since immutable car is let
you can't you can't actually call a
function that changes the internal value
of that let constant and this is one of
the very subtle differences between
let's and VAR in Swift if you remember
when we talked about variables at the
absolute beginning of this course I
mentioned that there are some small
differences between let's and bar which
we can't explain right now and this is
one of those differences what Swift is
doing in here saying that okay you
create a let constant in here
and you're saying that it is equal to an
instance of a structure but then you're
going ahead and trying to change it by
calling a mutating function on it if
this function wasn't mutating and we
didn't have this code in here you would
be able to easily call it you can see no
problem but if this function is marked
as mutating you're telling Swift that
this function is internally going to
change the data inside the structure and
since this is a let constant it is not
allowed to change either so by changing
I mean you're not either allowed to do
this so you can't do this and you can't
change it internally either so both of
these are invalid okay so that's what
let's stands for in this case
so how do we do that let's just comment
this out and go ahead and create now a
mutable instance of car how do we do
that well of course there's a syntax
word and the svar it's a variable it can
change so we say mutable car is a car
with a current speed of 10.
then you can go ahead and say that car
Mutual car
like this and drive with the speed of
30.
and then you see mutable car current
speed then you can see the current speed
is Gonna Change to 30 in here okay
so
um what we're going to do then is to
have a look at a little bit of copying
values and seeing how that also affects
our mutual mutability so let's just
remove this code for now
and if we go ahead and create a let copy
of this so we say let's just say copy is
immutable car so what what we're doing
in here is we're taking the value inside
mutable car which is an instance of car
and we're assigning it to a new let
constant called copy since structures
just remember that structures in Swift
are value types meaning that if you
assign an instance of any structure to
another
variable the internal data of that
structure will be copied over to this
variable meaning that now you have
duplicate cars one is in the mutable car
and another one is in copy and they have
absolutely no connection to each other
let's demonstrate that and we say
mutable car in here and we say drive it
at the speed of 30. and then we say
Mutual car and current speed and then we
say copy current speed now you probably
think oh they should both be 30 but you
can see that the mutable car which was
actually mutated using the drive
function
it has the current speed of 30 however
the copy has the current speed of 10 at
the point it was it was taken or
basically it took over a copy of mutable
car at this point mutable car had the
current speed of 10 as you can expect
from The Constructor or initializer okay
so remember structures are value types
when you assign a value of a a let
constant for instance or a variable and
where it is equal to an instance of
instruction to another variable then
you're basically getting a copy of that
structure and you might be thinking okay
is that is that because of let okay
let's test that let's change this to VAR
and see what happens in here you can see
it didn't really change anything by
assigning simply assigning an instance
of a structure to another variable
whether it's VAR or let you're making a
copy of this and placing it in here okay
so that's a very very important thing to
understand about structures
so
structures in Swift cannot subclass
other structures okay and subclassing is
something that comes into play when we
talk about classes but I'm naming it in
here we haven't talked about it yet but
I'm naming it here because as I
mentioned at the introduction to this
course I expect you to already know
another program language and chances are
you probably know JavaScript or python
or Dart for instance or rust and you are
probably comfortable with subclassing
though rust doesn't really have
subclasses it it has the concept kind of
like protocols okay but
I just want to mention that Swift
structures cannot have the functionality
of subclassing and I'm gonna I'm gonna
explain that how subclassing pretty much
works but we're going to go more into
details about subclassing when we get to
the definition of classes in Swift and
that is going to come up soon okay for
now let's create a oops a struct and
we're going to call it living think and
in the init function we're just going to
say I'm a living thing all right now you
may be thinking okay a living thing
could be an animal for instance so we
create a structure and we say animal and
you would expect it to be able to
subclass living thing like this you
would say an animal is indeed a living
thing but you can't do this this is not
a valid uh Swift syntax you can see this
is inheritance from non-protocol type
living thing so just keep in mind
structures cannot inherit from each
other in Swift okay
so let's comment this code out and we
just leave it there leaving thing is
still evaluative syntax so we could just
leave it there okay
now in Swift you can also have custom
copying of structures and as we saw when
you assign a value inside a variable to
like here we had mutable car and you
sign it to a copy let constant the
entire contents of this mutable car was
copied over to this variable but what if
you want to have some sort of a custom
logic while copying over something to a
variable well you have to create that
logic yourself let me show you how let's
say struct bike
we say manufacturer okay and we say
string and we say let current speed is
integer all right now if you say in here
let's bike one is a bike
and we have a manufacturer of Harley
Davidson in here and we say let's say
the current speed is 20. so not nothing
illegal and then we're going to create a
bike two in here so we say let's bike
two and then you say uh bike one now
what you want to do in here you say well
I want to get bike one but I want to
change its as sorry but I want to change
its speed when it is being assigned to
this variable you can't do that at the
moment right because even if you change
this to VAR and if you say Bike 2
current speed is 30 you can't do that
simply because current speed inside the
bike is specified as let you can't
change it you then go say okay I have to
change it to VAR then well you'd be
right you can't change it to VAR and
everything will just work fine but
remember you have to do all of this work
simply because you had this requirement
in here to assign a bike to another bike
and change its current speed there is
another way of doing this and it's
actually more preferred I would say to
do it this way that I'm going to show
you is to create a function that allows
you to do that so you could go ahead in
here and and say well I have a function
and I'm just going to call it copy it
doesn't have to be called copied you can
say copied with or whatever you want
okay then you can say copy and then you
say current speed so you want to change
the current speed so take it in as an
argument and then your function could
actually return an instance of bike
itself then you say okay I create a bike
its manufacturer is the sales
manufacturer because remember this is an
instance method meaning that it is
actually operating on an instance of
bike itself so it has access to self and
the manufacturer and its current speed
is going to be the current speed that is
coming from the argument itself in here
okay
so now that you have that you can go
ahead at call site in here and say bike
one copy with the current speed of let's
say 30. and then if you change this back
to lats you can see it works as well and
by two current speed is now
uh 30 and we could also say bike one
current speed and you can see that
should be 20. so this is one way of
creating copies or custom copies of your
structures and to be honest with you
there's not much more to structures I
mean it you have to just get the concept
of mutability and structures and also
having the ability to have arguments and
sorry having the ability to have
properties in here we talked about VAR
properties as well that can mutate and
we also talked about computed properties
which can return a value by assigning a
function pretty much to and that's
argument sorry to that property of the
structure so there's not so much more
into structures and I think we've talked
enough about them in the next section
we're going to go ahead and talk about
enumerations so let's create the
enumerations at Playground now so
command n playground
and blank playground and let's call it
enumerations
and in here I'm going to say it is
created inside the main workspace let's
change the group as well to the main
workspace in here and press the create
button okay gonna get rid of the
Explorer and let's say import Foundation
all right now let's talk then about
enumerations and immersions are one of
my favorite features of Swift and any
other program language that supports it
and I think actually almost all
languages that I've worked with except
for assembly of course support
enumerations or a form of enumerations I
mean Objective C does it C does it have
C plus plus does it typescript does it
JavaScript is it python does it Dart
rust all these languages I've worked
with have the concept of enumerations
and that's that's very good I mean and
they do have enumeration spot to a
certain degree they differ from each
other so some have more advanced
enumerations such as Swift I would say
Swift enumerations are the most advanced
I've seen and after that rust
enumerations are number Advanced and
then we have also JavaScript and
typescript which are at the same level
kind of like Dart animations but also
Dart is less advanced in supporting
different features of enumerations
what are animations I mean I've talked
quite a bit now about enumerations but
what are they
well enumerations are categorization of
similar values that are named
such as animals cats dogs and rabbits
you could put them inside an enumeration
now if I for instance ask you and I said
let's create a structure in here struct
animal and I said define the type of
animal in here you would probably say
Okay type is a string
and I would say okay so can I create an
animal and its type is a bike then you
say okay so what should we do should we
go ahead and create an initializer in
here that takes the type and it says if
type is a rabbit
or type is Doc
or type
is cat then self-type is type
otherwise you create a preconditioned
failure
of oops it didn't work something like
that so this is valence syntax and uh it
is going to work but it is not so
obvious I mean a lot of cases it
probably people don't even see your
source code so they have to kind of
guess what type they have to pass in
here
and that is the reason we have
enumerations Innovations is the
categorization of similar data together
by a name
so let's have a look at how that
actually works let's say an enum animals
okay and we can remove the structure
from here and this enumeration let's
also have our playground as
automatically running and it's animals
in here then you can Define your
different types of animals giving them
names and the way to do that is by using
a case syntax in here or a case keyword
then you say you can't I have a cat I
have a dog and I have a rabbit now when
I say I have I don't actually mean that
these are properties I mean these are
cases this animal's enumeration has
these various cases and you can also
omit case for every one of these cases
and remove it and just do it like this
as well this is also completely valid
Swift syntax so you don't have to prefix
every case with the case keyword but a
lot of people do that and it allows you
to also go to the next line I mean you
can also do this but it looks a little
bit strange to be honest with you if you
do something like this I haven't seen
animations in Swift in all my years like
I've written like this it's either
written like this or it is written like
this usually okay but it kind of depends
on you and your team how you want to
Define your animations I think what
would be really good if you and your
team decided on a convention
of how you want your animations to be
created either all of them have case
before them or you just have one case
for all the cases basically okay
so you may be thinking then okay now
that we have this how do we create an
instance of these animals so we could
say let cat is animals dot cat as you
can see in here you have all these
properties in here cat dog rabbit Etc
let's say cat and then we can print it
out here to the playground console and
you can see it just says cat you can
change this to dark and you can see it
says dog in here though we have to
change the variable name probably as
well okay so that's the simplest way of
creating an instance of enumeration now
you can compare enumerations with if
statements so if we go in here and we
say if cat is equal to animals cat then
this is a cat
and we can say else if cat is animals
animals dot dog
this is a dog otherwise this is
something else okay and of course you
can continue here you can say else if
cat is animals dot uh rabbits however in
here you can't say else if cat is equal
to three and this just won't work
because 3 is an integer and cat is an
instance of animals so you cannot
compare you can see it says there's no
comparison operator between animals and
integer and you would be thinking then
oh maybe I should go and create one and
you could do that you could say funk
equality and so this is an in binary
infix operator on the left hand side you
have an animal animals and on the right
hand side you have an integer and you
return a Boolean and you could say if
you could say you return left hand side
left hand side is equal to cat and right
hand side equal to three okay so then
this returns a Boolean and now you can
see your error will go away so you could
do something crazy like that in Swift
but please don't do it I mean I'm just
showing you different ways of doing
things but this I just want to tell you
that this is not okay to compare an
instance of a an enum with an integer
for instance okay
however there's another way of doing
this using its raw value but we haven't
talked about that yet so let's just
remove this and remove this entire if
statement from here like that okay so we
just have an else and you can see as you
expect this statement is being executed
simply because cat is in fact an
instance of animals dot cat all right or
an instance of animals rather equal to
cat okay
now if statements are a little bit
strange in that you would have to write
quite a lot of code if and then else if
and then you have to compare them with
animals etc etc there's another way of
doing this and that is using a switch
statement I'm going to show you how to
do that if you say switch on an instance
of an enumeration then in here you can
get help actually from xcode to complete
it for you you can see and you just
press the fix button and it will tell
you that okay I know that cat is an
instance of animals and I know animals
has cat and dog and rabbit I will type
it out all for you so you can see that
syntax is case and then the enum value
and then you can type some code in here
and you can say break meaning that as
soon as it hits that point you just
break out of this switch statement like
this okay so let's go ahead in here and
say this is a cat
and this is a dog and this is a rabbit
all right so we've written our code and
we expect this line to be executed and
if you go ahead in here and change the
value of cat to a dog then this case is
going to be executed you'll see soon
this is a DOT right
so let's change it back to cat again so
this is how you would do a switch
statement and then there's a Syntax for
switch statements where you don't have
to specify all the cases so if you don't
want to specify the case of rabbit you
can also do that just remove it but
you're going to get an error now as
you'll see soon it'll say that you
haven't covered all the valid cases it
says it must be exhaustive meaning that
you have to cover all the cases but if
you don't want to cover all the cases
there is a special syntax called default
in here and say this is something else
which is similar to our else statement
right so these two are pretty much the
same our One is using a switch the other
one is using a um an if and else
statement now
oh I probably I should tell you that
this is usually not a good idea
specifying a default clause simply
because in the future I mean uh let's
let me actually demonstrate to you let's
go ahead and in here say that you have a
funk and you want to say describe animal
and then you say animal
is of type animals okay then you go in
here and you say describe animal
and let's change the switch to uh from a
cat to an animal in here which is passed
to us then we say describe animal and we
pass our cats to it okay
um in the case of cat we're saying this
is a cat in the case of dog we're saying
that this is a dog and in here actually
we don't have to pass Cat to it we can
say animals dot rabbits
okay if we do that you can see it says
this is something else now what if we go
ahead and add another case in here and
we say case Hedgehog I think it's
spelled like this now you can see our
function is still saying this is
something else so for every case of our
um animals where it is not handled it's
neither cat or a dog it's saying this is
something else well this might work in
this example but usually in larger
applications when you add a an enum case
to your animations you want everywhere
where you have a switch statement to
actually take care of that case okay so
let me show you how if we remove this
case from here so we have cat dog and
rabbit again we go in here and we bring
the case of
at rabbit okay and we say this uh this
is a rabbit and we break okay and we can
actually take this out we don't have to
have it inside a function anymore we
take it out all right and then say in
here we say switch cats so we have all
the cases covered now cat dog and rabbit
now if another programmer inside our
team goes ahead and adds a case of
Hedgehog you can see our if statement
still works and you might be thinking
well the if statement still works it
must be good but the switch doesn't work
so it's not good however in my opinion
where you go ahead and add a new case on
enumeration you need to also always
ensure that everywhere you're handling
an instance of that enumeration you're
taking care of the new case as well the
if statement doesn't do that it doesn't
fail because it's simply doing
comparison however switch is doing more
than that it's ensuring that if you're
switching on an enumeration that the
enumeration cases must be exhaustive
meaning that you have to cover all the
cases so in in my opinion with my
experience it is always almost always
best to compare enumerations using
switch okay because it will tell you
that oh you can't upon your code now
because someone has gone and added a new
case through the switch you have to
handle that so let's handle Hedgehog in
here and we say this is a hedgehog
okay and we break
so now you can see it is handled and
though this is still a cat so this
statement is being called but at least
we've handled the case of adding a
hedgehog in here okay
now now that we've taken care of that
let's talk about enumerations a little
bit more advanced enumeration Concepts
and that is enumerations with Associated
values okay animations in Swift have the
ability to have Associated values a dart
for instance for those of you who are
flutter developers you probably think
that Dart also has that but
unfortunately it doesn't and in Dart
enumerations you create an enum and you
can't make it a class almost by adding
properties to it and then you create
enum cases that hard code the values of
those properties and that's not really
the same thing as having enumerations
with Associated values like Swift and
rust half because as you'll see soon
enumerations in Swift can have
Associated values that are dynamically
added at the time of creating the an
instance of that narration okay let's
for instance have a look at an
integration called shortcuts or
shortcuts
let's say in here you want to create
three shortcuts and one is called for
instance a case File or folder okay
another one is a www URL and then a
shortcut to a song so let's say that
you're creating an enumeration that can
allow the user to do a shortcut to any
one of these cases either a song for
instance on Spotify or a website address
or a file or folder
now how do you go ahead and do that how
do you then say okay this let's say let
www.apple
is shortcut
to www URL but how do we specify that
this is actually going to go to Apple
all right then you you would probably
think that okay I want to add case
www.apple.com or something like that
well if you had to do that then you
would have to create a case for every
website in the world and that won't work
and that is the reason we have
Associated values for enumerations is
Swift and rust
so let's go ahead in here and you say I
want to add some values to these guys
whoever is creating an instance of any
of these cases has to pass some values
to them then we say for instance here
the path is a URL you see in here okay
so then at the call side we're creating
an instance of this WWE URL you have to
pass it a URL okay so we say let's go to
the path and we create a URL and in here
we say it's a string of https and
apple.com and we force on rapid we
haven't talked about this operator yet
actually I think we talked about it once
is um this is a unary suffix
operator which we've actually seen an
example of before
okay when we're talking about optionals
but you see we haven't gone into depth
and with options yet so just accept that
this is a URL for now okay but we don't
have to know exactly what this one does
I'm going to explain it soon when we go
and talk about options
all right so you can see now we actually
passed a value to an instance of this uh
enum case and you can do the same thing
for others like file or folder we could
say it has a path to a URL and it has a
name of string okay and we could say a
song has an artist a of type string and
a song name of type string all right so
this is up to you I mean it's really up
to your imagination What values you want
to have associated with your enum cases
okay
now you would be thinking okay now that
we have this guy how do we compare it
with like if if there is a case in your
application where you get a copy of an
enumeration or an instance of this
enumeration if you want to see whether
this is a song or a URL or a file or
folder how do you do it so you would
probably say of if ww apple is equal to
shortcut dot dot URL and then let's say
you pass this URL to it
boom then do this okay so you may be
thinking okay I could do that but no you
can't really do that you can't do
comparison between an enum instance with
associative value and another in
immenses with the same associative value
because as soon as you add Associated
values to enumerations in Swift you
basically you need to Define equality
for this enumeration yourself there is
no equality by default anymore in this
case when we had animals and there was
no associative values we could do this
because Swift adds implicit equality
operator which is a binary infix
operator to enumerations with no
Associated values by default but as soon
as your animations have Associated value
Swift doesn't know how to compare them
anymore because it's not the comparison
of their cases anymore but you actually
have to define a comparison yourself
maybe you want to only compare the names
in the case of file or folder maybe you
don't care about the path maybe in the
case of a song you don't care about the
artist you just want to basically
compare the song names so Swift can't
deduce that equality operator for you
so you can't do that unless you go ahead
and you go ahead and and basically
Define equality operator which is a
little bit more advanced than what we're
going to go into right now so as you'd
guess you can rely on your friend switch
statement so we say switch dot Apple in
here and we can actually ask Swift to
complete this for us you'll see now
it'll be a little hint in here it says
fix and you can see it will come up with
all the cases for us okay now I usually
don't like the default format that is
created in here but we can use it for
now I'm just going to break them down
into smaller parts in here into smaller
bits of pieces of code now in here we
could say print the path print the name
and then break okay in here as well
we're going to say print the path and
then break and then here we're going to
say take the artist to its own line sign
name to its own line and then print the
artist
and then print the song name and then
break
like that all right so now we can see
that we're going to hit this point
and it says that you are the path of
this URL is actually apple.com all right
and actually I think in here yeah it was
called path as well but here it doesn't
have to be called the same just so you
know this path it doesn't have to be so
you could say let P okay the important
part is this one
now there is another way uh you can also
remove the argument names so you can see
in here it says there's an argument name
path and then it's a let path let's copy
this and make it cleaner let's copy this
entire thing so this is what Swift
suggests that you do but usually in
codes in code bases or at least the ones
I've worked with no one does this okay
no one says here's the artist and then
let's artist no one does that what
usually people do is go ahead and chain
and remove this external argument naming
here and just leave the let's in here
okay so remove the path and remove the
previous thing in here as well and this
and you will see that this works exactly
the same as the other one all right so
uh that's another way of writing it and
what is also very very common in Swift
uh code bases is that people don't like
the syntax of writing let's before every
argument name either so you could copy
this code now let's clean it up even
more gonna paste it here and remove all
these let's
okay so that let
this let as well and also these lengths
from here and what we're going to do is
to go ahead right after the case type
let
right after the case type let right
after the case type lets so this let is
going to be applied to all of these
arguments in here and you can see it
works exactly the same way as it did in
the other two examples every example is
going to become shorter and more compact
than the one before it basically okay
really good now there's another very
compact way of unpacking values inside
in iterations that have Associated
values
now there was two values in my sentence
but I think you get the point and that
is using an if statement in very rare
cases if you want to only handle a
specific enum case uh for instance in
this case you want to see if this dot
dot apple is an actual URL you could use
a if Case let statement you could say if
Case let
and to be honest with you in all my
years of doing Swift I still get this
wrong almost every time I sometimes type
if let case and sometimes if case
something something and then let but the
actual syntax is if Case let all right
and then you say the case is dot dot URL
which is your actual enum case and then
you say pass is equal to your variable
then you can print out the past so you
can see it's printed in here so you can
in here then say it could be anything
else it could be file or folder and then
you could say path and then name
all right equal to
your enum case like this
and you can see it is not executed
simply because.apple is not an instance
of file or folder enum case in here
let's change it back then to drop.url
and then we can grab the path out of
this variable instance or
a shortcut instance in here okay
now while you're working with enums you
can also ignore values inside the enum
cases let me show you how let's say we
create a an instance of shortcut we say
without you is an instance of shortcut
to a song by one of my favorite artists
Symphony X and the song name is called
without you so one of the really good
songs of Symphony X I highly recommend
that you watch it and sorry and listen
to it if you want to I don't actually
think there is a music video to it
unfortunately uh but there may be one of
these lyrics uh music videos to it on
YouTube
so now we have without you and we want
to compare it if it's a song by
um for instance only looking at its song
name so we say if uh case let
and it is it a song and we don't want
actually we don't care about its artists
so we can ignore the artist using an
underscore in here but we only care
about the song name and we say if that
is equal to without you
in here then we can grab the song name
okay so you can see it's it says without
you without actually using the artist in
here you could also say artist and then
type the artist in here as well and grab
that artist you can say it's a Symphony
X but if you want to ignore the artist
you can just pass underscore in here
okay
really good now you can also have a
case statements and switching case for
enums with Associated values that have
similar data types okay let me let me
actually show you an example of it let's
go ahead and create an enum of a vehicle
all right and we say one is a car and
every car has a manufacturer of type
string and a model of type string and
then we have bikes as well and with
manufacturer as well
and like this but for bikes we don't
want a model we want a year made integer
okay so this is an enumeration now you
may be thinking okay let's say that you
have this business case of uh every time
you access an instance of vehicle you
may want to grab its manufacturer so how
do you do that let's let's go ahead and
say let car is vehicle
and how do we do that let's say
vehicle.car
for its manufacturer we say it's a Tesla
and for model we say it's model X then
we say let's bike is a vehicle bike okay
and its manufacturers Harley Davidson
and it's your mate let's say 1987 or
something like that okay just making
things up in here okay now how do you
grab the manufacturer out of these two
like you have a car and you have a bike
and you want to grab their manufacturers
you know both of them have a
manufacturer but how do you grab that
well you could go ahead and say okay I
switched the car I'll let Swift extract
this information for me for all the
cases then add this in here then you say
okay I have the manufacturer I will
learn that we can have a let statement
in here and remove all of this in here
so we have the manufacturer we don't
care about the model so underscoring
here then you say manufacturer
manufacturer and then you break and you
do the same thing for bike okay you say
case let manufacturer is right there and
the year made we ignore and then in here
you say manufacturer and break okay so
this is a switch on the car all right
and you can see we grabbed the Tesla
manufacturer out of that car but what do
we do with the bike oh yeah we have to
go ahead and do the same thing for bike
we go ahead in here and we say switch on
the bike and we say in this case since
it's a bike you see Harley Davidson is
extracted then you may be smart and say
okay
I'm sorry and not you may be smart you
are smart but you might try to be smart
to say okay then I can create a function
out of this then I will say funk
um
get manufacturer
from vehicle
okay and vehicle of type vehicle and it
returns a string and in here you could
just say return
manufacturer and return manufacturer you
could do that as well okay so this is
actually one step closer to making this
a little bit more usable and then you
could call gets manufacturer
uh from car and then gets manufacturer
from bike as well okay so you could do
that as well so you get Tesla and then
oops
what happened to our bike the
manufacturer should be Harley Davidson
so car manufacturer bike manufacturer oh
because we're switching on car this is
very very bad we should switch on the
vehicle in here okay which is a local
variable to the function then we get our
Tesla and we should now soon get Harley
Davidson so this is this is another step
towards having a more reusable
extraction of manufacturer from our
vehicles what you could do is to move
this actually out and place it inside
the enum itself and instead of switching
on a vehicle that is passed as a
function we can remove this and say we
switch ourself all right and then we go
in here and then we can say car gets
manufacturer okay and then we could say
bike gets manufacturer right
so that's one one more step actually
towards having it a little bit more
Compact and having it make more sense so
it's a car get manufacture and buy get
manufacturing now both of them have the
same function however what you could do
is to have this as a computed property
enums just like structures can have
computed properties so let's say VAR
and we change it to manufacturer and we
say it returns a string
and now all of a sudden you don't have
to call this as a function you can
actually say manufacture just like a
property right like this
good now it's one step closer to having
it very clean there's one more thing
that we can do to have it even better
and that you can see that these both
cases case let car case like bike
they're pretty much doing the same
comparison they're extracting a
manufacturer and ignoring the second
value well what if we could just remove
this
and remove this case
and have a comma here instead so we say
in both cases the case of car and byte
we're returning the manufacturer and you
can see that this is valid Swift code
and it is doing the exact same thing
right so if you have pattern matching in
your enumerations like this where two
enum cases or more are having the same
pattern matching by grabbing one value
and it doesn't necessarily have to be
this to be honest with you it could it
could for instance be in the case of
bike and sorry in here model and you can
ignore this one and instead use the
model in here so actually you then have
to call them the same thing let's say
Foo Foo and then you return Foo okay so
pattern matching Works basically just by
matching the value types since both of
these are strings and the other stuff is
being ignored then you can use this food
but we actually broke the code because
instead of the car manufacturer we're
returning the car model in here but I
just wanted to demonstrate to it doesn't
necessarily have to be at the same place
so it doesn't necessarily have to be
like the same at first value of both
cases okay so this is a computer
property on an enumeration
and it is returning and it's doing a
pattern matching on the both cases and
it doesn't have separate case statements
in here okay
really good that part's also done now
apart from enumerations with Associated
values you can also have enumeration
with raw values and here's an example of
that so let's go ahead and say enum
family
member and then in here you can actually
say that we have a case of Father case
mother case brother and we have a case
sister but what if you want these cases
to for father for instance to be called
Dad so to have that value of that so you
want to for instance have a mother be
equal to Mom then you can say Okay
father is that
mother is Mom
brother is bro and sister is sis okay
but we're gonna get an error now simply
because it says that this integration
can't have values like raw values like
this what you need to do is to tell so
if that this enumeration has raw values
of a specific data type like this so you
could say it is a string basically all
right and now Swift is very happy so
what you could do then is to say family
member dot father and then you have a
new property in here called raw value
then you can grab that Dad value out of
Father case and it is a string you could
do the same thing with brother or mother
and sister as well okay so brother is
going to say bro in here
okay
um now you can also have a enumerations
in Swift that have that you can extract
other cases because if you go into
family member at the moment
you can see that you have brother blah
blah in it raw value but you don't have
you you don't have the possibility
of extracting all the cases inside this
iteration but you can do that in Swift
by conforming to a protocol called case
I turbo we haven't talked about
protocols yet we're going to do that
soon but for now just it's enough if you
understand the syntax so let's say
enough favorite emoji
and we say it is a string and also we're
conforming to a protocol called case I
trouble okay just learn it for now that
if you do this Swift allows you to go
through all the enum cases using a
property as you'll soon see so let's say
case blush is equal to blush in here
okay
and we say case rocket is rockets in
here
we then say case fire is
fire like this all right then you can go
ahead and say favorites emoji
and like that and we say we have a new
property here all of a sudden call all
cases all right you can see it says
blush rocket and fire so it gives you
all those cases okay and also you can
grab their values you can say favorite
emoji not all cases now we're going to
use a function called map and we're
going to get their raw value and please
don't worry if this doesn't make sense
I'm just demonstrating what you can do
but we're gonna talk about these things
when we talk about collections later all
cases is now an array of your favorite
emojis okay so if you make an
enumeration conform to this case I
triple protocol I think it is actually a
protocol yes then you can you can grab
all the cases out of your uh out of your
enumeration using all cases property
okay
now now you have enumerations you can
also I mean you can create instances of
them using like uh favorite emoji.blosh
favorite emoji.rocket but if you have an
if you have the value of an enumeration
how can you create an instance of it so
using so right now we have been able to
say favorite emoji.blosh dot raw value
so we get the value but if you have the
value can you reverse it into blush so
if you have an emoji like this
can you actually grab an instance a
favorite emoji using the Emoji itself
and yes of course you can do that and
the Syntax for it is if let blush is
favorite emoji and you can say using a
raw value of your emoji in here then you
say found the blush emoji and then you
can print it out to the console
otherwise this Emoji doesn't exist like
this else if I can spell it right now
you can see it says found the blush
emoji and then it actually prints it out
which is blush it's not the Emoji itself
you see it is actually the blush case of
the Emoji
the favorite emojis enumeration favorite
emoji you can see in here okay
but don't worry too much about this
because we're going to talk more about
these in later chapters when we talk
about optionals at the moment we haven't
talked about optionals so this might
look a little bit strange to be thinking
what is a flat well it is strange
because we haven't talked about them yet
but this is just an example all right
let's copy this as well and do another
example then we say let's see and create
instead of blush in here we're going to
say snow and we say
snow exists really so let's Pass snow in
here and see what happens because we
haven't defined snow as one of the cases
in here you see we don't have a snow
Emoji so and then we say
try to create an instance a favorite
emoji with this note and if it is
created then type this snow exists
really okay and then we can in here say
as expected snow doesn't exist in our em
so we expect actually to get in here
because snow doesn't exist as one of the
cases of our enumeration okay
now we've looked at these and don't
worry about these two particular
examples because they're using optionals
and we'll talk about options more in the
future okay now let's talk about
mutating members of enumerations now
just like in structures you can have
mutating functions inside enumerations
and the way to do that is by prefixing
the function with mutating as you did
with structures so let's say enum height
and then we say we have cases of short
medium and long and then we have a
mutating funk in here
Funk make long all right and by mutating
an enumeration you're pretty much just
assigning a new value to self because
there's not much more you can mute it
with an enumeration than actually
mutating it itself so in here then you
can say self is equal to height dot long
all right so you can basically assign it
back to your own self and change
yourself instance using a mutating
function on an enumeration okay so let's
go ahead and say we have a variable my
height is equal to height medium and
then we say my height make long and then
we say my height let's see what it is
so once it is executed first is medium
and then we made the heights equal to
long in here as you can see okay
and if this was a let constant then you
wouldn't be able to do this you will see
now that make long can't be executed
simply because it is trying to mutate
self all right
good now we're done with that now and
there is another Concept in Swift
iterations which is a little bit more
advanced but I wanted to just name it
and they're called recursive
enumerations or indirect iterations and
in all my years of working in Swift I
think I've used them once once or twice
it is very uncommon that you see
indirect enumerations and that's why
I've left them as the last concept to
explain it here but I think it's still a
good idea uh to explain them so let me
show you what indirect or recursive
enumerations are in short a recursive
Innovation as its name indicates is an
enumeration that refers to itself so in
here you can see we had Integrations
that just have short medium long and
even have we had iterations in here with
Associated values that we're not
referring to themselves you can see in
here they just had associate values of
URL but no Associated values of touch
shortcut again okay but let's go ahead
and create a new enumeration in here
which has reference to itself we say
enum int operation
and then we say we have a an addition
let's say so we're ex we're basically
defining an addition between two
integers okay so it's just a case it's
not a function we say k subtract and
then we subtraction subtractions between
two integers as well and then we can
have a free hand this is a special uh
case that we're creating which refers to
ins operation itself all right so what's
happening in here now you see we'll
again an error saying that you cannot
have error you cannot refer to yourself
unless you mark this enumeration as an
indirect enum as you can see in here
okay so you can now see that issue has
disappeared but what does this actually
really mean and what it means is that
now you can have a free hand operation
on this ins operation and I I completely
understand this is a little bit
complicated and we don't have to learn
this but let's just let's just see how
we can create a function now on this
enumeration that calculates the results
based on the cases let's say we have
funk
calculates results and we say that the
parameter is off operation
and we say ins operation in here okay as
optional
and we say that's equal to nil
and again I completely understand we
haven't talked about these yet either
and in here we could then basically
calculate the operations and by doing a
switch statement I'm just I'm just going
to paste that in here so we don't have
to type all of this to be honest with
you okay
so let's see what happening here we have
the operation or self
an unexpected non-void return value and
in here we should return an integer as
well okay so what's happening is that
we're we're basically switching on this
operation since it's optional we're
saying either the operation or self
itself and we're saying if it's an
addition then do addition if it's a
subtraction do subtraction if it's free
hand let's actually change this to
freehand with a capital H if I can spell
if it's freehand then call this function
recursively with that operation
and the result to this really is that
you can go ahead now and say let
freehand
is into operation dot freehand okay and
in here then you can say do an addition
of two and four
and then you can say freehand uh and you
can say freehand dot calculate results
and then you can see the result being
printed in here of six
again please don't worry this is very
complicated this is almost going to like
Advanced Swift and as I said in all my
years of working with
um Swift I've had to use I think once or
twice uh indirect iterations and if you
didn't learn this it's completely fine
it was kind of expected to answer it and
that's one of the reasons I'm kind of
jumping over it and pasting code because
I don't think there's so much value in
spending time learning about indirect or
recursive enumerations so just know that
they exist but you don't have to learn
it okay so let's close off the
iterations chapter with this indirect
iteration and that is probably a better
idea actually if you just remove this
whole thing from here so you don't have
to be taunted by the thought of having
indirect iterations
so uh at least for me it doesn't feel so
good to end the chapter with something
that we just jumped over but I just want
to explain that this exists so you know
about it okay
good now we're done with enumerations in
the next section of this video we're
gonna talk about classes now that we've
talked enough about enumerations let's
go ahead and talk about the next concept
which we've actually named before and
you probably know them from other
programming languages that you're
already familiar with and that concept
is classes so let's create a separate
um
blank playground for this so let's say
playground in here and we say blank
playground and let's call it classes and
just again ensure that you're creating
it inside your main folder or workspace
and then we say in here create
and like we usually do we just say we
need to import foundation in this
playground and again hold and the
trackpad in here and say automatically
run okay
so we have structures in Swift and we
also have enumerations but there's a
third category of storage space you
could say in memory and that is called a
class and and classes are like
structures but they're not value types
they're reference types and also they
allow for mutability without having to
prefix things for instance with mutating
a syntax or keyword so let's have a look
at a simple class in here so I'm just
going to say class person and let's say
VAR name String and then bar age ends
okay
and so this is a simple class now it has
two variables and let's see oh we're
getting an error in here and simply
because we have no initializers and this
is actually really good we're getting
this error
um because
um I actually didn't think of explaining
this first but now that it has appeared
let's talk about it as you saw before if
you have a structure like let's say in
here we say class person sorry struct
person
and let's actually put exactly the same
code inside the structure and comment
the class out and you can see everything
will just go fine with the structure you
don't need an initializer or a
Constructor for a structure by default
an implicit one will be created for you
with all the member variables added to
the argument list of the Constructor so
if you say person you can see name and
age are already there
however when it comes to classes you
always have to create Constructors
yourself there is a refactoring feature
in xcode where you can ask xcode to
create the Constructor for you I'm not
sure if it is available inside
um playgrounds and we can see that it
isn't maybe there is a menu somewhere
let's let's say Constructor or
initializer generate member-wise
initializer and that's the one but it
doesn't seem to really work in
playgrounds so we need to just use this
little hint in here and ask it to
perhaps
oops yes it is not really allowing us to
actually add an initializer it's trying
to add a default value to these
properties and that's not what we want
to do so a class's first difference to a
structure is that it needs to have a
Constructor or an initializer and we
already know the Syntax for it and that
is within it and then in in the
parenthesis you would add your arguments
in here okay so let's say we have a name
which is a string and then H which is an
INT and again the um not again actually
we haven't talked about this before but
the ordering of these arguments it
doesn't necessarily have to be the
ordering of your properties so it can be
anything in here and you can actually
ask for more stuff let's just say height
and I don't know what you want to do
with that because you're we don't have a
place at the moment to store it but you
can ask for more things than your class
actually has as properties because maybe
some of those values are going to be
using other ways inside the Constructor
of your class okay so let's take this
back to having name and agent here all
right and then inside a Constructor your
job is to first and foremost ensure that
your class as properties are all set
before the Constructor is finished so
you cannot return from a Constructor or
an initializer as Swift calls it and
without having initialized or all your
stored properties okay so it says name
needs to be stored I need name needs to
basically have a value and then we're
going to go ahead and say self that's
name
self that name is equal to name right
and then we also have to say self-h is
equal to H
alright so that's that's the simple
initializer but we haven't really looked
at mutability let's have a function in
here and say increase H all right and
then in here we say self age is and
we're using this operator in here which
basically takes the left hand side and
adds the right hand side to it all right
so now we have a function in here you
can see it's increasing the age property
by one and it doesn't have to be prefix
with mutating actually I think if you
type mutating in here it will give you a
syntax error is not valid on instance
methods and classes so you shouldn't
actually prefix anything in your in your
classes with mutating all right then you
can go ahead and create an instance of
this class let's say let's Foo is a
person with the name of Foo and the age
of 20. all right then I'm going to break
these into their own lines
then we're going to say Foo H have a
look at the age and then we say Foo
increase age and then full H all right
so let's have a look at these values
then you can see first the age of Foo is
20 and then after
think after incrementing it using the
increase age then we get the H equal to
20. so nowhere in here did you actually
have to create anything mutating and you
can see that the variable itself is
actually created with a let so that's
the second difference when you create a
let constant equal to an instance of a
class you cannot assign a new value to
the select constants constant because
there is one of the natures of a left
constant after creation it cannot be
assigned a new value so you cannot go
ahead and say Foo is equal to some other
person in here
so that rule stays the same when it
comes to let constants and classes
however since now you're working with
the let constant equal to an instance of
a class this class internally can change
as you can see the age has changed
without you having to change this to
afar so that's the second difference
between classes and structures in that
classes allow for internal mutability
without you having to create an actual
VAR out of them all right and also their
reference types and we'll talk about
that soon actually okay
so let's and let's have a look at what
reference types actually mean so in here
we say Foo age let's bring this down Foo
H maybe just type it again in here and
then we say bar is equal to food all
right and then we say bar increase H now
you'd probably expect bar to be copied
and have actually a new copy of Foo
however since classes are reference
types the reference of this Foo is
placed inside this bar so pretty much
after line 30. bar and food point to the
same
instance of person in memory so bar gets
a reference to this Foo and then by
increasing the age of bar then Foos age
is also increased and bars H is exactly
the same so they're basically pointing
to the same memory and memory space or
memory allocated memory for this
person's person instance okay so keep
that in mind it's very very important
now you can also compare instances of
classes by using the equal equal so the
triple equal syntax which in all my
years are working with so if I've never
had to use so it is very unlikely that
you'll have to use it however if you
want to see if two instances of a
variable pointing to a class are pointed
at the at the exact same memory space
then you would use this syntax you would
say if
Foo oops if I can spell is equal equal
bar
okay and I think I've placed actually my
fingers on the right on the wrong place
on the keyboard so that's why I'm typing
everything incorrectly so let's say Foo
and Bar
point to the same memory
otherwise we say Foo they don't point to
the same memory and then you can expect
that you get this printed to the console
simply because yes the r actually
pointing to the same memory space and if
any if for for those of you who are
curious you'd be probably thinking okay
what happens if I just change it to this
and we should ideally get an error as
you can see in here and that is simply
because we haven't implemented equality
on this class so person doesn't conform
to equality in here and we'll talk more
about equality perhaps a little bit
later but if you wanna basically ensure
your class instances are Equitable then
you have to say Equitable in here and
then you go ahead and Define a static
Funk equal like this but we will
probably talk about this a little bit
later just know that this equal equal is
not the same as equal equal this
basically tests if two variables hold
values that internally are equal to each
other base based on some logic however
this is some logic that Swift has
implemented and you don't implement this
in this logic at all what this one does
is just make sure two variables are
pointing to the same memory allocation
all right and as I as I mentioned before
you probably don't use this so often
now classes unlike structures can also
have inheritance meaning that you can
create a super class with some logic and
then you can have some other subclasses
that conform to that actually not
confirmed but they subclass that's super
class all right let's have an exam have
a look at an example in here so we say
class vehicle alright so we have a
simple class and we say go vroom
like this and in here we save room vroom
like this alright doesn't necessarily
have to be anything scientific then we
create a car class which should subclass
vehicle okay so we say it's subclasses
that vehicle in here and the car doesn't
have any implementation of its own then
you can create an instance of car like
this
and then you can say cargo vroom so you
can see car though it doesn't have an
internal implementation of Gover it it
has inherited that function from its
superclass namely vehicle in this case
so keep that in mind you can have
inheritance using classes which is
something that you cannot do in
structures okay now classes can also
have private Setters so you can actually
have a variable and that is marked as
VAR but can only be set privately so you
can see in here these variables are just
simple vars meaning that they can be
both internally changed and also
externally changed you can see in here
let's say Foo has the age of 20. I can
go in here and say food at age plus
equal to 10. and with this syntax I'm
pretty much changing the age of Foo so
if I then go to full age it should be 31
in here so you can see it's a variable
that can both be externally Lee and
internally changed all right so if you
mark some a property as VAR inside a
class however you can also Mark a
property as VAR however allow that to be
only internally within the class changed
okay so let's say class person two
so then we say private set VAR H ins so
by by using private sets we're saying
that only can be set internally inside
this class implementation and can be
read from the outside all right and then
we say we initialize it with an H of int
then we say self H is H all right and
then we have a function in here we say
increase
increase age and we say self-age is
equal plus equal one so we're basically
saying pretty much the same logic as we
had before but you'll now see that you
cannot change this age from outside this
class implementation so let's say Bas is
equal to person two
and then we say 20 here then we say bad
H Bas dot h if you then try to change
this externally you will gain an error
simply because this property is not
settable from outside you can see it
can't be mutated all right now if you
remove this private set from here you
can mutate that age from the outside as
well all right you can see it's working
as expected but if you have the syntax
private set then it can't be modified
from outside the class implementation
itself however you can use still this
function which then modifies that
variable internally so you can say bads
increase age and then passage you can
see now H should have been changed to 21
at this
all right so that's the Syntax for
private set in classes in Swift
now you can also I mean now that we're
talking about about classes very
important that we talked about
initializers as well because
initializers are very very special I
would say in Swift in that you can have
convenience initializers and you can
also have designated initializers now
designated initializers their goal
really is to is to ensure that they
construct an instance of the Class by
first of all ensuring that all property
values are set and also that the
internal structure or the internal
validity of that class holds up
however you can also have convenience
initializers meaning that the only thing
they do is that they probably add some
logic to the Constructor or the
initializer of that class but they
essentially at the end of the day
delegate the initialization to a
designated initializer so it's as if you
have for instance a you have for
instance your mother in the kitchen or
your father in the kitchen there is a
party and they're making food and then
you stand at the door of the kitchen as
kind of like a delegate and people come
and make their uh make like
they basically make their order they say
could I please have this then you can
talk to them you'd be like let's say
someone comes to the door the kitchen
says could I please get a cup of tea and
then you can say oh dude does it have to
be red tea or does it have to be a black
tea then they say oh red tea then you go
to your father and say could you please
make a air blah blah so I actually
forgot whether it was black or red that
that person decided But whichever they
say then you go to your father and ask
or your mother and ask them to make it
so you're kind of like a delegate you're
making the job of your father or mother
a little bit easier and that's exactly
what a convenience initializer does it
gets rid of some Hassle and then at the
end of the day it delegates the work to
a designated initializer so just the
designated initializer is the person in
the kitchen and the convenience
initializer is you at the door okay but
let's have a look at some examples of
how this actually works in real life so
let's say class Tesla all right then we
say let's manufacture my manufacturer
server is Tesla then we say let's model
is a string and let's year is in so the
year production all right then
um we will initialize our test line here
we we create a designated initializer
you can see in here is designated it
doesn't have convenience written before
it and we'll talk about convenience soon
but any initializer that doesn't have
the word convenience before it is a
designated initializer and classes can
have multiple designated and multiple
um convenience initializers all right so
here's a designated initializer and we
say here model is X so let's say by
default anyone initializing Tesla
without passing any values to us they
get a Model X Tesla and then we say year
is 2023.
so that's one designated and designated
initializer the next one we will say
init and in this designated initializer
we actually take the model as a string
and the year as an integer all right so
we say self model is a model and
self.year is a year
all right
like that now another property of
designated initializers is that they
cannot
delegate their work to another
designated initializer so in here you
can say self in it model X and year is
2023 so we should get an error in here
saying that a designated initializer
cannot delegate its work to another one
okay you can see it cannot delegate so
designated initializers should do all
their work themselves they cannot rely
on another designated initializer okay
so that's for designated initializers
now let's have a look at a convenience
initializer now let's say that you want
to create a convenience initializer that
by default assumes that the year is
2023. so the caller to that initializer
doesn't have to pass the year all right
so then you say convenience
initializer or sorry init and then the
only property we want in here is the
model all right and in here then you can
say this function calls the self in it
with the model
that is given in here but the year is
2023 by default so you can see a
convenience initializer is delegating
its work to a designated initializer in
here okay now you can go ahead then and
create a subclass you can say class a
Tesla
model y all right and it is subclassing
Tesla and in its in it then what you
want to do you want to create an
initializer for model y that by default
calls the super initializer and sets the
model to Y and sets the year to 2023 all
right or perhaps it could just call this
convenience in it in here as well let's
have a look so you create an initializer
and here you say Okay I want an init all
right however you need to be careful
because init is already implemented on
the superclass right here so if you're
also creating an in and in your subclass
you have to pre prefix it with override
so you're saying I'm creating also
another version of this okay and you can
see it it says you need to at the end of
this initializer somehow call Super in
it so then we say okay then we call
Super init and for model we say model Y
and year is 2023. all right let's see
what happens in here
okay so now this should actually work as
expected this shouldn't give you any
errors all right let's see what happens
if you comment this out and just instead
call one of our designated initializers
so sorry our convenience initializer
which is this guy right here we just
passed the model since the Year is
already set to 2023 in this convenience
initializer we could just try to call it
and see what happens so I'm just going
to say model is y all right and right
here since this is a designated
initializer inside a designated
initializer you cannot call a
convenience initializer from your super
super class so this is another rule that
you have to remember so I think a good
rule to remember is that designated
initializers in subclasses they can only
call to designated initializers in their
superclass
inside any class a designated
initializer cannot delegate to any other
initializer okay convenience
initializers can inside subclasses and
inside their own classes
call either and no basically not either
but they can call a designated
initializer okay it is a little bit
special I'm completely aware of that but
it's just some rules that Swift has set
and I think logically they make sense
but kind of they can make programming a
little bit difficult sometimes when
you're working with classes so let's
let's create an instance of this model y
so we say Tesla Model Y and in here you
can see we don't have to pass any values
to the initializer simply because we
already have an init with no input
values basically no arguments okay then
we say model y oops model y dot model
and model y that year and then model y
dots manufacturer which comes from the
superclass which is always set to Tesla
all right
now one thing that I mentioned at the
beginning of the section was that
classes are reference types they're not
value types unlike structures
and that should really make you aware of
passing instances of your classes to
functions so let's have a look in here
let's create a foo bar and we say it's
an instance of person two all right with
the age of 20 in here and then we say
Fubar dot h and then let's say that
there is a function that is looking
harmless it's called do something all
right and with person and we just pass
person two instance to it what this guy
does internally is that person dot
increase age it calls increase age
function on that person all right Fubar
is at the moment having the age of 20
and then if you say do something with
fubar and then say fubard.h you can see
the age will have been increased to 21.
and simply is because the reason behind
it behind this is that classes are
reference types meaning that by calling
this function and passing an instance of
your variable to this function you're
not copying the values of food bar over
as new instances except you're actually
passing your entire memory space Sorry
the memory and allocated for your person
2 instance into this function so this
function is completely free to do
anything it wants with this person
instance so just be a little bit careful
with that just know that classes are a
little bit more special than structures
with structures you get a little more
safety so to say
now another concept and that we're going
to talk about before we close off this
section of the video is de-initializers
they're quite useful in some special
cases but some other cases you probably
don't need them so I would say probably
90 percent of ties are working with
classes you don't need the initializers
unless you're working with some sort of
notifications or RX for instance and
yeah if you're working with reactive
programming
so let's have a look at the initializers
as their name indicates they're kind of
similar to initializers but they do the
opposite the initializers are invoked
automatically by Swift whenever your
class instance is going out of memory so
it's kind of getting cleaned from the
memory so no one else is holding on to
it and it has to be removed from memory
so let's create a my class in here okay
then in the init and we will just say
initialized and then we'll have a
function here called do something which
which is empty at the moment all right
then we create a new function in here
called D in it and you can see that it
is purple in here but it doesn't matter
I mean the color doesn't really matter
it just matters that this is a reserved
word it's a keyword in Swift meaning
that you can't really use it anywhere
else except if you do something like
funky like that but just know that
there's a reserved word it's it's
similar to in it but it's just called
when your class is going out of scope
and in here we can say d initialized all
right now to test this we should
actually create a function in which we
create an instance of this because if
you create an instance of your class in
here let's just say let's my class is an
instance of my class and then my class
do something where the initializer won't
probably be invoked you can see your
initializer is invoked uh do something I
mean in here we could actually say do
something just so that we see that that
function is also invoked however Danish
Lancer isn't embodian that's just the
nature of uh of playgrounds so what you
could do is to create a closure my
closure and we say it is
this it is basically carrying out this
logic inside the closure and then we can
call our closure so at the end of this
closure this variable should go out of
scope meaning that it's the initializer
should be called so let's say my closure
in here all right and then you can see
your D initializer oopsie Daisy what
happened my closure
uh all right cannot find my did I spell
it incorrectly like this
and now you can see that the initializer
is in fact called and invoked simply
because after my closure is called this
scope completely finishes meaning that
all variables inside this scope should
also go out of scope so dnits will be
called on all class instances all right
really good we seem to now be done
actually with classes so
um let's just jump right ahead into the
next concept and that is protocols so
I'm going to go in here and actually not
there we don't have to go there I'm just
going to press command n in here create
a new playground and we're going to say
protocols again ensure that it is inside
your workspace and in not inside another
playground
create all right and we get rid of this
Explorer in here and we say Foundation
like this Foundation all right now
protocols for those of you who are rust
developers you probably already know
what protocols are and Protocols are
special kind of objects kind of like
interfaces you could say in Java for
instance I'm not sure the term in kotlin
what that is but you also have protocols
as mixings in Dart for instance
so what protocols are is that you create
an interface you create a set of rules
that objects which conform to a protocol
have to follow
so it is not a class and because if you
have a class for instance if you have a
super class that has some functions all
subclasses do not have to re-implement
that function however if you have a
protocol that only creates some
functions with no body so the functions
don't have logic in them any object that
conforms to those protocols have to
implement those functions by themselves
all right so it is actually a little bit
difficult to explain what protocols are
without having a look at how they work
so let's go in here and say that this is
automatically running and create our
first protocol so we create a protocol
called can breathe okay
and in here we say any object that can
breathe should have a function called
breathe so you can see this function is
special functioning it has no body you
cannot create for instance a class
person and just have this in it this
just won't work you have to have a
function body and you can't do that
either in structures your function has
to have a body so you can see that won't
work in structures either that's why
Protocols are a little bit special in
that they can have just function
declarations without any implementation
all right and that's what is called
interface insomni in so many other
languages all right
so we have a protocol now can breathe
let's go ahead and create a structure
called animal and we saw when we when we
were talking about structures that
structures cannot have super classes so
they cannot actually inherit from each
other okay so if you create for instance
a structure of animal and then you say
struct cat you cannot say that cat is an
animal it just won't work structures
don't allow inheritance however they do
allow inheritance from protocols so you
can say a structure of animal that
inherits from can breathe and this is
completely fine Swift syntax however
we're getting an error because now you
can see it says the animal a type
doesn't conform to protocol can't
breathe and the reason behind that is
that a protocol here called can't
breathe specifies that anyone conforming
to this protocol has to implement this
particular function and we haven't done
that so as soon as we go and type
breathing here you can see then this
error will go away because now animal uh
character conforms to Cambridge protocol
okay and in here we can just say animal
breathing like this okay
and also then you can create another
structure struct person can breathe like
this and in here we say breathe as well
and then we say person breathing like
that all right so then you can go ahead
and create instances of these two
structures we say dog is an animal and
we say dog breathe and then we create a
person called Foo an instance of person
we say the food breathe all right now
you can see both of these lines will
then be invoked uh simply because we
call them from here so that's basically
the essence of how protocols work I mean
protocols can be a lot more complicated
than that actually uh in that I mean we
talked right now about having protocols
that only have function declarations but
not implementations but protocols and
Swift are kind of like mix-ins and dart
in that they can't actually have their
own implementations so they're not just
like objects that have dummy function
headers but they can indeed have
function implementations so let's have a
look at that let's create a protocol
called protocol can jump and then we say
a jump function all right then in order
to create implementation for this
function I mean you may be thinking okay
maybe I should do this jumping and this
will just give you an error because you
cannot create your function body inside
the Proto call itself the trick to do
that is to go ahead and create an
extension on can jump okay and we
haven't talked about extensions yet but
it is necessary that we just name it in
here simply because that's the way to
actually add implementation to this
function all right then we go and say
okay it's the same function and then we
just say jumping
so by this trick you I mean it's not
really a trick this is the way to do it
by using this uh technique I'm trying to
avoid saying trick by using this
technique you're adding a default
implementation to this otherwise very
dumb function
so you may be asking okay but what
happened here can I just call this
function now so can I just say can jump
is an instance of can jump can I do that
well you can't because you cannot
instantiate a protocol you need to
instantiate an object that conforms the
protocol
okay such as a cat that can jump so
let's say struct cat and jump and now
since this jump function already has an
implementation you can see that we're
not getting an error from Swift saying
cats should implement this function if
you remove this implementation from here
all of a sudden all objects that conform
to can jump need to implement this jump
function themselves but if you bring it
back into can jump then all objects that
conform to that protocol will get this
implementation by default but they can
go ahead and change it if they want to
like this okay
so that's also valid however if you
leave it it also works with that problem
so let's create an instance of this cat
we say Whiskers Whiskers it's an
instance of cat and we can just say
whiskers.jump all right this is how we
can invoke that function that is
implemented on can jump right
now protocols apart from defining
function headers that they're conforming
objects have to implement they can also
Define variables let's let's go ahead in
here and say we have a protocol in here
we say protocol has name protocol
has a name and then in here we say VAR
name a string and then we have to say
gets in here or set or both like this
now what this really means is that this
protocol is asking Swift saying any
object that com conforms to me has to
have a variable called name that has to
at least have a getter what does this
mean well this is really just a dumb way
of saying this
so it it basically says a variable that
at least I can read from but this syntax
isn't valid and protocols I wish it was
but you have to implement them like this
so you're basically saying a some sort
of a variable that I can read from which
is called name all right and then you
can also have H all right and let's just
say h should be getter and Setter
meaning that it should actually be a
variable that can be set all right now
we can go ahead in here and say we have
a struct of dog and it has a name you
can now see that we'll get an error now
from Swift saying that this doesn't
conform to has name and we can ask it to
fix it for us and you can see by default
it creates these variables for us
however what I really don't like about
this is that what it did is that it
created a variable for name so it could
actually be a let since the protocol has
name asks for this variable to be at
least and at most actually in read-only
so we can just demote this to a let's
variable and you'll see that everything
will work as expected okay so let's go
ahead in here and then create an
instance of this dog
and we can call this instance woof let's
say woof is an instance of dark and we
say name is with
an H is a very graceful ten then we say
with that name all right and with that H
wolf dot h plus equal one so we just
increase the age but we cannot change
the name all right so let's just woof
agent here as well so let's see what
happens okay and this I mean we're
getting these errors right here because
we can't modify woof because it's an
instance of a structure which by default
becomes a left constant that cannot even
have a mutation internally so we have to
change this to A4 so remember structures
are different from classes all right
so this is basically a protocol that
required all its uh classes or
structures that conform to it to have a
variable call name that can at least and
at most be read from so it can be a let
and it can also be a VAR but why does it
have to be a VAR a promotion of let if
we don't have to have it as a bar
because the protocol says I should just
be able to get from it now you may be
thinking okay but why do we do these
things well the reason is if you want to
go ahead and add functionality to this
protocol then this protocol internally
has access to name and age let's say
extension has name and then we can then
create a function that says describe me
then we can see we can say you your name
is name and you are
age years old
okay so since this protocol expects a
name variable and an age variable and it
can then go ahead and read them so it
can access them and it should also be
able to set them okay and then you can
say func increase age and in here then
you can say self h plus equal one and we
can fix this actually now
so you can basically go ahead and add
functionality to your protocols let's
say fix it and we add a mutating
function in here so you can see this
protocol since it knows what it requires
all its uh classes and structures that
conform to it have to have these values
then it can go ahead and take advantage
of those variables or functions or
whatever it has okay so now all of a
sudden all objects are conformed to have
has the name protocol will get a
describe me function let's go ahead in
here and say woof you can see it has a
describe me function all of a sudden and
it will say oops okay here
your name is woof and you are 11 years
old okay and maybe this should actually
return a string
and it could just return that string
instead of printing it here and in here
then we get the result you can see it
says your name is Wolf and you're 11
years old and then since we have a VAR
with uh pointing to a structure we can
go ahead and say woof dot increase age
and then we say wolf h all right so the
H by this point is 11 and then we in we
invoke this increased age function which
is mutating function and then we get the
age of 12 all right so protocols can
Define kind of um constraints or kind of
like an interface on objects that
conform to them and therefore can using
extensions on those protocols can access
those variables and functions which are
placed in here so it's kind of like
giving a blueprint so it's kind of like
any object that conforms to me has has
to have this blueprint and then I can
internally use that blueprint to my
advantage okay
now just we've just like we've seen this
in here protocols can have mutating
functions something that I want to
mention next but I think I just
mentioned a little bit too early perhaps
but at least you get the point let's now
focus on that mutating function so if
you say protocol vehicle I just want to
show you another example
and let's say we have a variable speed
and we say it should be an integer which
is getter and Setter so we should be
able to set it and read from it okay
then we create a mutating function here
increase speed and we say buy which
value like this okay so we Define this
mutating function here and then we go
ahead and extend this vehicle
like this and we implement this mutating
function all right so what we did here
was a little bit um is not optimal
because we implemented a mutating func
increased age inside the extension so
whoever looks at our protocol won't
immediately understand that there is a
mutating funk available on it so if you
wanted to make this code a little bit
more readable we would place this
function a declaration here as well okay
so let's go in our code again and we say
in the implementation of our protocol
increase speed by value will actually
have an implementation that's a
self.speed is plus equal to Value like
that and we can bring this value down
here to make the code a little bit more
readable as well
and perhaps decrease the size of the
preview as well
so let's then go ahead and create for
instance a a concrete implementation of
this vehicle protocol so we say struct
bike and then bike it will have a speed
oh let's actually move this and say it
is a vehicle all right then we get an
error from uh Swift saying that it
doesn't conform to Vehicles simply
because it didn't have the speed
variable then inside this bike we create
an init and we say self dot speed is
zero you could have also done it like
this
that also works it kind of depends on
how you like to implement and do your
implementations I've seen both and for
me both are fine it's up to you and your
team to actually make a decision on what
uh can what convention you want to use
for initializing your variables and
structures okay but this is completely
valid syntax as well
after doing that let's create an
instance of this byte let's say bike is
an instance of bike like this then we
get the current speed it should be zero
because that's what the initializer did
then we say bike increase speed by 10
and then we say bike speed all right so
because we are conforming to the vehicle
protocol we can have access to this
increased speed function in here now I
can see we're getting an error simply
because a bike cannot be mutated you can
see we're actually invoking a mutating
function on an immutable let constant
and the solution to that is to change
this to VAR all right now you can see
our speed was zero and then it was
increased to 10 simply because we
increased it using this mutating
function defined and implemented on the
vehicle protocol all right
so that's one thing I mean that's not
one thing that's quite a lot of things
about protocols but at least you get the
idea of protocols now protocols can also
be used as a conformance uh how do you
say it blueprints kind of so
let me just explain how this would work
you can at any point in Swift use the is
syntax or a keyword in order to check
whether an object conforms to a protocol
or not because any class or any
structure can conform to at least one
and actually not at least at least zero
and at most unlimited number of
protocols so a structural class doesn't
have to conform to any protocol or it
can conform to one or more protocols
that's what I'm trying to say and if you
want to at any point check whether an
object conforms to a protocol you can
use the is syntax let's have a look at
that let's say we create a function
called describe and it takes an object
of type any and we haven't talked about
this before but any is pretty much as
its name indicates any object okay then
we say if object is a vehicle then we
say uh object conforms to
their vehicle protocol
else object does not conform to the to
the vehicle protocol all right then we
can go ahead and call this describe
function and describe our object of bike
and then you can see since by conforms
to the vehicle protocol then we get this
printed to the screen however if we had
a structure of warm or at work warm and
it didn't conform to the vehicle
protocol and we sit warm as an instance
of warm and then we just say describe
more then you can see that we will get
this message printed to the screen
object does not conform all right so now
that we've done that let's just remove
this warm I don't like to have worms in
my coat
so at least you get the point now with
with that as well
now there's one more uh one more thing
that we have to talk about when it comes
to protocols and that is I mean we've
talked about is but we haven't talked
about as and as with a question mark and
they make more sense when we when we've
already talked about optionals and we
haven't talked about optionals yet we'll
talk about optionalism in like the next
three sections of this video but I just
want to name it as well so you know that
it exists in Swift so
using this as syntax you can
conditionally promote an object to a
specific type so in here you can see
object is vehicle and if you say object
dot you don't have any anything to do
now with this I mean you cannot do
anything with this object even though
you actually said if object is a vehicle
then I kind of would expect us to be
able to invoke these functions on that
vehicle because we actually asked Swift
is it a vehicle then we come here but
Swift doesn't understand the syntax as
good as it understands as like this and
the reason behind that is You're simply
just doing an if statement in here
saying is it that then do something but
you didn't actually promote this object
to that type all right so any is like a
very low object type however this is
sitting a lot higher in the hierarchy
and that's the reason we say promote
so let me actually show you an example
let's say that we have
uh that we have let's say a bike in here
and bike is a vehicle which has
increased speed all right but we want to
create a function that that can allow
any object to come in and if that object
is a vehicle kind of like this then it
will increase its speed by 20. all right
so let's say funk
increase speed if vehicle
and then the parameter to this is an
object of type any all right then in
here we say if then we create a VAR and
the vehicle is equal to this object and
then we say is it
a vehicle like this with an as syntax if
it is then we say vehicle speed you see
now we get access to all properties of
that vehicle because we promoted this
object to a vehicle so it's not similar
to is
because this won't allow us to access
the vehicle objects and hear our
Properties or functions then we say get
the current speed vehicle increase the
speed by 10 and then get the speed again
in here okay otherwise we say this was
not a vehicle so let's then go ahead in
here and see what happens so let's say
increase speed
if vehicle and then we pass our bike in
here all right let's see what happens
are we getting a lot of Errors perhaps
from Swift it crashed no okay so you can
see we got the value of 10 in here okay
and then we get the value of 20. right
here okay
now you may be thinking about what
happened in here bike let's have a look
at bike you can see its speed it was
zero in here and then 10. and then we
call this function which should have
increased the speed to 20. but if in
here we say bike speed what happens do
you think it's 20 well no it is 10
actually and the reason behind that is
that bike is an instance if you go back
to it is an instance of a structure
called bike so it's a structure
structures are value types meaning that
when you call this function with an
instance of your bike you're not
actually passing the memory consumed by
this bike as a reference to this
function what are your what are your in
fact doing is that you're making a copy
actually not you directly but Swift is
doing it doing that Swift is making an
entire copy of this is making a copy of
this entire object and passing it in
here so in here this VAR actually is
pointing to not the same memory address
that bike is consuming but it's pointing
to a completely new variable in the
memory and is allowing it to basically
be increased by a certain speed which is
not affecting the spike however if this
bike was an instance of a class so if we
went in here and said bike is actually a
class let's say class now you can see
calling this function it will actually
change the speed for you to 20. so
calling this function it affects the
actual instance of bike itself see the
speed is exactly the same but if you go
back to a struct you can see the speed
of your bike will be 10. all right so
keep that in mind when you're working
with protocols protocols and classes and
structures together go really hand in
hand to create amazing object oriented
applications in Swift but they can make
things also a little bit complicated so
keep that in mind when you're working
with these um
with these Concepts
good that's quite enough about protocols
now that we've talked enough about
protocols let's go ahead and talk about
extensions you've already seen examples
of extensions and how they work in Swift
but we haven't really focused on them so
let's do that now let's go oh I don't
have to do that let's create a new
playground playground and in here we say
blank playground and we say extensions
all right like that
and here as well then we say create
and just like usual we say we just need
foundation for now all right
so extensions as their name indicates
they can add functionality to existing
types they can extend existing types so
let's have a look at an example let's
say that we have an extension on data
type of integer and then we say we have
a function called plus two which returns
an integer and since this function is an
extension of int self in here refers to
the current integer instance okay then
we say we return self plus two all right
then we can go ahead and say 2 is equal
to value of 2 and then we say 2 plus 2
and then you can see then we get the
value of 4 here in our playground okay
so self inside extensions refers to the
current instance meaning that this two
in this case all right so self in here
is actually two so if you just print
self and then you say return self
self plus two you can see self is indeed
the value of 2 in here which is what
you've specified here so if you change
that self will change to that as well
all right so keep that in mind that's
one example of an extension
Now using extensions you can also add
initializers to existing types which is
one of the most powerful features of
extensions in Swift let's have a look at
an example let's say that you create a
structure called person in here and you
have a first name
string and then let's last name last
name as a string okay now what you want
to do is to create a I mean you want to
behold and sorry you want to hold on to
this person's Constructor or initializer
that Swift already creates for you with
the first name and last name so you
don't want to change that but you also
want a Constructor that takes in a full
name however if you go in here and say
init full name screen
then you can see all of a sudden your
person doesn't have any other
Constructor with a first name and last
name anymore your only Constructor
inside the structure itself will replace
the existing Constructor okay and that's
not good so what you want if you want to
for instance have a Constructor
initializer on this person that doesn't
replace the existing in initializer that
Swift creates for you then you need to
create an extension on person
and then you go ahead and add your
initializer in here okay now you can see
if you try to initialize an instance of
person you have both of these
Constructors the default one that Swift
created for you and also your own
Constructor which is inside the
extension all right so let's inside this
Constructor go ahead and grab the
components out of this full name so we
say full name
components is a function and we separate
the components by space all right and so
we say let components and then we want
to pass these values that we extract
from components so we say self in it
into our Constructor then we say the
first name is actually components first
otherwise fully and we say in here as
last name is components last otherwise
fully just like that all right so this
is very dumb implementation to be honest
with you but I mean it's not too dumb
either it is literally taking the first
part of a name and the last part of a
name assuming that this is the first
name and this is the last name and
anything that is between them separated
by space is the middle name which we
don't care about in this instance okay
then we can go and create an instance of
person so left person is a person then
you can see we have both Constructors or
initializers and we're going to use full
name in here we say Foo and bar you can
see they're separated by space and the
first component is Foo and last name and
last components bar then we say person
first name and person dot last name all
right so that's another powerful future
of extensions in Swift in that you can
extend an existing structure for
instance and add a new Constructor or
initializer to it okay
now apart from that you can also extend
existing types and add conformance to a
protocol to an existing type so that's
also really cool so let's create a
protocol in here we call it Goes Vroom
okay so that's our protocol name
and this protocol what it does is that
it has a VAR room value and it's a
string and it should we should be able
to read from it okay and then we create
a function we say go vroom and then this
function returns a string now we go
ahead and extend our goes room and then
we add the default implementation for
this go vroom function and then we say
self Dot vroomvalue
goes room
so remember this is just a variable that
we know any instance conforming to our
protocol should have access to and then
here we're just adding the default
implementation for this code firm
function and returning this string as
its return value all right then we go
and create a car instance we say struct
car and this car conforms actually we
don't want to conform yet and in here we
say let's manufacture is a string and we
say let's model is a string as well I
guess this is just a simple car
structure
then we can say let model X is an
instance of car with the manufacture of
Tesla and its model is going to be X
and after creating this instance we can
go ahead and actually extend this model
X so we can say model X extension sorry
extension of car then we say car now all
of a sudden conforms to the Goes Vroom
protocol you will get an errand here
telling you that you're not actually
conforming to go Gold's room and the
reason behind it is that if you go to
ghost room you can see that we have two
requirements one is that we have any
type conforming to goes from protocol
has to have a variable called room value
that's at at most and at least readable
uh however Carr doesn't have that and
that's the error that we're getting in
here so let's just get Swift to fix it
and you can see it creates a computer
property in here called vroom value
which should return a string okay and
for our vroom value we're going to say
it is self manufacturer model
and self.model all right and then all of
a sudden this car instance conforms to
That Goes Vroom protocol meaning that
this model X all of a sudden gets a
function called go vroom and if you do
that you can see it says Tesla Model X
goes room and that's because vroom value
is a variable that is implemented on all
types that conform to God's room but
ghost room doesn't really know what this
value actually is it just extracts that
value and adds it here and then says
goods room however it is the conforming
types responsibility to return this
value and in this case the case of car
structure we're just saying manufacture
and then model X so it says Tesla Model
X goes through this part is provided by
conforming types such as car and this
part is provided by the ghost room
protocol itself okay
so you can also have I mean now now that
we've talked about that let's go to the
next concept and that is having
extensions on classes and with
convenience initializers so you can
actually extend existing data types and
add convenience initializers to classes
and not structures because structures
don't have convenience initializers but
classes can
so let's go ahead in here and create a
class and we call it my double so like a
class that holds on to a double variable
and we say VAR value double
and then we can say an initializer that
takes a value of double and we say self
value is value in here okay
now you can go ahead then is actually
this I don't think this needs to be a
VAR it can just be a let perhaps okay
and in here then we're going to go ahead
and create a convenience initializer and
which always sets this value to zero if
anyone initializes the instance of My
Double because at the moment if we say
let
let's go ahead Foo is my double you can
see that you always have to have a value
available and pass to my double
initializer but if you don't want to
have that you can extend your my double
class in here and say you have a
convenience in it in here that takes no
parameters and calls self in it with a
value of zero so this is literally
delegating its task to a designated
initializer in the my double class but
it is a convenience initializer that is
created inside an extension so you
that's one of the powers of extensions
you can extend an existing class and add
a new convenience initializer okay
so then you can go ahead and say my
double to create an instance of it and
then you can just say value all right
you can see now the value is zero this
is another fancy way I'm of basically
accessing the value you could have said
let my double is an instance
of My Double and then you could have
said my double dot value so that those
two lines of code work pretty much I
mean achieving the same thing okay
now apart from extending I mean not
apart from but I mentioned that
extensions can extend structures and
classes but guess what they can also
extend existing protocols so so you can
see in here we have a protocol called
ghost room and it has this go room
function you can go ahead and extend it
you can say extension goes room
and then in here you can add a new
function say go of room room even more
okay so this is just a ridiculous name
I'm completely aware of it but you can
um what I'm trying to say is that you
can extend an existing protocol as well
and add new functionality to it and by
doing this every data type that conforms
to that protocol would get your new
function by default so you don't have to
do anything okay then in here we just
say self room value
is vrooming even more like that okay
then all of a sudden model X that we
created in here which conforms to which
is an instance of car which conforms To
Go's room gets this new functionality by
default so then we can say Model X
go vroom vroom even more and then you
can see that value being printed to the
screen as well is rooming even more okay
so extensions are I would say one of the
most fun aspects of any programming
language and in Dart for instance
they're called mixins as well and
they're available in some other
languages such as rust as well so
they're really fun because they allow
you to make existing things and types
better they can kind of get out of hand
sometimes if you're like misusing them
in that when you're extending generics
types for instance you can just go crazy
with generics but as long as you're
comfortable and you and your teammates
are comfortable with those extensions I
would say go for it now we've talked
enough about extensions for now at least
let's go ahead and start talking about
generics which is a topic a lot of
developers try to avoid but I think you
need to embrace it because if you look
at most modern toolkits and Frameworks
such as Swift UI
they could have not been made possible
without generics Swift UI is pretty much
based entirely on generic types so I'd
say one of the best practices of
becoming a better developer is to
embrace generics learn how to use them
learn how not to use them and truly
don't be scared of them so practice
practice until you get the concepts and
then use them wherever you think and
your teammates think makes sense
so without further Ado let's start
talking about generic so I'm just going
to press command in here and say a
playground and we say generics
like this and ensure you're creating it
inside your workspace so Swift crash
course
and we create this generics uh
playground import foundation and we say
automatically run this all right I'm
going to get rid of the export to the
left hand side now generix is for me at
least it's used to avoid writing the
same function multiple times or writing
the same code multiple times all right
now
generics they kind of look a little bit
strange
but
they really at the end of the day once
you've written the code for generics you
can use them in so many different ways
and you will be amazed by how powerful
they are okay so what we're going to do
as the first example of generics I'm
actually gonna jump right in and write
kind of like a scary looking function
all right but what this function is
trying to achieve is that I mean its
mission statement is kind of like this
it wants to expect any numer any
numerical data such as a floating value
or double value or an integer two of
those values so it takes a left hand
side and a right hand side and it
expects us to pass it a function that
can perform an operation on those two
values and return a new value in
response such as let's say x x is 10 and
let's Y is 20 and then we say let's C is
equal to X Plus y so this plus function
takes a left hand side and a right hand
side and returns a result which is the
equivalent of adding those two values
right
now you can have minus in here you can
have division in here it can have
multiplication oops if I can write it so
all these functions take a left hand
side and a right hand side so they do
some operations and they're actually
operators we've talked about operators
before okay so let's say then we create
a function we say a function that
performs
a task and we say
it's an operator that takes an integer
and an integer and returns an integer
kind of like this okay
and then oops and then we say it
performs this operation on a value
on left hand side of type int and
and right hand side of type int and then
in itself returns int okay so you can
see it's performing an operation that
actually does the job I think they
actually did something like this when we
were talking about operators and we
actually put this as a trailing closure
I remember but it's similar to that at
least and internally what it does is
calls that op function and passes the
left hand side and right hand side to it
and returns this value in return
then you can go ahead and say perform
Plus on 10
and 20. and then you can see it will
just say 30 as a result because this is
actually a function all right and you
can say plus and then you can say minus
of course you can say multiplication in
here
and you could also say division in here
okay
so maybe we could say 20.
and 10 in here for the division so that
we get proper values printed to the
console
so this is an example of this function
now your teammate comes to you and says
could you make this function work with
doubles as well then be like um okay
then I'm gonna change this to double
and this two double
and then this to double and then you
have to go and change this to double and
this to double and this to double
then your code kind of works all right
but the result of these is actually now
a double so if you look at Foods data
type is a double what happened to your
integers well you change the function
signature from int to double and you
lost the ability to work with integers
then you'd be like okay then I need two
functions one for integer m one for
double then you call this perform int so
we say let's see if I can change this
name perform int and then you say okay
I'm smart enough I go ahead and create a
perform double and I make sure that this
double works with doubles okay so
whoever wants to work with doubles calls
perform double and whoever wants to work
with integers works with uh perform int
then your third colleague comes and says
okay but I want to work with CG float
and which is another data type which is
inside the core Graphics framework which
we haven't worked with right now but you
can say core graphics and then you can
say let X is CG
CG float is equal to one it's kind of
like a double actually
and then you say oh a CG float then I
have to create another perform function
which is called perform CG flow
however as you can see this is not a
very maintainable way of working so this
will just increase the size of your code
base and you have to constantly go ahead
and add new functions to your
application
wouldn't it be really good if we could
create a function that works with any
numerical type
and if you look at integer let's go to
anything here and then we see signed
integer and then side numeric you can
see that this sine numeric protocol
conforms to another protocol which is
called numeric okay and if you have a
double value let's say let's X is a
double 1.1 if you go to double and let's
say numeric
there should be an extension on double
extension double which makes it conform
to a
that's numerical type as well so let's
say binary floating point I think and
then expressible by Flo oops not that
long perhaps
by integer literal hashable so stridable
it is one of these implementations
which conforms double
to add that numerical type that we were
just talking about I'm not sure which
one it is we have to dig deep inside
Swift source code basically
but what I'm trying to say is that both
double uh and int conform to a protocol
called a numeric numeric
now if we could somehow in here say that
this function works with any numerical
data type that would be really good so
let's change this to numeric
and then we say numeric numeric and here
here and here okay
now you'll see what happens inside your
sift code and Swift tells you okay I
understand you want to work with the
numerics but you can't just add them
like that you can't just say that this
function expects numerics numeric is a
protocol and if you want to use it here
you have to use generics so the way to
use generics is that you go right after
your function name and you just open
these less than an equal signs kind of
like in here then you designate a letter
usually a letter but sometimes people
use words as well but it is very very
common to use a letter so you say Okay I
want to represent numeric with a letter
okay I can't just say new American here
because that is an existing data type
let's just say n okay as a numeric then
you say n should conform to numeric data
type or protocol then anywhere inside
your function signature where you're
using numeric just type n okay so in
here in here right there
there and also here and also for the
return value of your function
all right so now you see all of these
errors are going to go away so you can
see all of them went away and your
function still works and if I say let X
and then I look at the data type for X
you can see X it is understood to be an
integer but how you didn't say anywhere
that you're working with integers
and that's the power of generics the
compiler is uh is basically inferring
the data type based on the values you
pass here so if you say 10 and 20 then
it knows that they both are integers and
the result should be an integer and
let's change this actually it's not
perform int anymore it is perform okay
now if you go and do and let's say let's
X is perform on 10.1 and 20.2 all of a
sudden X is a double because compiler
understood that oh these both values are
actually double they're not integers
anymore so it substitutes the return
value which is indicated by this n
generic value to the actual values you
pass through this function in here okay
and you can also go ahead in here and
say 10.1 and 20 what do you think X is
going to be now
well the compiler is also intelligent
enough to promote the value the return
value to the more complex or more
complete data type the more complete and
precise data type in this case is not
integer but it is actually double so if
you look at the data type for X is
indeed double all right so that was the
first example of using generics in Swift
and I know it could look a little bit
complicated but the more you work with
generics you the more you will actually
appreciate them
we've now seen this example I would say
actually a quite a simple example of
generics in Swift now when you have
functions that have multiple generic
parameters in this case we have just one
generic parameter that we've called n of
type numeric
but in other functions you might have
generic parameters maybe two two or
three of them or even more in that case
the function signature might be getting
quite long you would say R is something
and D is something else so looking at
this function you you would probably
just get a panic attack just looking at
the function signature and that is why
Swift allows you to create function
signatures for or generic function
signatures where the direct generic
parameters are stated at the end of the
function declaration itself and right
after actually the return type so to
demonstrate how that works as well let's
just take this that we have in here the
code that we have in here and let's go
and paste it right there okay and we
will just name this function and perform
two and change all these instances to
perform two just to ensure that
everything is working as expected so in
order to create a function or generic
function where the generic parameters
are defined at the anode function
signature you have to remove this
generate type right here or as many as
generic types as you have you remove
them from the beginning or attached to a
function name and you go right after the
return value and then Define them right
there using a word clause so in here we
then say where for instance n is numeric
so this is an alternative way of
creating a generic signatures for your
um or for your functions and in here you
would of course you would still have n
in there but you don't actually tag and
as a meaning of type numeric so this is
just a an alternative way of doing it
and some developers prefer this way
simply because in here you could just
say A B C D or your generic types and at
the end you could actually say what
those a b and c and d are in fact of
type of all right so just keep it in
mind it's it's a it's an alternative way
of defining your generic functions and
it will just perform exactly the same
way it did in the previous example okay
now any data types such as a class and
actually I can't say any data but
classes and structures in Swift can
conform to multiple protocols they don't
necessarily have to conform only to one
protocol okay and using this you can
basically create generics that are
um that are conformant to multiple
multiple types so let's have a look at
that right now and let's create
and let's create let's say that we
create two protocols in here we say
protocol can jump okay and then in here
we have a function that says jump so any
type that conforms to can jump should
have a jump function and then we create
another another protocol in here that we
say can run okay and can run has to have
a run function then we go ahead and
create a structure in here we call
person and we say it can jump and it can
run like that all right so this is
conform conforming a new structure to
two different protocols we can get a
swift to fix these functions up for us
in here you can see in run we say
running
and in Jump we say jumping jumping okay
I think the indentation was a little bit
wrong all right now we have that
now let's say that you want to create a
function called jump and run okay so
let's say flunk jump
and run and you want to take in a value
in here of some type you you want to say
Okay I want some value to be of any type
and in here I want to say value jump and
value the run but since this value at
the moment is of type any it cannot have
the ability to invoke that function jump
or the Run function so you could say
Okay I want value to be of type can jump
if you do this then you can do the jump
function but you can't do the run
function all right so in here what you
need to do is to go ahead and Define a
generic data type in here let's say t
and we say this data type can run can
jump and can run like this and then
inside the function signature itself you
say the value is of type T now you can
see if you type value you have access to
jump and run functions so this is a way
of combining multiple protocols in order
to create a generic function signature
where you have access to not only one
protocol data but also multiple as long
as basically you can make this as long
as you want to all right
so then we can go ahead in here and
create an instance of person we say
person is an instance of person and then
we can say jump
and run with the value of person and we
can actually change this values internal
sorry external parameter type to nothing
so we can just say jump and run person
in here okay
now you can also have extensions on
generic types and one generic type that
is very useful is actually we haven't
talked about them so much about their
arrays and I raise you to find them like
this you could say let names for
instance is Foo and bar now if you look
at the data type for names you can see
it is an array of string so it is
denoted by these square brackets now you
can actually look at if you just type
this is a string in here and let's see
if you can find the data type for array
so if you say array of strings so this
is this is a an alternative way of
writing the same same text instead of
this you can just do syntactic sugar
here and say array of string now if you
go to array you can see it is a
structure and it is a generic structure
basically it's working with a generic
argument called element
now you can also create extensions on
generic types so by simply saying
extension Offspring You're basically
extending an array of string and this is
new format actually there's a new syntax
in the latest Swift versions previously
you have to say extension array where
element
was equal to string so this is the old
syntax but the new syntax you can just
simply extend an array of string which
is a lot more readable okay then what
you can do in here since you already
have you've told the Swift compiler that
you're extending an array of string if
you create a function let's say we want
to create a function on our on any array
of string that finds the longest string
okay so we say longest string and we
return an optional string we haven't
talked about optionals yet so just for
now know that this means that we can
either return actually have we talked
about options structures enumerations
protocols extensions closures no we
haven't yet we will talk about optional
soon okay but just know that this means
it can either be a value or it can be
the lack of a value equal to nil all
right so and the reason behind is that
you can always have and the reason I
mean this is an optional string is that
any array like final names is an array
of string in here it can actually be
empty okay so if this array is empty how
can you find the late at the longest
string in this array well you can't
there are no strings in here okay
finally it should be let right so the
reason this is optional is because of
that
and then what you can do in here is to
say let dot
um so you sorry you say self-sorted and
this is I mean to be honest you don't
have to know exactly how this is working
and this is just an example okay so we
say sorted and then we say left hand
side string
and then we say right hand side string
and we want to say left hand sides count
the number of characters in the left
hand side should be more than the right
hand size characters and then we say
take the first argument you can see the
first argument is then deduced to be of
type string as simply because we are
extending a generic type whose elements
are of type string and if you look at
this property you can see it is using
the same generic type call Elements all
right so that's also extending generate
types and then you can go ahead in here
and say let's say
we create an array of strings we say Foo
bar and bads in here has one string and
then Cox in here then we say longest
string all right then we can get the
value of bar and pass it to the console
or the playground console whatever you
want to call it okay
then we have another topic to actually
discuss and this is this goes to a
little bit more
um I would say Advanced but I think
generics are Advanced topics to start
with so we shouldn't be scared of having
a look at some Advanced topics in here
so let's go ahead and talk a little bit
about Associated types in protocols okay
so and this is this makes generic
protocols we've already talked about
protocols before but we haven't talked
about generic protocols so let me just
show you an example and demonstrate how
generic protocols work in the beginning
it might not make so so much sense but
as we go on and complete this example it
will make hopefully more and more sense
to you okay let's create a protocol in
here we call it view all right so
anything that can that can be displayed
to the user and we call it just view all
right we say any view should have a
function on it that is called add sub
View and it is basically using the same
view so it says anything that's a view
should be able to add on another view to
itself alright then we go ahead and
extend this view we say it we had the
add sub view as a default implementation
in here and we say by default it is
empty all right so the end the default
implementation of add sub U doesn't do
anything then we go ahead and create a
structure in here we call a button and
we say it conforms to the view protocol
and at the at the moment we say it its
implementation is currently empty okay
if we didn't have this default
implementation of the add sub view
function then button structure would
have had to implement the add sub view
functioning here as you can see
suggested by the playground all right
so let's remove these comments from here
we go back to how we had it before
then what we're going to do in here is
to create a protocol and we say and we
want to basically represent every object
in our system that can be turned into a
view let's say you have a struct person
okay and then you say it has a name and
then you want to say I want to somehow
present this person on my user interface
and then you say okay I want to make it
presentable all right so you could
Define anything in your system that is
presentable as a View using a protocol
let's say protocol presentable as view
all right and this is kind of like
hypothetical at the moment but later in
this course we will actually talk about
mvvm in iOS or Macos and watch us using
for instance combine and Swift UI plus
RX Swift on RX Coco but for now just
this is a hypothetical protocol but it
is very real actually I use this in
production today so
and I just want to give you an example
of how this could look like all right
now if you want to turn a protocol to a
generic protocol you use a syntax or a
keyword called Associated type and using
Associated type is almost as if you say
presentable ads view has some sort of a
generic parameter but this syntax isn't
accepted and so if you get an error okay
you can actually see it says an
Associated type name V must be declared
so let's go ahead and Define this we say
Associated type and we say view type
should be any data type that conforms to
the view protocol you see what we did in
here we didn't just leave it empty we
said if something is presentable as view
its view should actually be be of type
view all right so it can either be a
button or it can perhaps be struct table
here's a view all right and maybe this
struck the person will conform to
presentable as view and say that my you
type is actually a table all right again
this is hypothetical at the moment at
least
then we say any object that is
presentable as view should be able to
produce a view for us to display the
user so we say produce view is a
function okay and this guy should
actually produce a view of type not view
but view type all right so if your view
type is for instance button then this
function should produce a button if your
view type is table then this function
should produce a table
then we can't go ahead and create the
next function in this protocol let's
let's just call it configure so we say
anytime we want to present a an object
as a view we can allow it to configure
itself using a super view as its
reference so super View and we say this
is a view as well and we save this view
is view type so we say the super view
could be any view but this view oops
type but this view should be is of type
view type which is a generic parameter
to this vertical okay and last but not
least then every object that is
presentable as view should have a
function on it that is called present
all right and in here we say view is
view type and then we say on super view
view all right so this view we're
already sure it is of type view type
because this configure function sorry
this produced view function actually
produces a view type and that same view
will be passed to this percent function
okay and a superview should be anything
that is a few okay so that that was the
X their protocol definition itself all
right let's go ahead and Define
implement it and basically do some
default implementation for some of these
functions inside this protocol so we say
extension presentable as View and now
this is a generic protocol simply
because it has an Associated type all
right then we go ahead and configure our
we write our configure function in here
so like that
let's just paste it in here and we say
it's default implementation is empty by
default all right then we will have a we
will implement the present function all
right like this and upon presenting a
view on a super view we just go to super
View and we say add sub view view all
right because we already know anything
that is a view has this add sub view
function on it so we just call it all
right then what we can do to make this
all very exciting we say we create a
button called my button which is
presentable as a view all right then we
know that this function and this button
has to have two function implementations
and they're the remaining two functions
actually we don't want to do that so you
can see presentable as view requires
four actually three functions it has a
produced View and it has a configure
Ampersand and these two functions at the
moment have default implementations
right here but the Purdue view function
doesn't have a default implementation so
you can go ahead in here and say that
you want to Define produce View
produce view okay and then we change
this and we say this actually returns a
button as we've defined it in here
button is a view all right and according
to our protocol implementation the
producer has to produce a view type that
conforms to the view protocol and button
does that it conforms to the view
protocol in here okay so inside produce
view we just say we return an instance
up button just like that all right now
what's going to happen is that you don't
have to implement anything else except
for this but if you want to go ahead and
for instance do it as configure function
in here so as soon as you start typing
it let's say configure you can see then
a swift understood that super view is a
view however this view is a button but
how they didn't understand the answer
button the reason is that we changed the
implementation of produce view so that
it produces a button then Swift went to
this protocol implementation in here and
said oh produce view is producing a
button so everywhere in this protocol
where I see view type I'm going to
replace it by button so it did this
pretty much button button and button you
can actually go ahead and test that by
adding for instance also at the present
function in here you can say present and
you can see superview the view is a
button so that's how generics work
basically in in Swift protocols okay so
it's very very simple when you look at
the whole thing but if you go into
details you can actually see there's
lots of things to learn about how
generics work with protocols especially
and Associated types so just know that
for now that protocols can become
generics using Associated types and
sometimes in Swift you need to know
about them and you need to use them but
if you're not working so much with
generics you probably don't have to
bother so much with Associated types but
again if you feel intimidated by
generics and Swift I think you need to
tackle that fear and go ahead and
actually play with generics so much that
you become so comfortable with them that
it becomes a part of your day-to-day
tool and day-to-day way of working with
swift okay
now if you want to extend generic
protocols just like you have extension
on for instance here and you can see we
have extension on this generic protocol
you can go ahead and actually
constrain your generic extensions to
specific types so let's say that you say
extension presentable ads View and then
you can say where view type view type is
equal to a button all right this way
you're training extension on any object
that conforms to presentable as view as
long as that object's view type is a
button if you did this let's see what
Swift says actually so we're just
creating a simple extension
Representatives view if you add a
function to this any object that
conforms to presentable svu's protocol
is going to get your extension values
and or variables and functions however
this way only presentable as view
conforming objects that have a view type
of button will get your extension all
right so let's say func do something
with button so we are adding a simple
function in here and we'll say this is a
button all right then let's go ahead and
create a button we say button is an
instance of my button and since my
button conforms to the presentable ads
view
protocol we can say button do something
with button right however if we went
ahead in here and set structure table is
also a view
actually let's go to my button and we
will just say my button is we copy that
code and we go ahead in here and we save
my table okay my table and in here where
we have button we create another struct
and we say table is a view and we say
it's empty as well all right then we go
back in here inside our my table we say
that my table produces a table and in
here we just create an instance of table
and we change this as well to table all
right so and we can remove the configure
function as well we don't have to have
it in there now if we go ahead and say
my table table is an instance of my
table if you say my table dot you can
see that you don't have access to to do
something with button function if you
want my table to have the same extension
do something with button and first of
all you'd have to change the name of
this function so you say do something
with view for instance
with View and then you also have to
remove this generic constraint from here
because my table doesn't produce a
button it actually produces a table then
your table my table will have to do
something with view function as well all
right so I hope that this makes generics
a little bit more clear
to us at at least by this point
now apart from all of this you can also
as I mentioned like when we saw this
extension on array of strings let's see
where we did that longest string okay
you can also create other extensions on
arrays even though there are generic
types such as for instance calculating
the average value of an array of
integers so you can say extension
int so any array and that contains
integers and then you can say a function
that calculates the average values and
we say double
and then we say self reduce this is a
special generic function on any array
and you start with a seed value and in
here you do your operation you basically
what it does is that if you have values
one two three four it says okay I start
with the value of 0. then I go to your
first element then I say 0 and 1. so
then we say Okay Plus them together it
says okay zero and one plus together
will be one then I will take this one
and I will go to the next element which
is two and I will do this operation
between these two one plus two is three
it says okay then I have three then I go
to the next element and say three plus
three okay six six is here and this is I
go to the next element six plus four it
will be ten all right so this is how
reduce actually works if you take the so
basically this com if you say lip XXX
and then in here we say XXX you can see
it's an integer but we want to grab the
average then we have to divide this with
uh the count of this array so self.count
and we have to convert all of these to
doubles so that they can actually
produce a double value in here okay
you can see now it is quite uh happy
with the code that we're written and
then you can say one two three and four
and you get its average all right and
you can see then the value printed to
the screen right here 2.5 all right so
if you had an array that was just like
two and two or four and four in here
then the average would actually be the
same value as you've entered in here 2
and 2 will produce two and four and four
will produce uh four okay so that's how
you can extend existing data types that
are generic such as race okay I really
hope that all of these examples made
generics make a little bit more sense to
you if they didn't I think it is
important that you go back and practice
generics yourself as well because
without practice generics will probably
never make sense
good we're done with generics let's go
ahead to the next section which is
optionals so I'm going to create a a
playground in here playground and we'll
say blank and we say options which is
also a very fun topic to talk about in
Swift so let's just do that
good and then in here we say import
foundation and let's just do this so
that it runs automatically as well and
let's get rid of our project uh Explorer
to the left hand side all right so
optionals indicate a value that might or
might not be present okay so let's say
that you want to take a value and
multiply it by two okay so let's create
a function that takes a value and
multiplies it by two so we say flunk
multiply by two in here and then we say
value
and you can see it's an integer and it
returns an integer as well all right
then in here you just say value
multiplied by two
in order to turn this data to actually
before I say in order to let me just
explain what options then would do for
this function and how they would make
this function perhaps a little bit more
fun to work with if you call this
function multiply by 2 you always have
to produce a value in here so you can't
just call this function empty we're
thinking that it will just produce zero
if you don't pass anything to it okay
you can see that it says okay you have
to pass a value to me in here then if
you don't want to do that if you just
want to say okay if a value isn't there
just assume it is zero okay what you
could do is to say okay value is
optional so you say it shouldn't it
doesn't have to be passed on here and
furthermore you can assign a default
value to it so you say value is an
optional integer that by default is not
present
then what you can do in here you say
if let's value so this is the syntax of
unwrapping an optional so you say if the
value is present then return value
multiplied by two otherwise return the
value of zero like this all right and
also there are other ways of actually
doing this in Swift so you can see now
this function works fine because it's
hitting this point since a flat value
syntax indicated that value is indeed
nil there are other ways of doing this
you could actually change this code to
this and do it like this you could say
it's an integer which by default is zero
then it will work exactly as it did but
I'm just trying to demonstrate how
optionals work and how a flat works it's
a little bit difficult to find
hypothetical examples for using
optionals which is a little bit a
complicated topic to explain and even
more complicated to find very trivial
trivial examples of how to use them all
right but let's just leave this example
as it is so now you can see that you can
call that function with either no value
values or you could say you pass the
value of nil and it will produce also
zero or you could say you pass a value
of 4 or 8 or whatever you want in here
and this function will still work so
even it works even with the value of nil
I don't know why our playground isn't
really running yet there we go so we got
our values okay
you can compare optionals with nil nil
is a special value meaning that the
absence of a value basically so you
could say let H is an optional integer
and it is equal to nil all right so it
is not present basically then you could
say if age is not nil age is there
how odd because we expected it to not be
there else H is now correct okay so we
kind of expect this Branch to be to be
executed right now and you can see that
it is okay so that's how you can compare
a value not being nil for instance okay
now if you want to take an optional
value and check whether it actually
exists or not you should use actually
not you don't have to use but you can
use the if flat syntax so you say if let
H if H is present then inside this block
after if let age is not optional anymore
so you can see it is right here okay so
then you could say h is there uh how odd
its value its value is H all right
otherwise no age is present as expected
because we know that age is actually nil
and we should get this uh printed two
that counts all right now apart from if
let's way of unwrapping and optional you
can also use another syntax which is
called guard and guard does the negation
of age basically so let's have a look at
how Guard works so let's say we create a
function in here we say check age all
right and in here we want to read age we
say we want H to be there if it isn't
then we're just gonna return from this
function within message but if it if it
isn't there we return with a message but
if it is there then we print something
to the console for instance so you could
say if age is nil then you could say age
is nil as expected all right
however there is another way of writing
this function and the way to do that is
you say this let's say that this entire
function depends on this age variable
right and however if you um if you type
a function if you type your code like
this anyone reading this code might not
fully understand that this age variable
is very important to this function's
signature or dysfunctions functionality
and that is why Swift has an alternative
way of doing this check so if your
function depends on some optional values
and it can't really continue without
those options optional values actually
be being present you need to perhaps use
the guard mechanism so in here you say
Guard age shouldn't be nil else then you
say age is nil as expected and then you
return okay so you're basically saying
make sure age is a nil if it is so this
else reads if it is then do this and
inside guard you always have to return
so if you don't return you actually get
an error so guards have this property
that they need to return and because
that's the whole point okay and also
using guard you can unwrap values as
well as we'll soon see so let's put this
card in here and then we say the rest is
age is not nil here strange because we
don't expect that and then we call the
check H function in here so we should
now hit this Branch because age is
indeed nil so we can't just guard that
it isn't nil because it is nil and it
will end up being here okay
Now using guard you can also unwrap
values because you can see in here if I
say let XXX is H and in here I say XXX
it is still an optional all right so
um even in here if I select XXX as H you
can see XXX is indeed optional integer
however in here we said make sure that
it isn't it isn't nil so it shouldn't be
integer so I kind of expect XXX to be an
integer all right but it isn't and the
reason behind it is that we're not
actually unwrapping this age we're just
making sure that it isn't nil but the
rest of the function doesn't understand
and the way to fix that is to actually
use garblet so let's say let's H2 int
optional and we actually set a value for
it we set a value on zero okay then we
create another function here we say
check age
two and in here we say guard let H2
otherwise so if we go in here and say
let XXX in here let's do a return and we
say XXX is equal to Age Two you can now
see XXX is an unwrapped integer it's not
optional anymore and that is simply
because we did a guard let all right and
then here we say age is nil how strange
and then we return and then in here we
say Age Two is not nil as expected uh
value is equal to
Age Two all right so this H2 in here is
not uh this Valley anymore really it is
unwrapped within this function all right
then we can call this function as normal
we say check H2 check H2 and we should
then hit this line in here and you can
see the value of H is indeed printed to
the console value is zero you can change
it to 10 if you want to and you can see
that value being printed to the console
as well all right so that's another
syntax for guard using guard let for
actually unwrapping an optional
now optionals are actually an instance
of an enumeration this enumeration is
called optional unsurprisingly so just
like you can switch on option on
enumerations you can switch on options
so you can in here go ahead and say
switch age all right and you can get
help from Swift to complete these for
you this search statement you can go in
here and say fix it for me you can see
this optional uh enumeration actually
has two cases let's see if we can find
it enum optional there we go and it
either is the value of none meaning that
it is nil or it has some value inside it
all right so in case of none let's just
say age has no value as expected in case
of sum we can unwrap it and say let's
say value and we say age has the value
of value like this and we can break in
here as well break okay so age was nil
if you remember so we kind of expect to
hit this casing here which is none and
it says age has no value as expected all
right so that's how you would switch
basically on an optional value you can
also go ahead and do simple comparisons
so if you could say if H2 for instance
is equal zero so you could do that then
you say H2 is 0 as expected and it's not
the nil and let's go to H2 and actually
make sure that it is zero so let's
change it to zero and in here we say
else age to
is not zero how strange all right and as
you can see the comparison is working so
you don't so what I'm trying to say in
here you can actually compare an
optional value with another value like
this without having to say if K slat or
is it let case or case let I I always
forget that so you don't have to unwrap
it using a case let's or using a switch
you can just compare it with an unwrap
value like this as well
okay now you can also just like we did
this comparison you can also compare
with the non or some cases so let's just
copy and paste that code in here then we
say if H2 is equal to sum
0 and then you say the same code in here
so this these two are equal to each
other I mean they're not equal but
they're identical to each other so it is
completely up to you how you want to do
this code and for me if I see this code
I don't assume that ah2 is optional but
is indeed optional and but if you write
your code for me I completely understand
that oh H2 is optional so this is a
little more descriptive of the problem
in hand so I actually would probably
prefer this but it is up to you and your
team to decide on a convention on which
one makes more sense to you okay now you
can also do optional something called
optional chaining and and that means you
optionally access optional Properties or
methods of some classes or structures so
let's create an example for it we say
struct person
and we say let's name the string and we
say left address is let's actually not
do that at the moment let's inside this
structure create another structure
called address okay and in here we say
let first line is a string and it's
optional all right so we if we have it
at an address then this first line might
not be present and also uh additionally
we go into person in here we say
addresses itself is optional so even if
it is present it doesn't have to have a
first line but if it's not present it
will be nil all right so it's like
optional within optional so this is
optional within this optional actually
the other way around uh address is
optional and within it there is another
optional property okay let's create a
person in here we say Foo is a person
and we say it is equal to an instance of
person with the name of Foo and its
address is nil we just say we don't have
an address okay then if we say we want
to get this person's first line of
address then we say if let Foo first
address line line is equal to Foo then
dot address and optional optionally grab
the first line all right so it means
address is optional we know about that
but go and grab its first line if it is
present then we say um
E flat okay
is equal to that
then we print it out through first line
otherwise we say Foo doesn't have an
address with first line
as expected so since we didn't have an
address for Foo at all then it shouldn't
even have a first line okay so this
address basically Swift stops right here
it says I can't go any further after
address because address it itself nil so
I can't grab the first line of it even
if first line did exist the address
itself doesn't exist okay so then we get
this message printed to the console now
we can go ahead and do another like an
alternative way of grabbing this value
is by first grabbing the address and
then out of the address grabbing the
first line it is a little bit more code
and I don't actually think you win so
much on it so I just wanted to show you
how you can do that as well let's say if
let Food address is food dot address so
you first unwrap the address okay and
then you say okay after that get the
first line as first line like this is
equal to full address DOT first line
then you can say Food address and then
you say first line all right but we know
that we don't get in here because food's
address is in fact nil so we don't even
go inside this code in here and not in
here either okay
now you can compare optionals using
chaining as well so let's go ahead in
here and Define a bar person we say bar
is an optional person actually and it is
equal to person whose name is bar and
whose address is in fact an address
instance with the first line equal to
nil all right so it has an address but
its first line is now
then we say if bars and you see we're
accessing bar using an optional like a
question mark simply bar simply because
bar in itself is an optional value if
bars name is equal to bar
and bars address first line is equal to
nil then we say bars name is bar and has
no first line of address okay otherwise
then we can say
um seems like something isn't working
right
because we know that Bar's name is
indeed bar and it has an address what
its first line is actually nil okay but
do you know this line of code actually
isn't saying that it has to have an
address but its first line should be nil
it could actually work as well it will
work as well if the entire dress is nil
so let's just change it to nil and you
can see still the same code will be
executed all right so that's how
optionality works it just continues
until it can't continue any further okay
now you can also switch on options with
word Clauses all right using an optional
chain so let's create a bass person in
here I'm just going to copy paste that
code so we don't have to create many
persons and this time it's an optional
person with an address that is present
and it has a first line as well all
right then we can go ahead and say
switch on the per on baz address first
line all right and in case we say in
case of a sum we say let at first line
and we just break in here and we say
case and none actually let's not do that
let's just say uh case first line and
then we can go ahead in here and add a
where Clause so this is pattern matching
and so we're saying okay if the first
line is available and using this word
clause is pretty much just saying and
and the first line starts with uh the
string baths okay then we say bad's
first address line is equal to
first line like that then we say case
let's sum and then we say first line and
we don't have a word clause anymore and
this one catches all then we say Bass
first address line
that didn't match the previous case and
then we print the first line all right
and then last but not least we also have
to cover the non case where the value
the optional value is indeed nil we say
bass first address line is new
and weird
okay because we already know that bass
is first address line is in fact Bas
first line and you can see this being
printed to the console it says Bas first
address line is bass first line as it
was in here so you can have where
Clauses in your case statements for
switching on optional
um enumeration or enum values okay
now you also can choose to um
if you're using a flat or Gauntlet and
you should do that uh as long as it
makes sense to you all right so let's
create a function in here let's say we
say funk get full name and then we say
we have first name as a string and then
we have a last name as an optional
string and we produce an optional string
as well all right then we say
we say that you have to have a last name
all right even though the function
signature says optional we say that okay
you should have one we said if let last
name
if we can unwrap it then we return
first name and name and space then we
say last name all right otherwise
otherwise we return nil all right now
that's one way of doing it so you can
just in here say get full name and for
first name we say Foo and for last name
we say nil then we call the same
function with uh Foo and bar as names
like this so this one has a last name of
Nils so it should end up being here and
you can see it's actually producing the
value of nil and this one has both first
name and last name therefore it is
returning Foo bar as this result so
that's one way of doing it but you can
also go ahead and use guardlet so if you
copy this code from here and then we go
and paste it right here we say get full
name two and in here you could say guard
let
last name otherwise
return nil
and then you switch these statements
basically all right so you basically the
way I usually read this is like this
make sure last name is present otherwise
return
and then do this otherwise basically
saying if last name is present okay so
after doing a guard let all statements
after that card let if we hit them in
that in those statements the value that
you unwrapped in here will be present as
a non-optional all right so that was
also short and sweet about optionals and
there's lots more to actually explain
about options and they pop up pretty
much everywhere in Swift and especially
Swift UI Azure as you as actually we'll
talk about Swift UI later in this course
as well but just know that they're there
you need to learn them if you're working
with Swift and it is very advantages if
you can really master optionals and suit
because they're pretty much everywhere I
hope you enjoyed this section of the
course as well and in the next core in
the next section we're going to talk
about error handling in Swift
now that we've talked enough about
optionals let's first do some cleanup
here in our workspace so I'm just going
to press command command W and close all
these tabs that we have opening here
there are quite a mini and they're not
really contributing to so much right now
rather they're just like making our
workspace look a little bit dirty so I'm
just gonna do command W in here and if
you're in Visual Studio code for
instance on Linux and or even actually
replace build build oh okay I don't know
what happened really and even if you're
on Linux and you're for instance having
Visual Studio code open with your Swift
files you can also close them if you're
not really interested in having them all
open at the same time so as mentioned
we're going to go and talk about error
handling right now so I'm just gonna
press command n and say blank in here
and playground and let's say error Dash
handling and I'm going to create it in
the main workspace in here as you can
see okay let's press create in here here
and say import foundation and like usual
we're going to go in here and say that
it should automatically run all our code
okay so error handling is one of the
most important Concepts in any
programming language that supports
errors and exceptions and really the
points of errors and exceptions are to
tell the the caller to our code or
whoever is using our code that something
has gone wrong it's either the failure
of the code that we've written such as
an error or it's the failure of the
person calling this function or code
such as an exception so there is a
little bit of a difference between
actually errors and exceptions in
different programming languages but in
Swift usually we only talk about errors
so meaning that the code found out that
something hasn't gone according to the
plans and then it throws an error and
actually the word for it is actually
throw in Swift indeed so there's a
keyword for it called Throw okay and it
is the same thing in many other
programming languages actually it is
called throw in Dart for instance as
well
so let's have a look at an example of
throwing an error in Swift and catching
it so we're going to create a person in
here let's see if I can spell struck
person and let's say we have a first
name uh it's an optional and we say last
name optional string as well okay then
we want to create a function in here
called get full name and this function
should ideally return a string okay so
we're going to say funk get full name
and we say it returns a string right
however how can it return a string if
first name and last name are both
optional meaning that they could at any
point both be nil or one of them could
be nil and in those cases we cannot
produce a full name so the goal of this
function is to return a string it
shouldn't really return an optional
string because the full full name
shouldn't be optional then what we're
going to do in here we're going to say
okay it is going to try to produce a
string but it may actually throw so we
say throws okay so the function throws
but inside is it will throw all right so
that's how the how the verb and the noun
basically work
uh actually I think it is a noun yeah so
the function is marked as thirds meaning
that internally it can throw an error
now we're going to go ahead and Define
our errors inside this structure then
you don't have to Define them inside the
structure or the class that throws them
but it is usually good practice to
Define them within their enclosing
structure or class so so to associate
the error objects with that structure or
class okay so we're gonna go and say
enum errors for instance it doesn't have
to be colors you could call it Myers or
person errors whatever okay person
errors also works but in here we're just
going to call it errors and we need to
ensure that this enum conforms to this
error protocol okay you can see it is a
public protocol okay so you cannot throw
errors that are not
um actually your enum if you're actually
going to throw its cases the entire enum
needs to conform to the error protocol
so that's their role basically
that we're going to see the first case
of the error is for instance first name
is nil we're going to say then last name
is no
and we're going to say case both names
are nil so these are the available
errors that this function can throw so
these are the three things that can go
wrong either the first name is no or the
last name or both in any other case
means that name and last the first name
and last name are not nil and we can
calculate the full name successfully all
right so as option as we've actually
learned in the optionals section of this
video optional data type is a it is an
enumeration meaning that we can do
switch on them so if we want to
basically learn whether these two are
both not nil you could either do it like
this a flat first name and let's last
name then you can produce the first name
and like this first name and then last
name
this then you should say else if first
name is nil and last name is not nil
then you should say throw
and you say errors
first name is nil then you have to do a
lot of else statements in here to
understand okay first name wasn't nil
last name was nil and then throw uh last
name is no and if both of them are
nailed then do this so it's a lot of if
and else statements instead of all of
that we can just do a simple switch
statement in here okay so let's just say
we switch and we say we switch on the
first name and last name alright so this
is the first name we're doing is switch
on two enums at the same time all right
so the first case and we want to handle
one third both nil so we say case the
first one is none and the second one is
none okay in this case both names are
nails so we say Throw errors
both names are name the next case we
want to make sure that
um we want to basically see if the first
name is nil but the last name is not
milk so we say first name is nil and the
last name is not mil remember sum and
non-30 cases of optional so if you go in
here do you remember these none and some
some meaning that there is a value so
we're saying that there is no value for
first name but there is some value for
last name in the case I'm not having a
first name then we throw an err and we
say first name is no
then we reverse these so we say in here
we take this non we say the first name
is sum value but the last name is no
values and then we say last name is no
and in the other case then we say in the
case of actually having a first name and
last name so we say case let sum first
name
and some last name
in here then we can calculate we say
return and we return a string with the
first name and last name in here just
like that okay so this is this is like
some sort of a pattern matching you
could say in Swift and pattern matching
in Swift is very powerful I mean I would
say it's even more powerful than pattern
matching for instance in Rust which is
also in its in its own very powerful but
Swift has some really neat features when
it comes to power matching with switch
statements for instance okay
okay so let's go ahead now and create an
instance of this person's structure we
say let's oops can I spell let's Foo and
we say person
and for the first name we're going to
say Foo and for the last name we're
gonna say nil all right so now we want
to go ahead and grab the lat the full
name of this person and knowing full
well that the last name is no meaning
that we're gonna get into this case
actually no sorry this case last name is
no all right
so how do we do that because if we go
ahead and say let full name is uh Foo
get full name get full name you can see
that we're going to get an error from
Swift saying that actually it's very
important that we see this in error it
says call can throw but is not marked
with try it says Well it can't throw
basically it can throw an error but
you're not trying to resolve that error
so the key word for trying to resolve I
know or trying to actually call a
function for instance that can throw the
keyword for it is try okay so you say
try however we're gonna probably get
another error now and it says well it
crashed so the entire playground pretty
much crashed and the reason is that this
function through but we tried this
inside a inside a context that doesn't
have error handling so if you're using
try then you need to be inside a context
in where in which you're handling your
errors and that type of context is
created with the do keyword so you say
do and then you place this code in here
okay and in here then you can go ahead
and say catch and then you say got an
error and there is an internal error
object in here which is just called
error okay and you can see now we are
getting this in here and says God error
and it says last name is no so this is
according to what we basically expected
okay so just remember do and catch and
inside the cache block if you don't
specify anything in here and like let's
e or something because then we're going
to get e in here if you don't specify
how you want to catch in into which
variable there is an internal hidden
variable called error inside every catch
statement okay
good now if you also want to I mean this
this just catches every error any error
pretty much okay so if you go in here
and say
Foo and the first name and last name for
it is nil now you see you catch another
error that's called both names are nil
okay but what if you want to catch
specific figures you don't want to catch
every error you want to catch for
instance specific errors you can you can
say I just want to catch person errors
okay and any other error that happens in
here I don't want to catch it because
remember inside the do statement you can
actually have a lot of code you can have
a lot code in here and you can say let
blah is try something else okay and any
of these statements that have tried
before them they can throw and they then
those errors that are thrown could be of
different types So within the do
statement you can have multiple uh lines
of code Each of which can also throw
different types of Errors if that is the
case how can you catch specific errors
and the way to do that is using the is
keyword after catch I'll show you so
let's copy this in here that we have and
paste it and then we put the full name
in here just so that we get the full
name printed to the screen if if any but
we already know that there will be no
full name and in here we're going to say
catch is person.heirs
I like this
okay and you can see in here this
statement is still I mean let's see here
okay we're gonna get rid of this one
because we already know that is a person
error okay
so we have pattern matching basically on
our catch and we can't actually grab the
variable out of it anymore so we we
detected that it's a person error and
then the error variable isn't available
to us anymore after doing this pattern
matching okay so this is how you would
look for specific types of errors in
your catch statements all right now you
can also catch specific errors I mean
here you're basically matching the error
against a type but then you would be
asking yourself well but how do I know
which one of these errors it is okay and
you can actually catch specific errors
just by typing catch which error okay so
let's copy this code actually maybe
let's create an another variable in here
we say let bar equal to person and in
this case we say both first name and
last name are nil all right like this
then we're going to copy this code that
we have in here and right after bar
we're going to paste that and we say
full name is bar get full name all right
and then in here inside catch we're
going to change this code that we have
and instead we say catch person errors
and a first name is nil then we say
first name
is no like that
and then I copy I'll copy this and I say
we also want to catch last name is no
and we say last name is no then we say
okay we also want to catch person dot
errors both names are now and we say
both names are nil and otherwise at the
end we have a catch all Block in here
let me say some other error was thrown
okay so now this now you see you can
we're basically getting this error in
here both names are nailed as expected
first name and last name or not are
basically nil okay so this is how you
can catch specific errors as well this
is how you can catch air types like
errors of this type but inside this we
already know that we have three specific
errors and if you want to catch any of
those specific errors you can do do just
catch and that that specific here okay
so that's another way of handling errors
now we've had a look just at one
function at the moment that can throw
but uh you can also do you can basically
throw errors inside Constructors as well
of structures or classes meaning that
you try to construct an object but the
parameters that you're passing to that
object are somehow not valid and so as
you know the Constructor or initializer
of classes and structures have complete
rights to do some validation on the data
that you're passing to them if those
data for some reason are not correct
according to the validation of that
structure or class then the class or
structure should be able to throw okay
and I'll show you now how you can Define
throwing
initializers or Constructors for
structures and classes so let's create a
struct car in here okay and then we say
let manufacturer and this manufacturer
is a string
then what we want to do is to create a a
Constructor or initializer for this car
that looks at the manufacturer that you
pass to us and if it is empty then it's
going to throw an error because at the
moment you can say my car is a car with
a manufacturer of empty string and this
is not valid according I mean to our
rules you shouldn't have a card that
doesn't have a manufacturer okay so we
want to basically catch this case we
want to see okay when you pass the
manufacturer to the structure is it
empty if it is then we want to throw an
error so let's go ahead and Define that
error first so we say enum errors and of
course we have to conform to the error
protocol and we say case invalid
manufacturer it is a very complicated
word to type in my opinion then we go
ahead and we say okay we have an
initializer in here which takes in the
manufacturer okay so I'm just going to
copy this so I don't have to type it
anymore and then in here we say this
init function and it or initializer
actually throws and then we say if the
manufacturer is empty then throw errors
dot invalid manufacturer otherwise self
manufacture is equal to that
manufacturer okay so you can see then we
don't have a problem in here the only
problem actually we have is that we're
now calling this now Swift understands
that this call to the initializer of car
is throwing but we're not trying it okay
so let's go ahead and do a try on this
so we say do and we say we catch car
errors
invalid manufacturer and we just have a
catch Hall case in here as well so we go
into the do and we say try this code and
in here then we say invalid manufacturer
and we say some other error just like
this okay now you should be able to see
that we get this invalid manufacturer
and pass in here so now the important
thing is also that if you're inside this
do clause
and after this try statement you can
definitely use my car so you can say my
car that manufacturer do whatever you
want with it but you already know that
none of this code is going to be
executed because the way we're calling
this car or the initializer of the car
structure is that it's going to throw so
it's never going to reach this code in
here so Swift reads this code goes and
calls the Constructor and it gets to
this throw and just immediately jumps
out of this into its catch statements
and says okay do I have any cash that
matches the error that was just thrown
yes and it then comes here and it
doesn't even go here okay so you need to
kind of follow the path of the program
to understand what is happening really
now you sometimes may not really care
about the errors that are being thrown
from functions or initializers for
instance and the way to do that is that
you want to grab the value of a function
optionally so you say if this function
is successful gets me the value for it
so you don't actually care about the
errors okay so let's go ahead and have a
look at the syntax where and syntax work
is using a flat okay so you said if let
your car is equal to try with a question
mark so this is simply try with a
question mark simply means that you
don't have to have a do and catch
statement it says optionally try to call
this function and if it is successful
then give me the value back okay so we
say Tesla and then we have access to we
say success
your car is a your car like this
otherwise we say failed to construct and
error is not accessible now so if you do
this statement in here so you can see
we're passing Tesla actually to the
Constructor for our initializer for car
therefore this logic is not going to be
called and and a proper instance of car
will indeed be created meaning that we
will indeed come in here inside the
success block all right so we optionally
try to call this function if it was
successful if it didn't throw then we
come here and then we have full access
to this variable all right otherwise we
get to this clause and as you can see
I've typed in here in here we lose
access to the error that was actually
thrown so we don't have access to the
error object really in here okay so
that's how you can optionally try to
call a function that throws and grab its
value
now you can also in some very rare cases
very angrily try to unwrap a the value
of a function that can throw
please know that in in all my years of
working with Swift I haven't done this I
know that it is available but you you
and you should as a swift programmer
know that it exists but you should
almost never ever use it but and the
reason behind it is that this code as I
said angrily unwraps a function that can
throw meaning that your program or your
application or your IOS app or watch OS
app or Mac OS app will indeed crash
completely and completely close should
the function that you're invoking
actually throw an error and the Syntax
for it is not with an optional try it is
indeed with a a how do you call this
actually exclamation mark okay so let's
go ahead and have a look at this we say
let their car
is equal to try and we say car with a
manufacturer of Ford and you can see now
this will indeed be a valid um car
instance and I can say their car that
manufacturer nothing really happened and
you think okay but why did he say that
you should never use the syntax and the
reason is that
should this manufacturer be empty this
whole playground will crash and it will
just you can see in here and encounter a
crash and could not finish executing
this same thing will happen to your app
and what whether it's a Mac OS or iOS or
and watch OS app your app will
completely crash it won't look as pretty
as it did in the playground because the
playground it still was open but it just
told you that it crashed if it is in a
real application the application will
just completely close and the user will
be baffled by what just happened so
please don't use the syntax try to
always do I mean ideally you should do
do and catch if you can't do that please
do try and please never try this never
tried this way of unwrapping values
unless there is a very compelling reason
for it that you and your teammates for
instance are completely comfortable with
okay
now we've already looked at throwing
errors from functions but just know that
you don't necessarily have to throw a
specific type of error in here we have
just one enum and then here we also have
just one enum that Define our errors but
a any function that is marked as throws
can't throw any error it doesn't
necessarily have to throw a errors from
just one enumeration so let me just show
you how that will look like let's create
a struct in here and we call it dog all
right
like this and inside this let me
actually create some empty spaces so we
can do this so inside the dog structure
we're going to create two variables one
is called is injured and is sleeping
okay so it is injured
injured Bull and uh let is
sleeping in here Boolean all right and
then we go ahead and we want to create
two functions a bark function and a run
function so let's say funk
Funk bark and Funk and we say run now
inside the logic of this dog structure
we're gonna say okay we're gonna bark
like this but we're only gonna bark if
we're not sleeping
all right so we're saying if is sleeping
like this then we want to throw on air
so let's go ahead and Define the error
for that so we say Ena barking errors
and we say error and in here we say
cannot bark is sleeping all right then
we say if you're if if you're asked to
bark and you're sleeping then we say
Throw barking hers uh cannot bark is
sleeping all right otherwise we bark and
then we do something similar for this
actually let's see what error we're
getting in here throw okay because this
function is not marked with throws so
let's just change that to throws and
we're also going to change this function
to throws okay
now we're going to go ahead and create
another enumeration in here and we're
going to call it uh running errors I
think let's just say enum running errors
errors error and then we say case cannot
run is injured
and we do the same thing in here so let
me just copy this code and put it inside
run and we say if is injured okay so we
cannot run if we're injured then we say
running errors cannot run is injured
otherwise we say running or run
something like that okay so I think you
get the point so you cannot bark if
you're sleeping or actually not you and
not me either it's the dog so the dog
cannot bark if it is sleeping and it
cannot run if it is injured
unfortunately okay so now that we have
those we will also go ahead and create
another function and we say funk bark
and run which combines those two
functions then we say try bark and try
run now what happened in here we just
said try without having it do and catch
what happened is that we're inside a
function that can throw and if you mark
your function as throws you can simply
just try things you don't have to wrap
them inside do and can
what happens is that if any of these
functions that we have inside bar can
run throws then this function itself
will throw so if you call this function
and you call Bark then Swift goes in
here and it says oh is it sleeping yes
then it throws this error
from this function and since that that
function was invoked from this function
then it will throw the error idea
essentially from this function out to
the caller okay so if you have a
function marked that throws inside it
you can try statements without having to
wrap them inside doing catch in some
rare cases you actually want to wrap
them inside doing catch because perhaps
let's say that your back-end developers
tell you that hey if someone calls this
function and this particular function
throws an error then I want you to
actually send an API request to the back
end to log that error because that
should never happen for instance okay so
then you can say do okay try and then
you say catch and in here you'll do your
API
okay you do your API call all right and
then you can actually rethrow this error
as well so and we probably will talk
about that soon as well
but just know that inside a throwing
function you can try your statements
without having to wrap them with that
within do and catch okay so let's go
ahead and create a little dog in here
that unfortunately is both sleeping and
injured so we say dog it's an instance
of dog which is injured and it's also
sleeping all right then we go ahead and
we create a do and catch Block in here
we say do and we say catch dog barking
errors cannot bark and also we want to
catch dog
sleeping errors actually what did we
have running here sorry running errors
and cannot run is injured okay so you
can see how we're catching both of these
errors at the same time just using a
comma and we'll also have a catch all in
here so we say cannot uh bark is
sleeping or cannot run
is injured all right and in cash we say
some other error
and inside do we're going to say try dog
dot bark and run
all right so you can see now when we do
that we say we get this catch statement
here that says cannot bark is sleeping
or cannot run is injured because we've
basically caught both of these Earths in
the same Clause all right you can
separate them if you want to just using
separate try statements now if you go
and change these to false you will see
that none of those errors will be thrown
meaning that we will just not see
anything in here basically so we can say
dog just to confirm that this try
statement actually ran its course and
went to the next Lifeline 115 here okay
let's revert them back in here so we
have this example as well
now
now in case you're catching errors in
separate catch statements just know that
only the first Throne error will be
caught all right so in here we caught
both of them but again Swift called this
block not because both these errors
happened but it called this block
because one at least one of these
happened because remember when a
function throws the execution of that
function completely stops so barking
throws an error Swift doesn't even go to
running meaning that this uh this error
will never be thrown therefore only the
bark a function will throw its error
which is right here Swift just
completely stops the execution of this
function and will run I will basically
run its course out of it a step out of
that function this error will be thrown
and then we will come in here okay and
we can actually test that let's copy
this code and paste it in here
and then we're going to go ahead and
separate these catch statements and we
go in here and we say catch first cannot
bark is sleeping and when you say cannot
bark as a sleeping
then we will say catch dog dot uh
running errors cannot run is injured and
we say
cannot run as injured like this
and you'll see now only at the first
error that was thrown will be caught
which is cannot bark as a sleeping even
though and this dog is both injured and
is sleeping but the Run function will
never be caught inside the bark and run
function simply because bark through an
error breaking the entire function call
basically in here okay so that's how you
can actually understand how you can
catch verse and I hope now you know
basically the flow of when errors are
caught and that you shouldn't really
expect to be able to catch multiple
errors at the in the same do statement
basically all right
now let's talk about rethrows I said
that we're probably going to talk about
rethrows but I think it is time and now
to talk about it so when we talk about
rethrows we're talking about a function
that internally calls another function
which can also throw so let me just
share an example let's create a function
here called full name okay and we take
in a first name which is an optional
string and then we say a last name which
is also an optional string and we say
okay we ourselves cannot calculate the
the full name we actually need a
function that can't do that for us
inside this function so this poor little
function can't really do anything it
just takes the first name and last name
and calculates the full name now this ER
is really stupid and I mean it is really
not how you probably want to do your uh
write your sift code but it is just here
for the purpose of demonstration because
if we didn't do a simple function like
this and which looks dumb it would have
to go ahead and create a very
complicated function which indeed is
production ready and you would probably
use it in production code but this is a
little bit easier at least to get into
what rethrows keyword means in Swift so
please just bear bear with me so we say
we have a function that actually does
the calculation we call it calculator it
takes in a string and it takes two
string optional parameters and it is a
throwing function so we say it actually
throws and it returns a string in return
okay and then we just do this then we
create our own function body in here so
all these errors are going to go away
now since this function is going to call
this function it has to do a try right
because this function throws therefore
this function should also throw so then
we say throws
all right and also produces an optional
string then okay we say try calculator
and in here we have to pass the first
name and last name so we say first name
and last name all right so if you look
at this code you will now see okay we're
trying something in here okay and our
function is called uh it's marked as a
throws anyone looking at this function
will think that somewhere inside this
function we're probably throwing a
specific error like we're actually
um have some errors that we know what
they are and we're throwing them perhaps
okay however there is another syntax for
this and it is called rethrows and how
this really works is that it this tells
Swift that this function in itself
doesn't throw anything it is gonna
basically invoke some other functions
that throw all right so we could have
gone in here inside the bark and run
function and say this rethrows okay and
you can see that our code will let's
actually see what happened must take a
throwing function argument and this is
is really good we're seeing this I mean
this is a example and why we actually
didn't mark this as free throws so in
order I mean the error is a little bit
cryptic but what it is telling us really
is that if for a function to be able to
be marked as a rethrows it has to it has
to have an argument that is a closure
which throws and it should call that
argument and since this bar can run
function it doesn't have any argument
that is a closure it doesn't even have
any arguments that it cannot be marked
as rethrows okay and that's what that
error was telling us however this new
function that we have in here has an
argument that throws and we're actually
calling it using try and therefore we
can Mark our function as rethrows and
this tells Swift that this function in
itself is just calling an argument which
is a closure which in itself throws on
her okay so it's just a way of telling
Swift that hey we have a throwing
function in here and we're calling it
and just we re-throw the errors that
this function might eventually produce
okay so let's then go ahead and create
an enum in here and then we say enum
oops enum and name errors
and it's a it conforms to the error
protocol in here and we say case first
name
is invalid and case last name is
invalid all right then we create a
function that can produce a a full name
based on a first name and last name so
we say func Plus
it's an operator then we say first name
is optional string in here then we say
last name as well as an optional string
and we produce a an optional string in
return okay like this and we also can
throw all right
good and you can see we created this
function with first name optional last
name optional and result optional as
well and throws and this function
signature matches this you see optional
string optional string throws at returns
an optional string and the reason we
created this function is simply because
we want to call this function and
instead of the calculator we're going to
pass a reference to this plus operator
in here okay so let's say we want to
ensure that both
um both the first name and last name are
presented so we say guardlet
first name so we ensure that first name
is available and we say in case the
first name
is
empty okay
so the way you should read the statement
is that we say make sure first name is
available and make sure first name is
not empty otherwise this is how I
usually read my card statements okay
make sure something and something
otherwise which is the sales do this
throw name errors first name is invalid
alright so if first name is nil or that
it is empty then we throw this error
then we're going to do something similar
like this then we say guard let last
name ensure last name is present and
that it is not empty otherwise say last
name is invalid so you throw that error
and if everything then goes fine then we
say return and that first name and last
name and you see these variables in here
are not optional anymore and that is
simply because we're doing a card let
okay after gartlett is executed I mean
if last name is nil then you never get
here and that's why Swift knows that if
you did get here and it means that
you've already checked that last name
was not nil therefore the data type for
last name is not an optional string
anymore it is actually a string same
thing with first name it is string and
not an optional string okay
now that we have those we can go ahead
and try to invoke this function right
here which is full name so we go ahead
and say we create a do Block in here and
we say let Foo bar is try get the full
name
and we say first name let's say first
name we say nil last name is nil and for
the calculator we pass a reference to
our plus operator in here okay and then
we say we have to catch some errors in
here so let's say catch and we say name
errors first name is invalid then we say
first name is invalid
then we say cash also namers last name
is invalid last name is invalid like
that and then we will also have a
catch-all block in here we say catch let
err for instance and we say some other
error and that is equal to err okay and
you can also put parenthesis around this
as well but this this is completely
optional I think actually this is a
little bit cleaner to read so now you
can see that we're getting first name is
invalid thrown in here okay and that is
simply because our code just came in
here I was like can I unwrap first name
is there a value in it nope then it
throws this error so it doesn't even go
here and it doesn't it definitely
doesn't go in these cases either okay so
let's change this let's change the first
name to Foo and you will see that your
error will be the other one which is
last name is invalid and then you say
last name is bar then all of a sudden
your function is gonna produce Foo bar
for you okay so let's let's go ahead and
do one more test and in here you can see
that our function which is this operator
is marked as throws but it is still
returning an optional string however
internally it never returns nil it
either throws which is caught by this
guy or not caught by it is covered by
the sky
or it actually returns a valid string so
why is it marked with returning an
optional string
and this is actually a really good good
question it doesn't necessarily have to
be an optional string it is better that
it is not and it still matches inside
this function signature so because this
is a promotion the a strain is not
optional is a promotion of an optional
string so it can always match it but if
the emotion will never match inside a
function signature okay so you can if if
this requires a string you can never use
a function that returns an optional
string you will actually get an error
now or we should get an error there we
go okay so just remember a promotion
will work but a demotion won't and this
is a promotion we're saying that
although you need an optional string
which is at a lower level meaning that
it can be nil but we will always produce
a string which is at a higher level
meaning it's never optional so it is a
promotion a promotion function
signatures in Swift always works okay
good we've now talk about that now let's
also talk about results and results are
also very important to understand
they're kind of related to error
handling so that's why I wanted to name
them and they're usually useful when
you're writing API calls okay so what we
want to achieve in here is to create a
function that is called get previous
positive integer and you will pass an
integer to this function and the res and
the responsibility of this function
we're going to develop is to find the
positive integer right before the
integer that you pass to it as an
argument so if you pass two this
function is going to have to return the
value of one if you pass one this
function has to return zero but what
happens if you pass zero there is no
more positive integer before zero
because the next number if you do a
minus one to Z basically say zero minus
one you are going to end up with minus
one and that's not a positive integer so
you could say well let's just throw an
error and you'd be right you could just
Mark your function as throws but there
is another way of doing that there is
another way of saying that a function
fails but it fails perhaps a little bit
more gracefully it doesn't actually
throw an error but it carries an error
with it okay and this concept is also
available in many other programming
languages you have it in Dart you have
it in Python you have it in Rust so many
other programming languages have this
concept and in some languages it is
called either but in Rust sorry in Swift
it is called results so let's first go
ahead and Define our error so we say
enum integer
integer errors it is an error and then
we say case no positive integer before
this value okay
enum error case did I do something
incorrectly in here it doesn't look like
it formatted it right but this is fine
okay then we create our function we say
func and we say get previous V is
positive integer and we say from int all
right and in here what we need to do we
are not going to say that this function
throws but instead we're going to say
that this returns a result that is
either an integer or an integer error
like in here okay so now all of a sudden
instead of this function just saying I
throw anything you're saying it either
gives you the result or it gives you an
error of this specific type which is a
little bit cleaner to be honest with you
because a throwing function doesn't
necessarily specify or it can't really
specify the type of errors that it
throws so the color the call side to
that function always has to have a
catch-all block in order to understand
okay what error is actually being thrown
by this function but by using a result
you specifically say which Earth you're
gonna throw not really throw but which
Earth you're going to carry with you if
any all right
so let's guard that this integer is more
than zero otherwise we say return a
result that is a failure and its failure
is indeed an integer error you can see
in here that is no positive integer
before this value and the value is this
integer right here okay
so regarding that the ins is more than
uh zero basically because otherwise we
can't minus one all right then after
this we say okay in that case we wanna
in any other case where the integer is
more than zero then we have to return a
successful result and we say return a
result with success and the value is
integer minus one
all right so you see how this function
is structured at the moment okay then we
go ahead and create a create another
function which internally calls this
function
so we call it funk perform get and this
is just to add another layer of
complexity really to our code so that we
don't go ahead and directly call this
function I just want to show you how you
can call this function within another
function okay so we say perform a get
for a value and we say value as an INT
and inside this function we're going to
call the other one get previous value
sorry get previous positive integer from
value and then since this guy returns a
result and if you look at results you
can see just like optional result is an
enumeration meaning that you can switch
on it so let's switch on this guy and we
say in case if we get a success and we
say previous value
all right uh actually success previous
value
maybe not previous value previous
positive yet previous value then we say
previous value is previous value but in
case we get an error we say case failure
and we say error then you can say okay
but this error it is in itself an enum
it is an integer errors enum we already
know that so since it's an enum you can
have another switch within your switch
the first switch is switching on this
result
and since it gets the error which is of
type integer errors with it itself is an
enum then you can have another switch in
here then you say switch error in the
case of no positive integer you put a
let in here and you say this value
then they say no positive integer before
this value all right
so now that we have this extra logic in
here we can go ahead and call our
perform gets function so I'm just going
to copy paste some code in here you can
see first we pass 0 to this function and
let me comment this line out
we first we pass 0 and 0 then count so
that zero comes in here and it's then
passed into this function then it comes
in here and says make sure int is more
than zero oops it's not return the
failure
and then it comes in here into failure
gets the error we switch the error is it
no positive integer before yes it is
indeed and then you get this line
printed to the console no positive
integer before zero and that's correct
okay then we bring this go code back you
can see now it will hit this block and
it says previous value is one all right
because the previous value before 2 is
indeed one so that's short and sweet
about error handling in so if you can
either use throwing functions and
throwing Constructors for instance and
then do and catch and you also looked at
try with a question mark which
optionally tries a function or try with
an exclamation mark we should try to
always avoid actually because it can
crash your application and then at the
end we looked at how result also works
in Swift and how it it goes hand in hand
with error handling in Swift as well
okay
now that we're done with error handling
in Swift let's talk about Collections
and collections is something we've
talked about up to this point a good
maybe five or ten times and the five to
ten times I would say but we haven't
really gone into details about them so
I'm gonna close this playground in here
I'm going to press command n and say
blank in here and let's create a new
playground and we're going to call it
collections all right and ensure that
it's created in your main workspace and
then we say create
and just like normal we say import
foundation and run this playground also
automatically we get rid of our Explorer
here and then we can start talking about
collections so collections as their name
indicates there are a collection of
stuff all right so for instance with
numbers and if you're I mean not if but
since you're already familiar with other
programming languages collections are
also called arrays or dictionaries or
even Json objects for instance if you're
working with simple JavaScript you can
just say
const something is equal to and then you
add your values in here value blah okay
so this is a simple Json JavaScript and
it's some sort of a collection and in
Swift you also have different types of
collections one of them is an array so
you say let's numbers is one two three
four for instance and then you can do
different things with this collection
you can say give me the first value give
me the last value give me the count of
objects in here or you can say numbers
map every element to its minus
counterpart so you can see in here then
let me just bring this over so you can
see we have one key one two three four
then the first element is one last one
is four there are four elements total
and then here we mapped every element
inside this numbers array to its minus
counterpart okay so this is an operator
in here now if you have an array in
Swift you can also mutate it as long as
it is a variable so let's say VAR
mutating numbers and we say 0 1 and 2
and then you can see mutating numbers
append the value of three and then
mutating numbers
insert the value of -1 at the index of
zero okay so index of zero is right here
not that the zero is actually let's
let's just say four five and six instead
okay and then we append the value of
seven and we then insert the value of
three at the index of zero meaning that
the array was four five six but at the
end it will be three four five six seven
you see what happened in here the index
of zero is right here and in the index
of one is right here index of two is
right here because the in index is in
arrays and any collection in pretty much
every program language that I know about
they start at the index of zero they're
called zero based indexes okay
so and apart from doing a pens and
inserts you can also insert a whole
array inside an array so you can say
mutating numbers insert and then you can
say insert the contents of for instance
one and two at the index of zero so
let's see what happens in here
and then right it's not insert it is
actually insert contents off so this API
calls called insert contents off and you
can see the resulting array will be one
two three four five six and seven here
okay you can enumerate over the elements
inside an array by just using a for
statement for Value in numbers so then
you can say a value and print it to the
console and now
um playgrounds have an interesting way
of showing values over time since we're
animating over these values and there
are four of them it can't print them all
in the same line so you have to click
here I believe and it gives you like a
little graph and then you have to right
click on it and you say value history
then you get the values one two three
four otherwise it shows you a graph for
some reason okay and let's somehow
remove this okay there we go so that's
how you would go through values inside
an array okay
you can also enumerate through items
inside an array with pattern matching
using the where Clause so if you want to
for instance grab all the uh all the
even numbers inside this array so
because you saw this printed one two
three and four and one and three are not
even numbers but if you want to grab
only the even numbers you could say four
value in numbers where
value
and we're basically the the result of
dividing the value by 2 should be equal
to zero okay so this is how you would do
your pattern matching if you say value
in here we can do the same thing that we
did earlier and say value history and
then you only get the values of 2 and 4
in here okay so that's how you can have
a where Clause right after your four
statements
now you can also map objects inside an
array and mapping is also very important
because it's one of the most useful
functionalities of collections mapping
means that you take the values inside
that collection and you turn them into
something completely different if you
want to okay so let's say numbers you
map them you see and it says okay I give
you the number so let's say value and in
here you can say I return anything in
this case we've decided to return an
integer and we say value multiplied by
two now you can all of a sudden see that
numbers are 2 4 6 and 8 whereas they
were originally one two three and four
so here you multiply them by by two
however inside map you can't return
anything you can say I actually return a
stream okay and then you turn these into
a string you can string first multiply
them by two but then turn them into a
string now you can see there are strings
so map allows you to map it to anything
all right and now that we're talking
about mapping it to anything you can you
can guess that this map is indeed a
generic function because it allows you
to change the resolved value and if you
look at its signature you can see it in
is it indeed giving you the elements
inside the array but it allows you to
throw to return anything and the result
would be the array of that anything okay
so if I go and say let values you can
see values is an array of um not in this
case but in this case values will be an
array of string okay like this
so values is an array of string right
now and just a note about this at Maps
don't necessarily have to be this
complicated I mean um to me this and
actually we can recommend this syntax
more than I can recommend the next
syntax I'm going to show you and simply
because the more information you give to
the Swift compiler the faster your code
compiles in larger applications but if
you have very simple applications you
don't have to do this much syntax work
in Swift you could literally just say
okay first of all I don't want to give
you I don't want to tell you what return
value I have and Swift still is happy
with that you can also remove this in
here because Swift already knows the
value is an integer okay and this works
as well and you can completely remove
that and instead of value use dollar
zero and that works as well so your code
could pretty much just look like this
but again I mean this does work but it
is it has a very little information
about what that code is actually doing
internally so so a new newbie software
developer may be quite confused by it
and also as I said this is more
information to the compiler which allows
it to compile your complicated codes in
the future a little bit faster as well
okay
apart from mapping arrays you can also
filter them meaning that you want to
grab specific values out of this array
you could say numbers
then you filter and you say you get the
value and you turn and return a Boolean
and for all the objects that have to be
included in the result of this filter
function so you say if the value is
greater than or equal to 3 then it
should be returned from the result and
you can see the result is 3 and 4. okay
so that's how Filter Works you can also
do compact mapping and compact mapping
mapping is similar to map but it returns
an optional and the values that are
returned from this compact map which are
nil will not be included in the results
so it's a compact map is a combination
of map and filter okay so let's have a
look at that we say numbers compact map
and we say we get the value as an
integer and we return a string okay an
optional string remember it should be
optional optionality indicates a
filtering so if it is nil it won't be
included in the resulting array then we
say if Val value is divisible by 2. then
return the string of that value
otherwise return nil so let's break it
down into separate lines it's a little
bit more readable okay so you can now
see the result is at Raf strings that
only includes two and four but it
doesn't include three and one or one and
three basically okay so compact map when
you see it just know that is a is a
combination of map and filter at the
same times
arrays in Swift can also contain the
value of nil so let's say numbers uh
numbers numbers two and it is an array
of optional integers so meaning that it
can contain not just integers but also
nil then you can say one two and then
nil four and five so this is completely
fine all right and then if you say
numbers two dot count you will actually
see it is five
because nil is one of the elements one
of the valid elements inside this array
and if you want to grab all the values
inside this numbers array and that are
not nil then you would say let's not
snails
is equal to numbers 2 filter so you
basically say here's my integer and I
return a Boolean for all the values that
are not known then you could say
um let's say its value its name is value
then we say value shouldn't be nil like
this all right and you can see the
result of this is just one two four five
all right however however
this you will be like okay we've checked
that the values are not nil and we place
them inside this array so this array
should now be an array of integers but
that's not correct because if you look
at this is is still an array of optional
integers so what's happening here is
that though we checked for nail values
but we didn't tell and this so basically
filter doesn't allow you to change the
data type all right you can see it
always returns the same array of the
same element type so if our elements is
optional integer the result of this
function will indeed be integers as well
in order to grab the non-null or not nil
values out of this array and also change
the data type you have to use compact
map all right so
um so you could say in here not Nails is
numbers too and we say compact map and
we say we take the integer
and which is value and we actually
return an optional integer as well and
just return the same value all right if
this value is nil it won't be included
in the result and also it won't
basically change the data type so not
Nils is now not an array of optional
integers okay I know it's complicated
and it's a lot of generic code but it
really requires that you work with these
functions yourself to for it to
basically click
now arrays can also include instances of
the same object multiple times so if you
say numbers three and we say one two one
two you can see that numbers three dot
count is indeed four so it contains four
objects it doesn't check whether there
are unique or not okay arrays can also
they don't necessarily have to include
home homogeneous objects so they can be
heterogeneous meaning that you can have
integers and strings uh mixed up and
Blended up in the same array so let's
say let's stuff one and we say it is an
array of it has an integer of one then
it has hello then it has an integer of
two and has a string up world but this
will give us an error or it should
because it says it is not a homogeneous
array all right and it says it's a
heterogeneous so in order to fix this
you can see Swift is telling you to
actually add as any to the end of this
array and a collection literally could
only be what is the same
as an array of any and I mean this to me
looks fine
uh but I'm sure I'm not sure really what
is the same collation level It could
only be inferred to any add explicit
type annotation
um I believe we've already done that so
I'm not really sure what it is
complaining about let's just say stuff
one and see if Swift has understood what
this code is actually doing
expected separator did I miss a
separator somewhere let's stuff one
to me this looks fine but not sure
really what it is complaining about let
me just bring it in here and then we say
hello let's put all of these in oh
because I've missed a comma in here I
can see
okay sorry about that so I've missed a
comment there so now you can see our
array looks fine and if I say stuff one
count it should include the count of
four in here okay there are four objects
so this is a trick to get your array to
include heterogeneous objects as well
all right so
um we can also go ahead and change the
Syntax for this so if I copy this and
paste it in here and changes the stuff
too and then stuff to account if you
don't want to have this as in here you
can also tell Swift that this is in fact
an array of any by doing this column in
here just specifying the data type right
there okay so that's another way of
actually achieving the same result
now that we've talked enough about
arrays let's talk about uh sets a set is
a special object it's a special
collection that only contains unique
values all right and the way it
calculates uh uniqueness is based on
hash values and equality all right and
this is a little bit complicated a lot
of people think it's just hash value but
it is not it's also equality which is
very important to understand and what
sets so let's create a set we say unique
numbers and then we say it is a set of
the values one two one two and three all
right and then we say unique numbers
count and then unique numbers map them
to their minus values let's just see
what values we get in here you see after
the creation of this set the set only
includes the values of three one and two
so two things are quite interesting
about this is that it removed the
duplicates so both twos were not
included only one instance was included
it and the same thing with the value of
one only one instance was included so
that's one thing that's interesting
about creation of this set or and one of
the properties that's important about
sets it only includes unique numbers and
the other one is that this array that we
just passed to it it's ordering was
completely changed within the set so
sets in Swift cannot guarantee ordering
as you pass the ordering to it so the
ordering could just be mishmashed and
the set will order the items as it
pleases all right
so
sets can also contain Nils so we can go
ahead in here just like arrays so let's
say my numbers is a set of one two three
and nil and five and then we say let's
not nil numbers if we want to get the
not nil numbers then we say it is a set
of my numbers and then we compact map
this guy a compact map and we grab only
the current value you can see in here
compact mapping let's actually break it
down into separate lines
so it is more readable like this and
like this all right so we're just taking
the same values which are inside my
numbers returning returning them from
compact map compact map what it does is
if the values are nailed it removes them
from their result and you can see the
result of compact map inside a set it is
an array of the values and that is the
reason we're putting it inside another
set because we want the return value to
be a set as well all right and then we
say not nil numbers
in here you can see in here we have five
where is it uh two three nil one five
but in in there we have only three two
one and five so nil was removed
essentially by calling compact map on
that sets okay
now you can also create heterogeneous
sets just like you can create
heterogeneous arrays so a set doesn't
necessarily have to only have integers
for instance so the trick to do that is
to create a set of a protocol called any
hashable all right so you say stuff
three for instance and we say this is a
set of any hashable and you can look at
the code for any hash well sorry it's
not a protocol it's a structure and we
say it is equal to uh one two three and
then bounded all right then we can say
stuff three count you will see that
includes four values all right
so this is the trick to create a
heterogeneous sets as well
now if you want to extract specific
items uh like of specific types out of
uh any of these sets or arrays and let's
just focus on the sets right now
actually let's have a look at our stuff
one you can see our stuff one is an
array at the moment and that is an array
of any but if you want to grab specific
objects out of this array which are of
specific types for instance only the
strings or only the integers you can use
a keyword which is called as so let's
say let's ins in stuff one and again
remember stuff one is this array it has
integers and strings and you only want
to grab the integers out of them so then
you could say ins in stuff one is stuff
one and then you compact map all right
remember compact map does map and filter
at the same time then you get your value
which is any and you want to optionally
return an integer then you say value
as ins so you compare the values type to
an integer and optionally return it if
it is integer okay
and then you can see in here that the
result of this is only your integers
and you can do the same thing with
strings so you can say okay let's copy
this and then we say strings in stuff
one and then you get the value and you
optionally return a string and then you
say as long as the data type is a string
I return it okay then you get the hello
world printed in here okay
so if you if you are comfortable doing
this with a race then you're probably
also comfortable doing that with sets
and it is very similar it's actually
compact map on sets as well so let's
copy this code ins in stuff one and then
we say ins in stuff three and remember
stuff three is a set then we go in here
and we say stuff three and we compact
map and the value is any hashable
hashable and then we optionally return
an INT and then we get the result
printed to the screen which is two three
one and you can see one two three van
dot so van dot was essentially removed
from this set but one thing to note
about this is that as I mentioned before
compact mapping on a set doesn't return
a set it actually returns an array so if
you go in here and call type of which is
an internal function in Swift and say
give me the type of ins in stuff three
it will tell you that this hopefully is
did it crash it will tell you it's an
array it's not a set anymore though
stuff 3 was a set uh you can see in here
is a set but the result of compact
mapping is set is an array okay so just
keep that in mind
now now that we talked about sets a
little bit and we talked about that they
can contain the only that they only
contain uh unique objects then the
question is how does it calculate
uniqueness and and the way it does it is
using a protocol called hashable
now hashable a lot of people think that
only thing it does it it contains a some
sort of a hash value is some sort of an
integer value that uniquely identifies
every object but it but hashable
protocol
in itself also includes equality all
right so uh without without actually me
talking too much about that let's have a
look at an example so let's just say we
create a person struct in here
struck person and then we say we have an
ID so every person has an identifier we
have a name of string and then we have
an H of integer as well
okay and then we want this person to be
able to instances of this person to be
able to be included inside sets Okay so
without making and without making this
person hashable let me show you what
will happen if it is not hashable and
you try to create a set out of it so
let's say that we have a foo ID in here
and we say it is a uuid then we say let
Foo is a person
with the ID of Foo ID its name is Foo
and its age is 20. all right then we
create a bar person in here and we say
bar is pretty much similar to Foo and we
say bar but we forget to change the ID
and bar is also using the foo ID its
name is bar and its age is 30. all right
now we want to go ahead and create a set
of Foo and bar so let's say we have
people
and we say it is a set of person and it
is equal to Foo mbar now we should get
an error ideally from Swift telling us
that these objects are not hashable you
can see it says it does not conform to
protocol hashable all right so how do we
do that how do we ensure that they
conform to hashable so let's go ahead
and say that they conform to Hash Rule
and everything will just go fine nothing
will happen in here you won't get any
errors okay and if you go in here and
say people that count
let's go in here okay you will see
unfortunately it is still two so what
happening here we said that well we are
making this person hashable and it
should ideally not be placed twice in
this set because uh it is pretty much
the same but if you look I mean same
data but what happens in here is two
things when you when you create a
structure and you just say it is
hashable without having any custom logic
in it meaning that you didn't actually
tell Swift how to calculate the
uniqueness of this object what Swift
does is that it looks at all the
properties of that object and says okay
are all these properties unique
themselves like are they hashable and if
you look at uuid is indeed hashable if
you look at string it is hashable
uh let's see extension
string hashable
somewhere it should have been made
hashable I'm not sure if it is exactly
there we go extension string hashable
and also if you look at the code for INT
it should also be extension and
hashable there we go so since all these
three are hashable then Swift says okay
I'm gonna calculate the hash value
myself then it says okay you created a
person it has the ID let's just say it's
hash value is one let's say then it says
oh the name is Foo the hash value is for
instance 10. I'm just making this up
okay and the hash value for this guy
let's say is 20. all right then it comes
to bar and says oh it has the same ID as
the other ones which is has a hash value
of one but it's its name is bar so its
hash value is let's just say 30. and the
age is also 30 with a hash value of 40
for instance okay so it says okay then
you put both of these inside a set and
I'm gonna calculate these hashes 20 plus
10 plus one for instance okay this is
not how hashes are actually calculated
but we're just going to plus them
together so 20 10 and 1 are going to be
31 and then we have 40 30 and one which
is going to be 70 a month so at 31 and
71 are not the same meaning that they're
basically not the same object and should
both be placed inside the sets Okay so
that's how hashing basically Works
within Swift okay
but what we may want to do is to tell
Swift that hey we actually don't want
people with the same ID to be recognized
as different people so what we want to
tell Swift is that if two people have
the same ID then they're essentially the
same person okay and in order to give
Swift more information about how it
should do our hashing we should go ahead
and basically implement the hash
functionality somehow ourselves or at
least inject our own logic within it so
let's create a person two object in here
so a person to structure so now that
we've seen that example let's say a
struct person two okay and we're gonna
grab let's actually grab this struct
from here but instead we're just going
to call it person two
so person two in here and we said that
it is hashable now if you make an object
hashable you also have the ability to
override a function in here and not
really override but also Implement
actually a function called hash into all
right and this function comes in here
because we have we've conformed to the
hashable protocol all right then in here
what you can do is to say hasher and
then you combine you call the combine
function on it and then you basically
hash the fields that you want to be
taken into account while Swift does its
hashing so what this really did in here
is that it jumped over hashing name and
age and instead only hashed ID within
the hashing mechanism of Swift all right
so now that you've done that you also
need to tell Swift whether two objects
are Equitable because you've just
implemented your own hashing
functionality
and when you say something is hashable
by default it's also Equitable and what
happens in here is that right now you
set that take ID only into hashing
mechanism but in terms of equation
because hashing is also doing equality
Swift if you don't intervene Swift goes
and it says okay the hash values are the
same but these two objects are not
really equal because by default Swift is
going to also equate all three
properties so in here what we're going
to do is to say static func equality so
we're going to overwrite equality as
well on the left hand side we say self
and the right hand side itself then we
say Boolean and we say as long as the
left hand side's ID is equal to the
right hand size ID then these two
objects are equal so not only have we
changed the way a hashing works but we
also need to change the way equality
Works otherwise they won't really
come to an agreement with each other
okay
now that we have that let's go ahead and
create a baz ID in here and we say it's
a uuid all right
and then we say we create a baz person
in here which is person two remember
create an object of type person two not
person then we say baz ID its name is
bass and then we say it has or he has
the age of 20 or she has the age of 20.
then we create a Cox value in here and
we say q u x and we say person two and
then we say baz ID and the name is Cox
and the age is 30. all right so you can
see now the ID is the same but all the
other values are different however the
way we've done our hashing and equality
is that we only take into account the ID
so even if their names are different but
they're using the same ID then we
consider them to be the same person and
that's why you can go in here it's say
if that's equal to Cox they are equal so
this basically is invoking our equality
and you can see it comes in here okay
but that's not the point that's not what
we're trying to do in here we actually
want to add them to a set so let's say
let lets people people to and we create
a set of bars and Cox in here and if you
look at the values inside people too it
should just be one value
people too that count all right simply
because our hashing intervene in here
and both these objects were considered
to be the same object all right and if
you take the first item out of this you
can get a person person two and then you
can say the first objects uh name give
us the name all right and you can see it
is pass all right so a Cox was not
inserted into our set simply because baz
was already there and Cox was considered
to be the same object therefore it was
not inserted into the set all right so
that's how you can go ahead and
Implement your own hashing value or hash
value and equality all right that's
enough about sets let's talk now about
dictionaries now dictionaries they're
also called Json objects and many other
programming languages like like as such
as um not really Json objects yeah well
kind of Json objects yeah there there
are keys and values basically okay and
you define them using a square bracket
in
um in Swift so you say user info and you
can create your dictionary and then you
say keys are in this case string for
instance with a column and you separate
the keys from the values using a column
and you can say the key is name the
value is Foo this key is H and oops if
we can spell H and its value is 20 then
you can say I have an address field in
here whose value is indeed another
dictionary and you can say the address
has a line one and it is address line
one then we have a postcode for instance
it's key as postcode and its value is
one two three four five let's say all
right and this is completely valid a
swift object if I haven't messed
anything up let's see Foo age address
all right and we also have to tell Swift
that you can see it is a heterogeneous
values because some values are strings
and some values are integers then we
have to tell if there is a dictionary
with keys equal to string and values of
any type all right without that it won't
work
however if you didn't have this age in
here and we didn't have this address in
here we could have just gone away by
defining our dictionary like this as
Swift would have understood the data
type to be of key strings and values of
strings as well but since we have keys
of string and value of integer and a key
of string and a value of a dictionary
then we have to tell Swift that the keys
are string and values could be anything
basically now you can grab values out of
your dictionaries using type using
subscripting so you say user info grab
the name and you can see it will give
you the value of Foo in here you can say
give me the age user info give me the H
so you're basically giving it the keys
and you're extracting the values for
those keys now you can say user info and
then give me the address let's go in
here address
at rest all right and since this is an
address dictionary coming back from here
you may be hoping that okay since this
is an entire dictionary maybe I can type
a key in here as well and get the
postcode all right and if you do this
then you get an error because you've
told Swift that the values that come out
of this uh dictionary are of type any
meaning that Swift Just believes that
this is any and now you're trying to
tell Swift that this is not any and it's
in fact a dictionary and it should go
into that dictionary and x and extract a
value with a specific key and Swift Just
rejects that okay there's a dangerous
way of doing that forcing Swift to
believe that this in itself is a
dictionary and that is using the as
syntax but please don't ever do this in
production applications and there there
are better ways of doing this so I just
want to show you how it works you can
say get the address
and force cast it to a dictionary of
type string and string you can see it
because this has keys of string and
values of type string as well okay
so after doing that uh then you can go
ahead and say give me the postcode on it
all right and this should this should
work but in production applications
really is not a good idea to do this so
let's see what happened actually found
nil one on wrapping optional value and I
think it's because I I misspelled
address basically
so it works but you should never do this
because this will crash your application
should this key Either not exist or that
its value shouldn't be of type string or
string your application will crash so
please don't do this I'm just showing
you so that you know this syntax also
exists okay if you want to extract the
keys and values out of a dictionary you
can say user info dot keys and also you
can say userinfo.values and this will
give these this will give you the keys
only you can see in here let's go in
here the keys are age address name and
the values are 20. let's go here 20. Foo
uh which is let's see where it is
it is 20.
Foo and then this dictionary so you grab
basically only the keys or only the
values out of your dictionary using that
syntax however it is more common that
instead of just saying keys and values
you want to enumerate over the keys and
values and their Associated values you
can because you can see in here we're
only saying keys and only values but
what if you want to grab every key and
its Associated value the Syntax for it
is for key and value
in user info then you can print them out
key and value like this okay let's see
if the playground can help us extract
these values so and the key says name
value history you can see age address
and name are the keys and the values we
can also perhaps get their history let's
see value
it's oh the playground isn't so smart in
being able to print the value so
let's instead print the values and see
if we can get them in the console
uh like this so here are the values
basically okay and you can also print
the keys as well so let's say we print
the keys and we print the value so uh
the key of address has this value the
key of name has this full value and the
key of H has the value of 20. all right
so we can do that as well let's just
revert them back to how they work okay
now you can also have a where clause in
your enumeration over keys and values so
let's say four key and value in user
info where the value is an integer okay
and then you can say key and value
so you see the only value that was an
integer had the key of H and it the
value was of course the value of 20. all
right now you can also have
multiple word Clauses so you're not
limited to only one where Clause so you
can say four key and value and use for
info were
the value is an INT and a key that
counts so the key is a string and we're
saying it should contain only two uh
more than two characters then we say
give us the key and the value all right
so the count is pretty much the length
of the of the key
and then you can see that we got the
same result because age is three letters
long and are conditions that it should
be more than two but if in here we said
more than three then this will never be
cost so we won't get any results in here
okay so I think that's actually quite
enough right now about collections we
talked about arrays we talked about sets
and we talked about also dictionaries
and some new formats and pattern
matchings that you can do with these
collections they're very very useful and
I think you need to really get and get
quite handy with these objects
yourselves and in order to get a good
grasp of how they work I can just sit
here and explain these for ages but
without practice and probably it will
never really click so my advice is to go
ahead and create some sets arrays and
dictionaries yourselves to get a good
grasp of how they work
now that we talked about collections it
is good time that we start talking about
equality and hashing as well I mean we
did touch upon this topic a little bit
right now but we haven't fully covered
them equality and hashing they're like
their own whole world of understanding
how they truly work and basically
understanding them is the key to
understanding how sets for instance work
and how equation generally in Swift
works and so I think it's very important
that we dedicate it's
um a whole section just to equality and
hashing so and that's what we're gonna
do right now so I'll see you there let's
then go ahead and create a separate
playground for this so we say
um blank and foreground sorry playground
and we say equality
and hashing like this and ensure that
you're creating it in The Roots folder
like this and then we just say create
and we import Foundation
and we can get rid of the Explorer to
the left hand side now equality in Swift
is provided using a protocol called
e-codable any object that conforms to
the equilible protocol has to have a
function a static function and which is
an equality function like this is pretty
much an operator and this function has
to have two arguments one at left hand
side and right hand side both of the
same exact type as the current
structural class implementing it
now if you go ahead and create a person
structure in here and say that this
person is conforming to the equatable
protocol and you say let's ID is a
string and then you say let's name is a
string
then we create two instances of this we
say let's Foo one is a person with the
ID of one all right and then we say name
here is Foo then we create food too
right here and we say the name is
actually bar then if you say if Fu one
Foo one is equal to Food 2 then we say
they are equal with an exclamation mark
in here because they shouldn't be they
are not equal otherwise okay so what
happens in here is that by ensuring that
this person is Equitable all right let's
also make sure that this is running
automatically by conforming the struct a
person to Equitable as Swift goes in
through all the properties of the
structure and ensures that they are
indeed themselves Equitable string by
default conforms to the Equitable
protocol and so does this one so then
Swift says okay then I understand that
it should be Equitable however if you go
in here and say a struck dog and don't
make it Equitable and in hear you say
this person should also have a dog all
of a sudden Swift will throw an error in
here saying that oh I can't give you
equal Equitable by default because dog
which is one of the properties of this
person's structure does not conform to
Equitable if you want to get rid of this
just ensure that this dog is also
Equitable which then gets rid of the
problem in here but the only problem we
have in here that is that we need to
pass a dog instance in here but we're
gonna remove all this dog reference in
here just wanted to show you how default
implementation of Equitable basically
works it looks at all the properties and
then make sure that they're Equitable
and then goes through all of them one by
one compares the properties between
these two objects that we're comparing
okay
now you can also override equality and
uh you can basically say let's say that
you in your person uh structure you want
to say any two persons that have the
same identifier should be considered
equal so then you can say extension
person
and you can see at the moment these two
objects right now before our extension
they're marked as not equal all right
simply because their names are not equal
but if you go to extension person and
then Define the static function equal
equal like this and you say left hand
side itself
like this and right hand side itself as
well and this function should return a
Boolean indicating whether the two
objects are equal or not then we say if
the left hand side's ID is equal to
right hand size ID then these two should
be considered equal now all of a sudden
you see that this will be flipped to
they are equal
previously before this extension this
branch of code was being executed
because by default there were not equal
since they had different names however
with our extension in place since we're
only comparing the IDS then they're
marked as equal so if you comment your
code out you can see all of a sudden
that this Branch will stop being
executed and instead this Branch will
get executed all right
so that's how you can create your own
equality on custom objects so we can
comment this guy out
apart from structures you can also
Implement custom equality on
enumerations let's say that we have an
enum in here we call animal type and we
have a case where a dog and we ask for
the breed and also we have a cat and we
ask for the breed okay now let's say
that you want to compare these
um to with each other if you go ahead
and say let's dog and say is an animal
with a type of dog with its breed is a
labradoodle and then you say let's
whiskers is an animal
type another dog basically exactly of
the same type then if you go ahead and
say if dog equal to whiskers let's just
change this to maybe dog two
dog one and Dot two and then we say if
dog one equal to dog two like this you
can see that you get an air from Swift
because by default animal type is not
Equitable you can go ahead in here and
say okay well I'll make it Equitable
does this work you'll be surprised to
see that actually my default what Swift
does is it looks at these values and
says let me let's put some values in
here and say they are equal
like this otherwise we say else they are
not equal all right so since dogmon and
dog 2 we actually are giving them the
same values in here then suit by default
says oh they're equal but if you change
the value inside this breed for instance
then Swift says they're not equal so
Swift does the same thing that it does
with structures as it does with enums it
goes through all the properties of those
enum cases and then make sure that
they're Equitable if they are it will
just call the equation function on those
parameters as well and Compares them
with each other if all those they're
equal to each other and the case is
equal to the other case as well then the
enum cases are marked as equal however
you can go ahead and change this
implementation so you can say extension
extension animal type and let's just
remove the Equitable from here and we
say animal type becomes Equitable in
this extension all right
and then we go ahead and Implement a an
extension and sorry the static Funk left
hand side itself and right hand side
itself as well and then in here we say
bull all right so now what we want to do
in here is to compare the breeds with
each other so we say we switch the left
hand side and the right hand side then
we say in case and we have a dog with
the left hand side breed and another dog
with their right hand side breed
then they're considered equal as long as
the left hand side breed is equal to
right hand side breed we do the same
thing for cats so we say if we get a cat
in here and a cat in here then they're
equal to each other as long as their
breeds are equal and since this pattern
matching is the exact same thing between
dog and cat you can see they're getting
left hand side breed right hand side
Bree and the same thing in here you can
remove this coating here and just put a
comma and remove this case as well all
right so they're basically doing the
same thing
and then you can go ahead and say
anything else they're considered not
equal to each other okay so as long as
it's a dog and a dog and their breeds
are the same then it's considered to be
the same and if it's a cat and a cat
then they're considered to be the same
as well
so let's see what we got and we got this
oh we have to return this of course we
can't just write that statement in the
playground good then we can go ahead and
um basically we've now created an animal
type let's go ahead and create an animal
now so we say it's struct
and we say animal animal in here animal
and we said let's name is a strain
and then we say let's type is an animal
type okay and since both string and
animal type by this point are Equitable
you can make this animal also conform to
Equitable all right however what we want
to do is to say okay the animal equality
has to only look at the animal type we
don't want it to look at the animal name
that is the default behavior that Swift
looks at all the properties but in this
case we just want to look at the animal
type all right so let's say that then we
override the static oops static Funk
equal equal and we say left hand side
itself and right hand side itself as
well and we return a Boolean okay and we
only look at the types so we say left
hand side type should be equal to right
hand side type otherwise they're not
equal okay
then we can go ahead and say let cat one
is an animal and its name is whiskers
like this all right and it's animal type
is actually a cat then we say it is a
cat of type Street gap of the breed
Street cow okay let's put that in here
and this is also a shorthand of writing
um the animal types instead of saying
animal type in here you can just say dot
cat so instead of doing this you can
just do the shorthand and so it will
understand the code anyways let's copy
this code and then we say cats number
two and its name is whoosh okay just
like that and it's also a straight cap
so looking at our equality functionality
in here we only look at Types on animal
in order to to determine if they're
equal to each other or not so then we
should be able to go and say if cat1 is
equal to cat2 they are equal because of
their breed actually type because of
their type
else and they are not equal all right
and you can see that this branch of the
code is being executed simply because
our equality custom equality on animal
only compares the animal types and since
they have the exact same type of cat and
Street cat then our code works and you
you can actually go and remove this
implementation on animal type because
this pretty much is the same thing that
Swift provides Equitable and you can see
the code will be executed just like
before so no difference really so it's
up to you if you want to do custom
implementation of Equitable or you want
to let Swift deduce this on its own if
Swift can already deduce this on its own
which it can you shouldn't really go and
write an exact same implementation so
this this is pretty much just redundant
but if your custom implementation of
Equitable adds some functionality to how
swift does it by default then please go
ahead and add your own Equitable to your
custom types okay so we can now we've
had a look at Equitable let's look add a
hashable and we've already talked about
this a little bit before but let's just
talk a little bit more in details about
it just like Equitable hashable also
looks at all properties of a struct or a
class to make that start or class
hashable so if you say struct house and
we make it hashable then we say let's
number is int and we say let number of
bedrooms
is an INT then we say let house one is
house with the number of one two three
and number of bedrooms is let's say two
all right and then we say house one and
you can see now you have a property in
here called hash value and that is
coming from the hashable protocol in
here
then we go ahead and create another
house we call it house number two in
here okay house two and its number is
one two three but it's number of
bedrooms is three and then we print out
its hash value in here as well now you
can see these hash values are different
simply means that they basically if you
create a set with house one and house
two they can occupy their own space and
not overwrite each other however if you
go in here and say number of bedroom and
bedrooms is two then you should ideally
in here see the exact same hash value
meaning that you cannot put both houses
inside the same set and expect them both
to basically appear in the set one is
going to overwrite the other one okay so
if we go ahead and create a setting here
we say let houses is a set of house one
and house two and please note that I
changed this back so it's now number of
bedrooms two and this one is three then
if we say houses dot count then you can
see we get two in here because none is
overwriting the other one
let's see if the playground is going to
be able to update soon hopefully
even if it doesn't show the count we can
still see in here that we have one house
in here and another one here and now the
count is also being displayed right
there okay really good you can overwrite
the uh how hashing of course Works we've
already had a look at this and when we
talk about collections but let's have a
look at another example so we say a
struct numbered house okay and we say it
is hashable
like this and we say let's number is int
and then we say let's number of
uh bedrooms is an end and this is pretty
much the copy of the house structure but
we had to give it another name and
because you can't have two structures
with the same name in the same code
scope in Swift okay then in here we're
going to go and overwrite this a hashing
mechanism so we say hash into and we say
we only want to combine the number into
the hasher so we say combine the number
and this simply means that as long as
two houses have the same number then
they're at the same house pretty much
when it comes to their hash values okay
however this doesn't mean that they're
equal you have to override equality as
well so say static Funk equal and we say
on the left hand side we get self and
the right hand side we get cell self as
well
then we say this returns a Boolean and
then we say as long as the numbers so we
say left hand side number is should be
equal to right hand sign number and then
both houses are considered to be equal
to each other in that case Okay so let's
create let house three and please make
sure you create a numbered housing here
not a house it's house number we say one
two three and number of bedrooms is two
okay so as a house number one two three
then we create another house we call it
house four in here okay like that
and then we say it is a numbered house
and the exact same number as this house
however it has three bedrooms okay then
we create a set of these we say houses
at three and four it is a set of house
three and house four and then if you
look at houses three and four count you
can see there's only one object inside
this set simply because house three and
four they can only consume the same
space in our sets and simply because
their hash value is the same you can see
in here and let's see if playground is
going to be able to update our codes
hopefully soon if I close this one maybe
it's just gone crazy a little bit
let's say automatically run
hopefully it can run the code so you can
see there's only one value in here and
if you say houses three and four get the
first item then it gives us a numbered
house and then we can say get its house
number bedrooms and it says the number
of bedrooms is two and the reason behind
this is that house Ford could not be
placed in the set simply because there
was a house already in the set with the
same hash value and you can also look at
the house at three hash value and house
for hash values and they should pretty
much be the same simply because the
hashing algorithm is only taking the
house number into account so you can say
house three
house three number dot hash value and it
should pretty much be unique
as well and you can see they're exactly
the same thing okay and house for that
number hash value there the same as the
entire hash value of the house okay
another example now EMS are by default
hashable even without raw values so I'll
show you in here we say enum car part
car parts like this and we say case a
roof uh case tire and case trunk
then in here we say let's unique Parts
is a set of car parts okay
and it's equal to a set that contains a
roof
it contains Tire
it contains another roof and then a
trunk so since this is a set of car
parts and it doesn't have any raw values
like we're not doing it like this
so they don't have raw values if you in
here say unique part oh actually we can
see the value already here you can see
it only contains trunk roof and tire so
it doesn't contain two roofs that's what
I'm trying to get to so if you create a
simple enum in Swift without any raw
values or any Associated values it's by
default hashable and Equitable all right
that is the whole point now if you have
an enum with
um with Associated values then you can
basically go ahead and change the
hashing mechanism yourself so let's say
that we have an enum in here we call it
house type and it has a big house and we
say its Associated value is a numbered
house and we say case small house it is
a numbered house
like this and then you can go ahead in
here and say this is hashable all right
so as you do that Swift looks at the
properties that are inside this enum and
it understands that oh this big house is
of course hashable because it's an inum
case however it has an Associated value
then it looks at the associated value
and says is this value hashable then it
goes to numbered house and it says yep
it is hashable then it implements
hashable by default for you on this
house type okay so then you can go ahead
and basically add these into some sort
of a set so let's go ahead and we say we
create two big houses we say big house
number one is a house type
big house like this and it has a
numbered house inside it like this all
right and this number it has has a few
properties it has a number and we say
number one and it is number of bedrooms
is one as well so we have a big house
and that's number one in that street for
instance and it has one bedroom for some
reason a big house with one bedroom only
then we say a big house number two in
here okay let's get rid of this Bottom
bar then we say it is also a big house
at number one and total number of
bedrooms is one on that one as well then
we create a small house so we say small
house one and like this small house one
it is a small house house and we say it
is at number one as well and it's number
of bedrooms is one all right so now we
have three houses with the same number
and two of them are actually the same
house type as well so what's going to
happen if we go and put these inside a
set so we say all houses is a set of
house type
and is equal to a set with a big house
big house one big house two and small
house one all right
so if you say all houses the count in
here then let's see if the playground
can resolve this you can see there's
only two objects in here the reason is
that big house one and Big House 2 are
considered to have the same hash value
simply because that their numbered
houses have the same hash value and
their cases have the same hash value
however small house one is of type small
house not big house though it's numbered
house has the same hash value as the
other numbered houses however the enum
case itself also has a hash hash value
therefore in here you can see if I say
all houses first and all houses actually
let's see if you can get the values
inside the sets like this you can see we
have a let's see oh you can see the
first one is a big house at number one
and if we say all houses last uh let's
see if you can get the first does it
have a last item no it doesn't we can
get the first unfortunately and let's
just say four value in all houses and
then we type the value out in here let's
maybe even print the value like this
so you will see then the first elements
inside all houses is a numbered house is
a small house with that numbered house
and the second one is a big house
meaning that the two big houses couldn't
actually occupy two separate spaces in
the set simply because their hash values
are the same okay so I think that's
actually enough right now about equality
and hashing we've talked quite a lot
about them right now and I think you get
basically the idea so there's two
different things you have to implement
or think about when it comes to equality
hashing one is the hash of value which
determines whether two objects should
consume the same space inside a set but
also you have to implement equality
which determines whether two objects are
actually equal to each other okay and
also you may sometimes just need objects
to be Equitable not hashable in in which
case you can just implement it Equitable
protocol or conform to the Equitable
protocol as long as all the properties
inside your structural class are
equatable then you don't have to
implement a custom equality static
function however you can always go ahead
and change the default implementation of
both hashable and Equitable as well all
right now we're done with equality and
hashing so let's start talking about
custom operators I'm going to close this
playground in here so let's create a new
one a blank playground
like this and then we call this one
custom operators all right and we create
the playground
then we say import Foundation like that
and then we can get rid of the Explorer
to the left hand side
like this and we can run our playground
automatically now we've talked about
operators to this point uh quite a bit
actually but we haven't talked about
creating so many custom operators and
that's what we're going to do in this
section of the code so let's say that
you have a first name and which is a
string optional string and you say it is
actually equal to Foo though it is set
as being the optional string and then
you create a last name in here and then
you say bar now if you want to get the
full name and you say it should be equal
to first name plus last name you'll see
that you get an error from Swift saying
that this operator it is not defined
between you can see there is no operator
that exists that matches this particular
signature left hand side optional string
and right hand slide optional string if
these were not optional strings then you
would have this operator you can see
that the error goes away let's see if we
can get the definition actually for this
one A Plus operator I don't think we can
unfortunately let's see a static Funk
Plus
here we go there is that function
signature all right however the Swift
Foundation framework hasn't defined the
same operator for optional strings so we
can actually go ahead and do that
ourselves so let's say we have a funk
plus and its left hand side is an
optional string and its right hand side
is an optional string as well and it
returns an optional string okay then we
go inside the function implementation
and we switch the left hand side and the
right hand side if they are both none
meaning that they're both null then we
return nil or actually not null but nil
Swift is one language that is chosen to
use nil instead of null then we say okay
if then we get the left hand side so if
we say case let we have some value on
the left hand side
but no values to the right hand side
then we return the value to the left
hand side so if you only have the first
name but not the last name then we
return the first name as the full name
we do the opposite of this for last name
as well so if the first name is is nil
but the right hand side has the value
meaning that there is a is a family name
then we say return that value all right
and we can join these two together like
this
because they have the same pattern okay
and then we say if both of them have a
value so we say sum left hand side and
some if I can spell some right hand side
then we say return the left hand side
plus the right hand side okay as soon as
you're done writing this function you
can see all of a sudden the errors go
away and all of a sudden full name is
indeed equal to Foo bar all right so
um we can also add a space in here
perhaps or add a space before bar so it
becomes Foo plus bar right here okay
so that's how you can create a simple
custom operator in Swift okay and I
think we've actually looked at something
similar to this before maybe even
something more complicated all right now
we haven't yet created our own unary
prefix operator this one was a binary in
fix operator because it works with two
or binary and things two things
therefore binary so this is a binary in
fix it is binary because it works with
two operators and sorry with two
parameters and it's an infix operator
because it says in between two values
okay
however we haven't looked at unary
prefix operators so let's create a unary
prefix operator let's have a look at an
example let's say that we have a
lowercase naming here which is equal to
foobar and we want to turn it into
uppercase Name by saying lowercase name
uppercase like this and this operator
doesn't exist at the moment so you can
see it is we want to say unary unary
prefix it is unary because it only works
with one argument to its left hand side
and that's why it is called prefix
because it is it basically works with
some actually no that is a that is a
suffix I would say that we need to move
this here okay so this is a unary prefix
because it operate cases whatever it
comes to its right hand side so prefix
because it is previous to the argument
to its right hand side okay
so what we can do then is to go ahead
and implement this operator but before
doing that since it is not an infix
operator you actually have to Swift you
have to tell Swift that it is a prefix
operator so you do that by saying prefix
operator it like this so you first tell
Swift that this is a prefix operator
then you go ahead and Define a function
for it so you say prefix func like this
oopsie lazy
all right and then we work with a value
of type screen and we return a value of
type string then we take the value and
we say uppercased oopsie Daisy uppercase
like that now all of a sudden you can
see that this error will go away and our
Foo BAR value will turn into Foo bar as
uppercase okay so that that is how you
do a prefix operator
in Swift you have to first Define it as
a prefix operator then you create the
function for it similar to this we can
also create a unary postfix operators so
let's say that we have for instance
um a name here which is fool bar and we
want to turn it into a star star star
Fubar star star star like that okay so
whatever string we give our operator we
wanted to prefix it with three stars and
a space and then a space and three stars
after it okay so we say left with stars
is equal to lowercase name and then make
sure you start it out so meanwhon a
unary post fix operator it is unary
because it works only with one object to
its left hand side and therefore it's
called post fix because it comes after
the element that it works with so let's
define it we say postfix operator star
and then we say postfix func star it
takes a value of type string and it
returns a string as well and what it
does is that it just says star star
space value star star star okay and then
you can see the value printed here will
then be star star Fubar space star star
okay
so you can also Define your own custom
binary infix operators on completely
unrelated types so it what we've looked
at so far is that every time you work
with a binary infix operators both left
hand side and right hand side were of
the same type however what happens if
you have for instance a struct in here
let's say we have a struct
of person and we say let name is a
string and then you have a struct family
and then you say let members is an array
of persons okay then you go ahead and
you say that you for instance have a mom
let's mom is person with the name of mom
then we create a dad in here Dad we say
that and then we say Sun
sun is Sun like that then we create
dollars so we say daughter one and his
daughter one and daughter two all right
now what we want to do in here is to say
and we want to create a family we say
family
like this is Mom plus dad so Mom and Dad
create a family together however this
operator at the moment is not defined
Swift doesn't understand what plus
between two persons means so we can go
ahead and actually Define that so we say
we have a function in here we say funk
Plus on the left hand side we take a
person you see a person and right hand
side another person so we say a
left-hand side person
and we say right hand side person I can
understand that we said left hand side
and right hand side are probably going
to be different types and we've so far
created binary infix operators with the
same types for both parameters and we're
going to do something different now so
you're probably asking yourself so why
aren't we doing something different but
before we do that different thing that
we're going to do we have to first
implement this function you'll see soon
okay so we first say if you create if
you add two persons together we create a
family all right then in here we say we
create a family with members equal to
this let's create these in separate
lines like that
the members are at the left hand side
and the right hand side okay now all of
a sudden you can see this error will go
away and then you get a family in here
okay
so that's one thing now what happens if
you then go ahead and say for instance
family
with sun is equal to family plus some
hmm does this work no it won't because
the left hand side of this operator is a
family and the right hand side is a
person and what we've defined is plus
between two persons not a family and a
person so what we're going to do is to
go ahead and say func Plus on the LA on
the left hand side we're going to take
in and we're going to take in a family
all right so we're gonna say on the left
hand side we have family and the right
hand side we have a person and this
returns also a new family then we go
ahead and we say we take the current
families members family members then we
append to it the current uh the person
to the right hand side
then we create a new family and return
it with the given members like this all
right
and then you can then see that this
error will also go away so you can say
family dot members
dot count and then in here you say
family with sun members.com which should
be one more than this family you can see
it's three okay now what if you want to
say family with daughters so let's say
family
with daughters and then you say okay
take the family with the son and then
add a whole array of daughters to this
so you say daughter one and daughter two
or S sorry not an array of daughters but
an array of person you'll get an error
now because we still don't have an
operator that can work on a an object on
the left hand side of type family and an
object on the right hand side of type an
array of person but we can go ahead and
Define that okay so we can say func Plus
on the left hand side we take a family
and the right hand side we take an array
of persons and this guy returns a family
all right so the way to do it is to say
VAR members again members
equal to left hand side members then we
say members
birth append contents of the right hand
side okay and then we return a family a
new family with the new members
like this all right so now you can see
this error will also go away and if you
say family with daughters dot members
dot count then you should get the value
of five printed to the console in here
okay so you can see how easy it is to
rationalize about how operators should
work in Swift they're just simple
functions except for unaryfx and urinary
postfix which you have to also create
these operator
um tags kind of or declarations so this
is the implementation of the operator
and this is the Declaration of the
operator okay so I think that is
actually quite enough right now about
custom operators in the next section
we're going to talk about some of the
new features uh inside Swift
for a basically concurrency and
asynchronous Swift and that is going to
be the last section for this course and
so without further Ado let's just get
started with it I'm going to close this
tab in here and then I'm going to create
a new playground and then let's say
playground
and we call it async Swift all right and
we just say we want to import foundation
and here is one of the exceptions where
we have to import three things we say
import also playground support and then
we import
import concurrency concurrency like this
and we're doing this playground support
here simply because asynchronous code
requires that our playground is active
all the time and it doesn't just start
from the beginning and ends and when the
when it encounters the end of the file
we just need the playground to stay
alive simply because concurrent code and
and asynchronous code requires that kind
of behavior because if you make an API
call that takes three seconds to finish
maybe before that API call is done your
playground has already reached its and
it just terminates and you don't want
that so let's go and say playground
support sir playground page at dot
currents page and then we say needs
indefinite execution equal to true so if
you're running your code on a Macintosh
in xcode then you have to do this but if
you're on Windows or Linux and you're in
Visual Studio code I'm just running your
code using simple Swift then you
shouldn't really do this you should
perhaps just create a simple project
that can have a main Loop and then you
can then execute your code inside that
main Loop That Never Ends okay and
however if you're in a playground then
you will need to do this on Mac OS all
right
now let's say that we want to create a
simple asynchronous function in Swift if
you're already familiar with dart for
instance for flutter or python or rust
you probably have already used Tokyo
perhaps in rust or in Dart you also have
Futures and stream stream controllers
you're probably already familiar with
asynchronous code but if you're not I'll
just quickly brief you on what it means
it means if you have an asynchronous
function it will not immediately return
its result it can take any number of
seconds or milliseconds to complete its
work and return some value and perhaps
it won't even return a valuesome
asynchronous functions don't return a
value okay so let's go ahead and create
a simple dummy function in here which we
call calculate full name so we say funk
calculate full name all right then we
say we have a first name first name is
string and then we have a last name
which is a string then we say it is an
async function which returns a string
okay so by creating this asynchronous
function in here you'll have the ability
to basically delay the return of your
results so you can in here just say
return hello you could definitely do
that but that's not the point of async
functions this is asynchronous function
not an asynchronous function a
synchronous function returns this value
immediately and asynchronous function
might take some time before it returns
its value so let's go ahead and say we
try to await on a task by sleeping for
the duration of one second so this is
how you would create a delay a fake
delay in your function all right and
we're using the try with question mark
syntax in here because we're not
throwing okay if this function throws
then we didn't have to do that
however we're saying that our function
is an async function that doesn't throw
let's also Mark our playground as
automatically running
so we say try and we say await and let's
say cannot convert return expression
okay and here then we can say return
after waiting one second return the
first name with the space and the last
name as the result of this function all
right that error is now going to go away
now inside your playground if you want
to call this asynchronous asynchronous
function you have to create a task and
then you can say let result 1 is equal
to a weight on the result of calculating
the full name the full name comes from
the values of Foo and Bar in here okay
and you can see the result is actually
Foo bar all right it waited before it
calculated the value for us then we can
also go ahead I mean you can see in here
we have let result equal to a weight but
there is another syntax word in Swift
which is called async let and you can
say async let result 2 is calculate and
so you can see how async is before the
let and then we say take Foo bar again
as the values and in here if you want to
if you want to wait for the result of
this you have to await on it so you say
a way to resolve to now asynclet is a
little bit more special because it
creates a child task as part of this
task you can read about it in Swift
Evolution on GitHub and so I won't go
too much into it but it is kind of
similar to this guy uh but it has a
little bit difference in like how you
await on it because some developers
think maybe that oh this by default
awaits on this but it doesn't okay you
have to wait on the result yourself
manually okay so that's how you can
create a simple task in asynchronous
task and then do some async and a weight
code inside it in Swift
now we can go ahead and put together
maybe an example that talks about async
and async let's and tasks all together
just to make it stick a little bit more
okay so let's say we create a cloth enum
in here and we say we have case socks we
have shirts and trousers all right then
let's create some asynchronous functions
in here so we say the first function
that we have is called buy socks all
right and it is an async function that
throws and we say it returns a clove and
what it does is it says try a weight
on a task by sleeping for a duration of
one second and the reason this function
throws is that we're not doing try like
this if we did try with a question mark
we didn't have to throw okay but we're
doing just normal try therefore the
function has to throw or it has to be
inside I do but what we're indicating to
the outside world by writing this
function and seeing that this function
is an asynchronous function that can
internally actually throw an error so be
careful while consuming its value all
right then we return a close of type
socks so after one second we produce an
item of clothing
after doing this one we can go ahead and
create another function which is called
by shirt like this and it produces an
item of clothing and ins in here we just
say shirt all right and we can create
another one that produces a item of
trousers so we say trousers and it says
dot trousers all right so they're very
similar to each other they just return a
different result of them now you want to
create a structure in here that is an
ensemble an ensemble is a you can say it
is a collection of clothing clothes
items and you can say struct Ensemble
all right and then we say this guy has
clothes in it and we say it is an array
of clothes and it has a total price
price of type double all right doesn't
really matter what the currency for the
prices we also want this Ensemble to be
printable to the console in a very nice
format so we can form it to custom debug
string convertible protocol and
therefore we have to implement a new
variable here called debug description
like this we make it a computed property
and then we say clothes equal to clothes
and we say price is equal to total price
so the value that you're producing here
will then be printed to the debug
console whenever you try to debug an
instance of this Ensemble structure okay
now we create a function in here called
by whole ensemble
like this and we say it it's an async
function that throws and it produces an
ensemble in here okay then we should go
ahead and buy all our uh parts so we say
async LED socks is buy socks async let
shirt is by shirt and async lets
trousers is by trousers all right so
since all these are async let's then we
need to await on them and also we should
also sorry not also also twice now
became four times
so what we want to do is to go and
create an ensemble so we say let's
Ensemble on uh symbol is an instance of
Ensemble and it says okay give me the
clothes and you probably think okay I'm
just gonna give it socks shirt and
trousers but you can't do that because
these are async let's items you have to
await on them so just type a weight and
then we go ahead in here we say socks a
shirt trousers but since these guys are
also throwing functions you have to try
them okay so you say try try try
and then for the total price we're gonna
say the total price is 200 okay
there we go and then we can return The
Ensemble like this now all these errors
are hopefully gonna go away so there we
go
now you can to test this you create a
task in your playground and then you can
say a flat
Ensemble is equal to try a weight on buy
hola Ensemble then you can say Ensemble
is this otherwise something went wrong
like that all right and then you can see
our Ensemble debug description will be
printed to the screen says clothes are
this let's see if you can get the entire
clothes maybe we could print it even so
print
it's a little bit easier perhaps to read
it here
there we go so it says is a shirt it's a
socks trousers and also the price is 200
dollars let's say okay now async lab can
only be used within asynchronous
closures and asynchronous functions or
wherever there is a task being run so
you cannot use asynchronous async let
within uh anything that is not one of
the ones that I just described so it
should be an asynchronous closure an
asynchronous function or wherever there
is a task that you have such as in here
okay so let's let's have a look at a few
examples we go in here and we just say
funk get full name and we ask for a
delay a fake delay and we say it's of
type duration and we say we have a
calculator for
what we calculate like how we calculate
the full name and it is an async
function that returns a string
in here and then we say it is async
function add it in itself returns a
string so our job is just to try to
await on this uh task sleep for this
delay and then we return and we want to
return the result of this function but
it is an async function so we have to
await on it so we say wait on the
calculator like this all right and then
you can see all these errors are then
going to go away and then we have our
print statement in here let's just
remove it so that we don't get this
print in the console all right
now that we have that we can go ahead
and actually say we have a funk and we
call it full name and we say it's an
async function which is an error
function and we just for now just we say
Foo bar all right so it is an async
function but right now it just returns
asynchronous result back to us full name
like this then we can create a task and
we can say await on get full name and we
say uh let's break these down and then
we say the delay is in delay in seconds
one and its calculator is indeed uh
let's actually see for the calculator
let's create a a trail enclosure in here
then we say async let name is full name
and then we can say return awaits name
all right so let's see if we get the
results printed to the screen now you
can see Fubar then being printed to the
screen so we could use async let simply
because we're in a an async trailing
closure okay and also we've been able to
use asynclet in other contexts such as
here which we're in an async function
all right so
I mean there's a lot more actually to
talk about when it comes to asynchronous
programming with swift but this just
gives you an idea of the basics of
asynchronous programs very similar to
JavaScript and typescript and you could
also say it's very similar to actually
Dart for instance for those of you who
do flutter development it's a little bit
more complicated because well it is
Swift it has a long history of its own
code base and there are a lot of people
contributing to Swift as a programmable
language not even just people just
inside Apple so it is somehow a mishmash
of everything the community thought was
a good idea to add to Swift I personally
don't like for instance async let I
think it makes things more complicated
almost every other program language that
has asynchronous programming such as
JavaScript typescript and dart don't
need async lab they just do async and a
weight and everything works as expected
I think async lab adds a new layer of
complexity to your code which is
unnecessary
some people may argue that it is
actually nice but I personally don't
like it so much but that's just my
opinion and I think it although I don't
like it so much I learn it and I think
it is important that we all learn how to
use these syntaxes that are available in
modern Swift so with that said I think
we can then conclude this particular
video of the full stack with swift
course and we've talked a lot about you
can see we have so many playgrounds in
here I can't even count but we talk
about variables operators classes
expenses generics pretty much everything
that you can think of in Swift so now
what we're gonna do in the course is to
go ahead and start talking about client
development and also back-end
development with Swift I really hope
that you enjoyed this video if you found
it helpful please press the thanks
button at the bottom of the screen or
you can just alternatively join my
YouTube channel so see you in the next
video